Oh, bin ich müde.
So.
Ist schon jemand da? Ich vermute nicht.
Lass mich mal auf Twitch gucken. Nö.
Ich hab einen Zuschauer und das bin ich
mit meinem Vorschau-Rechner.
Lul. Omega.
Lul. Oh, doch, jetzt. Jetzt kommen die Leute.
Moin. Pepo, hey.
Oh.
Ich war seit einer Woche nicht mehr on,
ungefähr.
Hab ich gesehen.
Ja.
Benachrichtigung ist wirklich mal on point. Normalerweise dauert es
dann teilweise bis zu 10 Minuten, bis das rausgeht.
Oh, ja.
Moin.
Muss noch ein bisschen Tee trinken hier.
Ja, ich war jetzt seit einer Woche nicht mehr on.
Ich war beschäftigt.
Einmal MMO-Kreisel
grind und
mit
endlich
einen neuen Job finden.
Beziehungsweise was finden. Gefunden hatte ich
ja eigentlich schon was.
Das jetzt klar zu machen alles.
Wurde jetzt echt mal Zeit. Ich mein,
es ist 18.
Bis spätestens, lasst mich schon mal kurz gucken bis spätestens hier, also wirklich alle, alle spätestens hier muss ich meine Kündigung abgegeben haben, weil ansonsten geht die nicht mehr rechtzeitig ein.
Wahrscheinlich werde ich sie hier abgeben, wenn das hinhaut oder nachdem man das dann da ist hier.
Aber hier ist wirklich allerletzter Stich.
Was ist?
Sag mal, was für eine?
Was für eine bescheuerte Idee ist eigentlich in diesem Kalender dieses Licht im Hintergrund?
Warum?
Jetzt mal ganz im Ernst. Ich mein, Optik schön und gut.
Man darf davon abgesehen, schön sieht es ja auch nicht aus.
Aber die wollten einen coolen Effekt machen.
Wäre es nicht einfach deutlich sinnvoller einfach nur das hier zu Highlighten, wo man gerade drauf ist, anstatt diesen komischen Spotlight-Effekt da zu machen?
Der verwirrt mich.
Ah Mann, Leute.
Was ist es jetzt geworden?
Der in Würzburg.
Nee, kann ich gleich was zu sagen.
Jetzt warte ich aber noch ein bisschen, weil das fragen sonst wieder 350 Leute den Stream über.
Das ist ein paar Onsen.
Ansonsten gibt es eigentlich nichts spannendes Neues.
Jetzt hab ich den Stream angemacht, jetzt fängt mir die Nase an zu laufen.
Da gibt es überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Als hätte ich jetzt nur drauf gewartet, bis ich den Stream anmache.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen?
Ach ja.
Ich brauche immer noch ein neues iPhone.
Das gucken wir jetzt.
Lass uns das gerade mal schnell gucken.
Was kostet das aktuell?
Store, apple.de.
Gibt es da überhaupt welche zu kaufen aktuell?
Ich wollte mir ja so eins hier kaufen.
Ein 14 Plus.
Moment.
Ist das das Richtige?
Ist es billiger geworden?
Hat es nicht 1500 letztens noch gekostet?
Oder habe ich mich verguckt?
Ach nee, den Pro will ich haben.
Den Pro will ich haben.
Aber kein Pro Max.
Ein Pro.
Ich will das mit 120 Hertz Display.
Das, das, das will ich.
Das hat.
Ja genau.
Das hat irgendwie 1300 gekostet.
Ne ne, Pro Max will ich nicht.
Das ist mir zu groß.
Ich will das.
Gibt es das eigentlich aktuell?
Gibt es das aktuell lieferbar?
Ja das reicht Digge.
Das reicht Digge.
Sieht man da irgendwo, ob das lieferbar ist?
Ach hier, Lieferung.
5. bis 13. Januar.
Kackel Alter.
Gibt es bei Amazon noch was?
Temporary out of stock.
128 bei dem Preis.
Wieso 128? Reicht doch.
Die machen unendlich viel Geld.
Mit einfach nur mehr Speicher.
Guck mal.
Die wollen einfach 400 Euro mehr.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Für ein bisschen mehr Speicher.
Viermal mehr Speicher ist ja auch egal.
Der Speicher kostet nichts.
Aber es ist alles
Temporary out of stock.
Ja da wird es dieses Jahr
mit dem iPhone wahrscheinlich nichts mehr.
Ja die wissen echt wie es geht.
Also eins muss man sagen.
So Upselling oder wie das heißt,
hat Apple wirklich perfektioniert.
Wenn du da über die Webseite gehst,
du endest zwangsläufig meistens
beim aktuellen iPhone Modell
und dann einem der besseren noch.
Hey.
Das eine Upgrade
können wir noch machen.
Das kostet 100 Euro mehr
und dann bist du irgendwann bei 1300 Euro
für dein fucking Smartphone.
Ja es ist tatsächlich
1 Euro pro Gigabyte,
wenn man sich das mal überlegt.
Ich höre nur auf der einen Seite
vom Headset nichts.
Früher konnte man das hier muten.
Das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr oder was?
Ist die Lautstärke richtig eingestellt?
Irgendwas buggt heute rum.
Lull.
Was ist denn hier los?
Jetzt ist gut.
Du arbeitest doch noch bei einer Bank
oder stimmt es, dass man im Bankensektor
mit IT Weiterbildung überschüttet wird?
Das kommt drauf an wo du bist.
Also ja arbeite ich,
aber das kommt drauf an wo du bist.
Also bei uns ist das jetzt eher verhalten.
Ich bin gerade noch auf dem alten Rechner.
Das ist richtig.
Ich habe gestern dieses Be Quiet
Grafikkartenkabel
Wie heißt das Ding nochmal?
12 Volt
HWR
oder so?
12 Volt
HWR
Kabel
gekriegt per Post.
Als Tipp by the way Leute,
wenn ihr euch fragt wo kann man das bestellen?
Nicht hier
irgendwo im Internet,
einfach bei Be Quiet selber.
Es hat nämlich
einen Ersatzteilstore.
Wir haben einen Ersatzteilstore.
Das findet halt niemand.
Da wählt man dann hier aus.
Netzteil, Dark Power,
Dark Power, Produktname,
Im Ersatzteilshop muss man.
Und dann kann man es einfach hier drüber bestellen.
Weil ansonsten war dieser
Kram nirgendwo lieferbar.
Und hier habe ich
festgestellt, ah ja guck mal da.
Ach guck mal.
Ich hab noch eins bekommen.
Lull.
Es kam gestern oder vorgestern per Post.
Lustig.
Das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr.
Aber anscheinend
wollen das noch mehr haben.
Ja aber zumindest wenn man Ersatzteile braucht
ist es wirklich am besten.
Man guckt bei denen.
Geht schnell, innerhalb von ein paar Tagen
ist es jetzt angekommen.
Und die haben das meistens auch lieferbar.
So lange es geht,
so lange es noch neue Updates gibt,
gibt es ja eigentlich keinen Grund.
Ich würde mein iPhone 11 auch noch behalten,
wenn ich es noch weiter benutzen könnte.
Aber ich kann mein iPhone 11 ja wahrscheinlich
ab April nicht mehr verwenden.
Weil es ja nicht mein
iPhone 11 ist, sondern das
von der Firma wo ich gerade arbeite.
Und ab 31.03.
arbeite ich da ja wahrscheinlich nicht mehr.
Ich sag jetzt nur wahrscheinlich.
Also zu 99% nicht mehr.
Weil ich die Kündigung noch nicht
abgegeben habe.
Aber
es kann eigentlich
so gut wie nix dazwischen kommen.
Das lohnt sich.
Also du musst mal gucken,
wie viel länger das wirklich läuft.
Weil es kostet halt
generell also Smartphonepreise
und Grafikkartenpreise.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht Chat,
was würdet ihr lieber kaufen?
Eine aktuelle Grafikkarte
oder ein aktuelles Smartphone?
Ein aktuelles iPhone?
Muss man bei iPhone einschalten,
gibt es ja deutlich günstiger.
Ein aktuelles Highend iPhone oder Grafikkarte?
Im Prinzip nimmt sich das Preislich
ja gar nicht mehr so viel.
Nur dass Grafikkarten tatsächlich
noch ein Ticken teurer sind.
GPU?
Ja, GPU habe ich jetzt ja schon.
Also wird es ein neues iPhone.
Aber trotzdem.
Das ist eigentlich schon unglaublich teuer.
Paper please Musik hier.
Jaja, ich werde dazu was erzählen.
Bevor das jetzt wieder 350 Mal
im Stream gefragt wird.
Aber wir gucken uns mal gerade
die aktuellen GitHub Trends an.
Das gucken wir uns immer...
Das gucken wir uns immer einmal sonntags an.
Mal gucken, was es da so gibt.
Moment, Moment.
Habe ich die nicht sogar schon offen?
Doch, hier.
Ne.
Also was trendet denn diese Woche?
Was sonst?
Das ist ja gerade überall total angesagt.
Ein Python Compiler.
Gibt es ja schon ein paar.
Das ist noch einer.
Was macht der noch besser als der Rest?
Es gibt doch wieder irgendwelche Probleme
mit Packages oder sowas.
Garantiert.
Uptime Kuma, ja nice.
Endlich mal was, was ich kenne,
was in den GitHub Trends ist.
Habe ich zwar nicht mal bei mir im Einsatz,
war aber trotzdem sehr nice.
Muss ich mir mal in Ruhe angucken,
was es da Neues gibt.
ChatGPT, ChatGPT,
AI,
Alibaba,
was auch immer.
No description
und der Rest ist auf China-Chinesen Sprache.
Alles klar, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Irgendjemand eine Ahnung, was das macht?
Ich sehe C++.
Das schreckt mich schon mal ab.
Ist es ein Search Engine?
Alles klar.
Blazingly fast written in Rust.
Das Weltkit
ist erschienen in 1.0.
Das habe ich gelesen.
Tasmota, endlich mal was.
Das hat es verdient.
Das gibt es schon so lange.
Das war bestimmt auch zum ersten Mal in den Trends.
Würde einiges bei mir heimautomatisierungstechnisch
nicht funktionieren ohne Tasmota.
Nice Subprojekt.
Du hast einen Werbespot
für die US Marines bekommen.
Vielleicht entspricht es ja sonst
seinem View-Verhalten.
Vielleicht guckst du ja gerne
Military Content.
Oh ja, neuer Monitor.
Das steht bei mir auch demnächst an.
Ich vermute mal,
es wird aber noch ein paar Monate dauern.
Es sind jetzt ein paar Monitore angekündigt.
OLED.
Ich kann mir immer nicht entscheiden,
ob ich OLED sagen soll oder OLED.
Leute, OLED vs OLED.
Moment, das müssen wir
eine kurze Umfrage machen.
Ich mach mal kurz.
Was sagt ihr?
Ich bin einfach gespannt.
Du kriegst hauptsächlich englische Werbung.
Das liegt bestimmt auch ein bisschen daran,
wie dein Browser eingestellt ist.
Oder ob du über einen VPN
oder so zugreifst. Aber wahrscheinlich
greifst du nicht über einen VPN zu.
Ist beides scheiße. Was soll man denn sonst sagen?
Niemand sagt Organic LED.
Also OLED. Okay.
Hört sich ein bisschen an wie irgendein Backstein.
Weiß auch nicht. OLED.
Niemand spricht den Kram
doch so aus.
Brauchst du irgendwas kurzes, griffiges?
Ich tendiere auch zu OLED
anstatt zu OLED.
Oder O...
OLED.
Ist alles Blödsinn.
Ich kaufe mir einen OLED-Monitor.
1440p, 27 Zoll.
Wenn es dann mal ordentlich welche gibt.
Aktuell gibt es ja einen angekündigt von LG
für ungefähr 1000 Euro.
Es muss natürlich auch alles immer super teuer sein.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass nächstes Jahr,
also 2023, einige kommen.
Guck mal hier. OLED
von LG.
Das Ding. Ja.
Das ist tatsächlich sehr spannend.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was der Unterschied ist
zwischen OLED und Mini-LED.
CRT. Ja. 27 Zoll
CRT. 16 zu 9
wird es halt schwierig.
Und am besten auch noch mit
Display-Port-Anschluss.
Sowas müsste mal einer bauen, Alter.
Dann bricht dein Schreibtisch darunter zusammen.
Es gibt teilweise schon Monitore
mit irgendwie 45 Zoll.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich will keinen 45 Zoll-Monitor.
27 Zoll und dafür zwei Stück.
Das ist gut. Allerdings muss der zweite dann auch nicht
Monitore sein.
Aber die Kombination aus
240 Hertz plus
OLED-Technologie, also ganz ehrlich,
ich glaube, dann hat es sich mit Input-Lag
und sonstigen Sachen tatsächlich erledigt.
Aktuell habe ich einen 240 Hertz
ganz normal LED.
TFT.
LED, LCD.
Wie auch immer.
Die Hintergrundbeleuchtung sind LEDs.
Aber es ist nach wie vor
ein TFT-LCD.
Ach.
Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, der ist schon ziemlich gut.
Was Input-Lag angeht.
Die 360 Hertz habe ich nicht mitgemacht.
Werde ich auch nicht machen.
Als nächstes wird es wahrscheinlich sowas werden hier bei mir.
Mal gucken, wann es das denn dann auch wirklich
lieferbar gibt.
Reorder kannst du nämlich aktuell nur.
Das Einbrennen.
Ich würde jetzt mal erwarten, dass man die Monitore
normal benutzbar macht.
Also.
Mal gucken.
Ich werde hier auch definitiv
nichts pre-ordern.
Irgendwie so ein Blödsinn.
Das wird gekauft frühestens,
wenn es dazu ein paar Tests gibt.
Und ich werde mir wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht den hier kaufen.
Sondern abwarten.
Weil nächstes Jahr über
kommen jede Menge
solcher Monitore.
Tipp ich zumindest drauf.
Ja.
Mehr als 175 Hertz bringen noch.
Das
kann schon sein.
Aber das ist ja die Technik ab.
OLED ist an sich eh schon mal ein bisschen
noch mehr responsive.
Aber wie gesagt.
Ich als Boomer mit 150 Millisekunden Reaktionszeit.
Was ja schon im
Pro Gamer Bereich liegt.
Ist das natürlich wichtig.
Dass ich auch ein
Monitor habe.
Der dazu passt.
Ich mein besser treffen werde ich trotzdem nichts.
Es war jetzt nur so
halb Kappa.
Ziemlich schnelle Reaktionszeit.
Aber ich mache ja auch nichts anderes als vom Rechner sitzen.
Wenn ich nicht schnelle Reaktionszeit habe wer sonst?
Treffen tue ich trotzdem nichts.
Letztens wieder über Battlefield gesehen hat.
Ja also
360 Hertz fand ich jetzt auch
hat mich auch bis jetzt die Geräte nicht überzeugt.
Aber
240 Hertz OLED
ist glaube ich das.
Da ist wirklich so das Limit wo ich sage hey.
Also ich glaube mehr brauchst du dann echt nicht.
Wobei mal abwarten in ein paar Jahren dann.
Reaktionszeit ein Test gemacht.
Ich hatte zwischen so 100
155 und 170 Millisekunden Reaktionszeit.
Es ging richtig
richtig ab. Haben sie alle geglaubt.
Haben sie mir erst mal gar nicht geglaubt.
Als ich das gesagt habe hier im Stream.
Dann haben wir live den Test gemacht im Stream.
Easy.
Mit der Zeit verschiebt sich das Bild.
Echt? Warum soll sich das Bild verschieben?
Warum?
Weil einbrennen verstehe ich ja noch.
Aber verschieben? Warum soll sich das Bild verschieben?
Verstehe ich nicht. Nun gut.
Wenn jetzt einige da sind. Also.
Um der Frage.
Die trotzdem wahrscheinlich 350 mal kommen wird im Stream.
Bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Aber um der Frage jetzt mal so weit vorzubeugen.
Zumindest für alle die schon da sind.
Moin.
Unifying 1337
Also.
Ich habe jetzt einen neuen Job angenommen.
Ich werde kündigen da wo ich arbeite.
Ich habe noch nicht abgegeben.
Weil ich den finalen Arbeitsvertrag noch nicht in Papierform hier habe.
Und noch nicht unterschrieben habe.
Ich habe das aber alles schon verbindlich.
Und per E-Mail
vertragstechnisch.
Ich warte jetzt noch drauf bis das Ding endlich per Post kommt.
Und sobald das unterschrieben ist.
Werde ich dann
meine Kündigung einreichen.
Die anderen Angebote habe ich schon abgesagt.
Was
echt etwas
Also was mir wirklich
schwer gefallen ist. Weil
Ich hatte ja vorher
schon mit einem Anbieter
Also mit einem IT Dienstleister
aus Würzburg was ausgemacht.
Und mit dem war ich eigentlich auch schon soweit
fertig und mir soweit einig.
Das ich bei dem sogar schon den Vertrag in der
Post hatte.
Und.
Jetzt musste ich dem das halt absagen.
Ich wusste echt gar nicht wie ich das gescheit machen soll.
Das war mir übelst
peinlich da anzurufen und zu sagen.
Jungs wird doch
nichts. Aber letztendlich
Irgendwo habe ich mir gedacht.
Ist es ja trotzdem Business.
Was willst du machen.
Also habe ich das abgesagt.
Und ich gehe jetzt.
Von einer Bank in Frankfurt.
Zur anderen Bank in Frankfurt.
Die ist ungefähr 2
200 Meter
nicht. Aber keine Ahnung.
Die sind irgendwie 500 Meter voneinander entfernt.
Also es ist ungefähr 500 Meter Luftlinie
voneinander weg alles.
Wo ich jetzt arbeite.
Also das ist wo ich dann arbeite.
Boomerland ist das wo ich jetzt arbeite.
Aber wenigstens
mehr Geld und 99% Remote.
Also es ist.
Erstmal überlegen wie viel ist denn das Remote.
Also man muss alle
14 Tage mal ein Tag hin.
Ich weiß nicht wie viel Remote das ist.
Also quasi ein Tag auf 8 Arbeitstage
bei mir.
Einmal die Woche
bis 14 Tage irgendwie sowas.
Aber
selbst einmal die Woche habe ich auch gesagt.
Ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Das ist ja in Frankfurt.
Das ist quasi um die Ecke.
Da komme ich ganz gut hin.
Einmal die Woche ist okay.
Zumal die im Vergleich
zu meinem aktuellen Job.
Und vor allem
dann auch nochmal zu dem
anderen Job den ich in Würzburg
schon eingenommen habe.
Echt ordentlich bezahlen.
Also das andere in Würzburg
war schon nett verkehrt.
Letztendlich ist es unterm Strich
was ich aktuell verdiene auch nett verkehrt.
Wenn man das mal vergleicht
mit was man so
im Durchschnitt bekommt in Deutschland.
Aber letztendlich man muss ja auch mal gucken
wo man unterwegs ist.
Frankfurter Bankensektor.
Da ist einfach ordentlich Kohle drin.
Und jetzt bist du bei 100%.
Jetzt bin ich tatsächlich 6-stellig bei den Neuen.
War ich vorher nicht.
Aber jetzt bin ich es.
Allerdings auch jetzt nicht irgendwie
im hohen 6-stelligen Bereich oder so.
Das ist logisch.
Aber 6-stellig ist es jetzt.
Niedrig, niedrig 6-stellig.
Also es ist 6-stellig
hat aber noch eine 1
an der ersten Stelle.
Also niedrig 6-stellig.
Nein Linux-Engineer bin ich jetzt.
Aber Senior.
Senior Linux-Engineer.
Was sind deine neuen Aufgaben im Job
oder bleibt es gleich?
Na ja so 100%ig erzählen kann ich euch das nicht.
Weil ich selbst noch nicht weiß.
Also ich weiß was die mir erzählt haben
und ich weiß was in der Stellenanzeige stand.
Also
so wirklich wissen
tu ich das ja erst
wenn ich da angefangen habe.
Also ich kann es euch so ungefähr erzählen.
Also es ist tatsächlich von den Skills her
relativ ähnlich zu dem was ich jetzt mache.
Wenn ich weiß was ich jetzt mache
kann ich mir ein Video dazu angucken.
Es ist wohl ein großer Teil
klassisch noch Systemadministration.
Es ist
Infrastructure as Code
mit Ansible und Puppet.
Es ist ein bisschen Cloud Provisioning
mit Terraform.
Ein paar, keine Ahnung
Kubernetes Manifest
Jammels erstellen.
Ich weiß es noch nicht genau. Mal gucken was da auf einen zukommt.
Ich kann es schlecht
einschätzen jetzt.
Weil zwischen den Technologien die aufgelistet werden
und das was man dann wirklich macht
das kann man schlecht sagen.
Da muss ich mal abwarten bis es los geht.
Also anfangen kann ich eh erst im April.
Also es dauert noch ein bisschen.
Ich habe ja noch 3 Monate Kündigungszeit.
Kündigungsfrist
Du hast als Schüler 0 Income
Ja aber du hast danach bestimmt auch mal
mehr als 0
Wie viele Stunden?
4 Tage.
80%
Bist du auf Github?
Bist du auf Github in der agilen
Broggers Gruppe?
Das ist bestimmt
toll wenn man das in die
Bewerbung schreibt.
Github.
Nicht in der agilen Broggers Gruppe.
Okay ich erzähle euch
das mal kurz wie das ganze gelaufen ist.
Ich erzähle euch das mal.
Also ich war weder Probearbeiten dort
noch habe ich irgendwie
sonderlich viel im Vorfeld mir da angeguckt.
Also folgendermaßen.
Ich war in Würzburg
Also nennen wir den mal
IT-Dienstleister in Würzburg.
Was zum Teufel soll denn das sein?
Also ich war
beim IT-Dienstleister in Würzburg
Hab
vorher mit denen einen
Remote-Termin gemacht.
Dann habe ich einen Termin vor Ort gemacht mit den Teammitgliedern.
Wir haben uns super verstanden.
Geld war in Ordnung.
Arbeitsbedingungen, Homeoffice, war alles gut.
Hab ich gesagt gut können wir machen.
Und
da haben sie mir einen Vertrag geschickt.
So dann hatte ich den Vertrag beziehungsweise
ich hatte den Vertrag erstmal nur per E-Mail
und dann kam er ein paar Tage später per Post.
So und in der
Zwischenzeit wo ich schon den Vertrag per E-Mail
hatte aber der Vertrag noch nicht per Post da war.
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich ihn nämlich sonst
unterschrieben.
Hat sich ein Ex-Kollege gemeldet
mit dem ich früher bei der Bank
gearbeitet habe, wo ich jetzt gerade
arbeite.
Und hat gemeint Max
ich arbeite gerade für die sowieso
Sonstwas Bank in Frankfurt
und wir suchen noch
so zwei, drei neue Leute.
Wie schaut's denn aus? Hast du Bock?
Ja klar.
Passt ja wunderbar. Hab ich Bock drauf.
Dann hat er
hab ich mit ihm telefoniert
und ich hab ihm mal
meinen Lebenslauf und meine Skill-Liste
geschickt. Die Skill-Liste haben wir uns ja im Stream
auch schon angeguckt.
Und die hat er seinem Chef weiter geschickt.
Und
da war ich gerade im Bauhaus
und hab einen Weihnachtsbaum gekauft.
Da klingelt auf einmal
mein Handy. So keine Ahnung
eineinhalb Stunden später.
Es gibt auch nur eine Handvoll Leute mit
denen ich mich gut verstehe. Und da hat
der Ex-Kollege dazugehört.
So und da hab ich irgendwie
eineinhalb Stunden später hat mich dann
während ich im Bauhaus war und Weihnachtsbaum gekauft
habe, der Chef
von meinem Ex-Kollege angerufen und hat gefragt
hier, wie sieht's denn aus?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr
was er gesagt hat.
Genau, er hat gesagt ich soll
ihm nochmal offiziell die Bewerbung
schicken, weil es ist
eine Bank und da müssen natürlich Bewerbungsprozesse
und alles eingehalten werden und sonstwas.
Dann hab ich dann ihm nochmal offiziell
die Bewerbung geschickt. Das musste man über so ein
Portal machen, wo man dann auch zustimmt,
dass datenschutztechnisch die
Bewerbung verarbeitet
werden darf. Und hast du nicht gesehen,
wir haben ja da mittlerweile so krasse Auflagen in Deutschland.
Kannst dich einfach mal bewerben und
ein paar PDF hier irgendwo hinschicken.
So, dann hab ich dort
die Bewerbung hochgeladen.
Im Endeffekt war es mein Lebenslauf und die
Skill-Liste. Es war sehr, sehr wenig.
Hat dann auch der von der Personalabteilung
gesagt, also ein bisschen
mehr könnte ich schon auch hochladen. Vielleicht auch ein paar
Zeugnisse oder so, anstatt
einfach nur zwei Dokumente.
So, dann hab ich das da hochgeladen und irgendwie
zwei Tage später
haben die sich schon gemeldet und haben gesagt, hier
Max,
hast du nächste Woche Zeit?
Oh, ja klar, passt.
So, dann bin ich nächste Woche nach
Frankfurt gefahren und hab
da mich mit
einem von der Personalabteilung
und
dem Teamleiter
von dieser IT-Abteilung,
diesem Team, wo ich dann hingehe,
bzw. das Team, was die Stelle ausgeschrieben
hat, hatten wir, pass mal auf,
haltet euch fest, fast
drei Stunden Vorstellungsgespräch.
Fast drei Stunden.
Also 2 Stunden 42 oder sowas.
Das hat ein bisschen geschlaucht,
aber es war insofern wichtig, weil ich
musste ja mitkriegen, was da so läuft und die mussten
von mir was mitkriegen und das Ganze musste
möglichst schnell gehen.
Weil ich muss, wie gesagt,
muss gekündigt haben spätestens, aber
allerspätestens hier bis 30.
Das heißt, wenn wir hier, wir haben letzte
Woche, also wir haben diese, nicht letzte, wir haben
diese Woche ja hier erst Vorstellungsgespräch gemacht
und
bis hierhin muss ich quasi Vertrag
haben, unterschreiben und dass ich bis hier maximal
kündigen kann. Also es ist etwas sehr,
sehr
knappes.
Ich hab jetzt alles hochgeladen dort.
Ich hab wirklich alles hochgeladen, weil ich
hab hochgeladen
mein Schulzeugnis,
meine IHK
Abschlussding,
von meinem ersten Aushilfsjob das
Zeugnis,
vom Provider das Zeugnis,
von meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber das Zwischenzeugnis,
vom Zivildienst
die Bestätigung. Ich hab wirklich alles
hochgeladen, was es gibt. Also jetzt können sie sich
nicht beschweren, dass sie zu wenig,
zu wenig irgendwie Infos über mich haben.
So, zumindest hab ich jetzt dann
direkt am Tag danach ein Angebot
gekriegt.
Verbindlich schon.
Jetzt Vertrag per Mail und jetzt warte ich auf
Vertrag, Vertrag per
also noch zusätzlich
auf den Vertrag
per Post.
So, dass ich dann nächstes
Jahr dort
anfangen kann. Und wisst ihr was das Beste ist?
Das hab ich euch ja noch gar nicht erzählt.
Ähm,
wobei,
ich hab das, ich hab das glaub ich schon vor ein paar Wochen
mal erzählt. Hab ich euch vor ein paar Wochen
erzählt, dass ich mich zusammen mit einem
aktuellen, also mit
einem aktuellen Arbeitskollege, mit dem
ich dort, wo ich jetzt gerade arbeite,
öfters zusammen arbeite.
Hab ich euch da erzählt, dass wir uns zusammen
beworben haben bei einem Laden?
Ich glaube schon. Ich glaube das hab ich euch erzählt.
Wir haben uns so doppelt, doppelt beworben.
Und
kann sein, dass ich das erwähnt habe.
Zumindest,
als ich dort war,
hab ich erfahren,
die suchen noch
jemand für diese Stelle. Halt für
eine andere Stelle, die exakt mehr oder
weniger den gleichen Wortlaut hat.
Und ich hatte passenderweise schon
den Lebenslauf von
meinem aktuellen Arbeitskollege dabei
und hab gesagt, sag mal, also wenn ihr noch Leute sucht,
ich kenn da jemand.
Hab ich den Lebenslauf rausgepackt,
hab ihn in die Hand gedrückt
und einen Tag später
haben die sich bei meinem Arbeitskollege
gemeldet und haben gefragt, hier, wie sieht's
denn aus? Hast du Bock?
Und jetzt
läuft's wahrscheinlich so,
dass sowohl er als auch ich
da anfangen können am 1. April.
Du hast Glück gehabt, oder?
Dann kenn ich meinen Ex-Kolleg dort
plus meinen aktuellen
Wechsel mit, also kenn ich wirklich schon ein paar Leute.
Das find ich immer gut.
Ja.
Drei Monate Kündigungsfrist sagt...
Es ist ja noch schlimmer bei mir.
Es ist ja nicht drei Monate Kündigungsfrist,
es ist drei Monate Kündigungsfrist zum Quartal.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt nicht
bis Ende des Monats kündige, dann kann ich
fast wieder in drei Monaten
plus drei Monate kündigen.
Also dann erst im
Juni oder so
noch Anwerberbonus
rausgehaltet. Das ist ein gutes
Stichwort. Ja, könnte ich wahrscheinlich probieren,
ist mir aber egal. Also für
mich hab ich das ausgefüllt,
dass mein Ex-Kollege
Mitarbeiter werden,
Werben-Mitarbeiterbonus bekommt.
Das ist angegeben.
Ja. Ohne Scheiß,
wenn man Leute kennt, ist einfach besser.
Es hat Vorteile. Es hat, es hat,
ehrlich gesagt, hat das mehrere Vorteile, wenn man
irgendwohin wechselt, wo man jemand kennt.
Also, erstens kennt man selbst schon jemand und
zweitens ist es natürlich, macht es auch immer
einen besseren Eindruck, wenn man empfohlen, also
macht es schon mal etwas besseren, einen guten Eindruck,
wenn man empfohlen wird und
wenn die Leute einen quasi in das eigene Team
holen, heißt das irgendwie auch, man passt wohl
ganz gut dazu. Also ich glaube,
das ist für alle Seiten von Vorteil,
wenn man auf Empfehlungen
von jemandem, den man kennt,
mit dem man sich gut verstanden hat,
irgendwohin geht. Also zumindest
stehen dann die Chancen deutlich besser,
dass das alles passt.
Wäre dein aktueller Job jetzt frei?
Also soweit ich gehört habe,
Moment, ich muss mal kurz ein bisschen
Klimaanlage anmachen.
Also nicht kühlen, wärmen.
Hier ist nämlich gerade nur 19 Grad,
also ein bisschen kühl.
Ne, ne, noch kälter. Was haben wir denn?
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz bei mir auf meine Temperatur gucken.
Was haben wir denn? 18,6.
Ja, ein bisschen wärmer kann es schon noch sein.
Also,
also, wird dein aktueller Job jetzt frei?
Naja, offiziell
erst einmal ab April,
aber ich habe schon gehört, dass
jemand anderes
dort, wo ich gerade arbeite,
seine Stelle abgebaut
werden soll und der
dann meinen Spot übernehmen könnte.
Wäre ja eigentlich auch ganz gut, dann haben die dort weniger
Lücken und Probleme,
weil ich habe jetzt ja nicht vor,
da meinen aktuellen
Kollegen irgendwie mehr Stress
als nötig zu verursachen, ja.
Was mich überhaupt
nicht mehr interessiert, ist es dann quasi die Firma,
wo ich jetzt aktuell arbeite, weil
das hat schon seinen Grund, warum ich wechsle.
Ich werde das drei Monate noch ordentlich
übergeben alles und dann
mache ich mich vom Acker.
CU, sage ich dann, CU.
Wie lange meine Kündigungsfrist war?
Drei Monate zum Quartalsende,
korrekt.
Also, ich kann auch,
wenn ich das dann, wenn dann alles in trockenen
Tüchern ist, mache ich vielleicht noch ein Video
über das
Vorstellungsgespräch. Ich will jetzt erst einmal
abwarten, ob das
alles klappt, weil es hat ja keinen Sinn, wenn ich sage
neuer Job und es klappt irgendwie doch nicht, aber
wie gesagt, ich habe schon ein verbindliches Angebot,
eigentlich kann jetzt da nichts mehr
verbindlich vertragen.
Kann jetzt da eigentlich nichts mehr dazwischenkommen.
Aber letztendlich weiß ich das
ja erst, wenn ich wirklich hier
mein Darliegen habe. Zumindest
ein paar Fragen waren
tatsächlich sehr trickreich.
Zum Beispiel wurde, Leute, ich kann euch,
ihr werdet euch, ihr werdet euch weghecken.
Ich sage es euch. Ihr werdet euch
absolut weghecken, bei dem, was ich jetzt erzähle.
Und zwar,
ich wurde im Vorstellungsgespräch
gefragt, also Herr Max,
was müssten wir, das waren so trickreiche
Personalerfragen halt.
Muss man sagen, also,
der hat es schon gut gemacht.
Der hat es schon gut gemacht. Also, der hat sein,
Personaler hat seinen Job wirklich, versteht seinen Job
wirklich, muss man sagen. Zumindest,
er hat mich gefragt,
also Herr Max,
was müssten wir denn hier wirklich machen, um
sie so richtig auf die Palme zu bringen?
Ja, wahrscheinlich wollte er testen,
ob ich irgendwie
mich gerne streite oder sowas.
Das ist so eine typische, richtig
trickreiche Frage.
Also, was müssten wir hier dann machen,
um sie so richtig auf die Palme zu bringen?
Wisst ihr, was ich geantwortet habe?
Ich habe gesagt,
Windows administrieren.
Und die
Antwort,
die Antwort hat er sich aber, hat er aber nicht gelten
lassen.
Die Antwort hat er aber nicht gelten lassen.
Hat gemeint, ja, mal jetzt
von so, von so technischen Sachen weg.
Er meint, er meint ja
eher so,
so organisatorisch und
und alles drum herum.
Aber ich sagte, hey, ich habe von Windows
keine Ahnung, ja.
Es steht auch nirgendswo, irgendwo in meinen
Skills oder im Lebenslauf, sonstwo. Nicht mal
ansatzweise irgendwas von Windows.
Ich habe dann gesagt, lass mal
überlegen, was habe ich denn als Antwort
dann noch gegeben? Achso,
ja, tatsächlich, ich habe was gesagt, was mich
wirklich nervt, wenn man
rückwirkend
quasi Sachen
umdefiniert, um dann irgendwelche
Leuten den
schwarzen Peter in die Schuhe schieben zu können.
Also zum Beispiel, eine Sache, die
aktuellen Arbeitgeber passiert ist, habe ich euch ja schon mal
erzählt. Es wurde zum Beispiel gesagt, hey,
wenn wir Service XYZ
in die Cloud umziehen,
dann ist uns bewusst, dass es in einer Übergangsphase
da zu Problemen kommen kann.
Das wurde ja auch darauf hingewiesen im Vorfeld.
Und dann wurde von ganz oberer Stelle
gesagt, nein, dieser Umzug soll
exakt so passieren
und so schnell wie möglich und auch so, wie
es angesagt
war, trotz der Bedenken. Und
sollte es zu Problemen kommen, also Leute, ohne Scheiß,
diese Aussage wurde eins zu eins so getroffen,
und sollte es zu Problemen
durch den Cloudumzug kommen,
an dieser Stelle, dann
nehmen wir die in Kauf. So.
Und da könnt ihr euch vorstellen, es kam zu
Problemen, unter anderem
durch den Cloudumzug, weil manche Sachen nicht
bedacht wurden. Kann ich jetzt im Detail nicht so sehr
erzählen. Und danach
wurde gesagt, wie kann das
sein, dass der Service down war?
Und dann wurde das quasi retroaktiv
umbenannt,
äh nicht umbenannt, umdefiniert,
was denn mit Problemen beim Umzug
gemeint war, um dann sagen zu können,
die Leute, die den Umzug exakt
so gemacht haben, wie es damals
trotz angemeldeter Bedenken
ja,
gefordert war, sollen jetzt dran schuld
sein, dass es nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Und das sind so Sachen, die mich
tatsächlich aufregt.
Das
habe ich natürlich ein bisschen schöner umschrieben,
da erzählt, und das war
wahrscheinlich auch okay, die Antwort war, da hat keiner mal was drauf
gesagt.
Wie läuft es mit deinem Bewerben? Habe ich gerade was
zu erzählt? Also, ich habe jetzt einen neuen Job angenommen
in Frankfurt, bei einer anderen Bank.
Ja, fast schon. Geht in die
Richtung. Ich wechsel
quasi von einer Bank in Frankfurt
zu einer anderen Bank, die irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
800 Meter Luftlinie entfernt
ist. Und das erste, was ich
erlebt habe, war der Wahnsinn. Ich war
jetzt ja ein paar Wochen nicht mehr
in dieser Ecke in Frankfurt,
weil, was soll ich da, wenn ich Urlaub habe?
Ich bin am Hauptbahnhof ausgestiegen,
bin durch die Nebenstraße
gelaufen und auf einmal kommt jemand an
und meint so
zu mir, hallo. Und ich so,
hallo. Lauf so weiter.
Dann kommt er
noch einen Schritt auf mich zu
und meint so, Marihuana,
Marihuana.
Sagt, nein, nein, kein
Bin ich weg. Da wollten wir halt als erstes mal gleich
Drogen verkaufen.
Das ist
typische, typische Frankfurter
Hauptbahnhof-Seitenstraße, Alter.
Der erste Typ, der Hallo sagt, ist
gleich irgendein Dealer.
By the way, was ist eigentlich aus
Marihuana-Legalisierung
geworden? Sollte das nicht, weil das würde den ja
komplett die Geschäftsgrundlage entziehen
dort. Ah, zumindest dem.
Ist doch, nee, ist glaube ich
noch nicht.
Ist noch nicht. Vielleicht wollte er auch noch
seine Restbestände loswerden.
Das ist auch geil gewesen. Das erste,
irgendein Drogenhändler, oder was ist
Drogenhändler?
Eher im größeren Ziel. Erstmals irgendein Dealer
in Frankfurt über den Weg gelaufen.
Naja. So, also was gucken wir uns
denn jetzt an? Was
schauen wir, was haben wir denn, was haben
wir denn hier? Was können wir uns denn angucken? Also,
new, most pop, oh ja.
Data is beautiful. Das
guck ich immer gerne. Zeig mal her.
Lass, lass, lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz gucken.
Also, da kann ich die Musik laufen lassen.
Oder läuft, oder ist da Musik
dabei? Ja.
Most popular Messenger. Okay,
1998, Quartal 2.
Ja, ICQ und
natürlich, was sonst?
AOL Messenger.
Und MIRC.
Also, ich muss, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hab alles
davon, also, hab ich installiert gehabt,
hat kaum jemand verwendet von meinen Bekannten.
Hier, ICQ war das Ding schlechthin.
ICQ war, war hier
auch noch vor 1998.
Also,
ja, so als das mit Modem und so, also
ICQ, ICQ, beste. Hab ich damals
gekannt. Kennt noch jemand Sumo-Volleyball?
ICQ, ICQ Sumo
Volleyball.
Genau.
Kennt noch jemand Sumo-Volleyball?
Das war eigentlich so ein Minigame in ICQ
eingebaut, Alter. Sumo-Volleyball.
So, also,
MI, also IOC natürlich, damals,
damals auch. Also,
ich hab hauptsächlich tatsächlich ICQ
und MMO
technisch war
IOC. Das hier war quasi so ein
bisschen, ich mein Discord ist ja
hauptsächlich auch Voice-Chat und sonst was. Aber das war
für uns damals so ein bisschen
das, was Leute heute in Discord machen, ja.
Absprechen so nach dem Motto,
hey, wollen wir heute Abend Gruppe machen?
Oder, was weiß ich, heute Abend
Raid und solche Geschichten.
Jetzt nicht intern mit ein paar Leuten in der
Gilde oder so, sondern teilweise
auch komplett übergreifend. Also, da gab's
da gab's den IOC
gab's den IOC-Channel für MMO
Kram. Ja, IOC gibt's heute immer noch,
aber die Benutzung ist, glaub ich, jetzt auch nicht
auch nicht mehr das. Also, IOC,
und ICQ war's bei mir hauptsächlich. Ich hatte
AOL-Messenger bestimmt installiert,
wahrscheinlich Yahoo-Messenger auch
und MSN natürlich auch, aber
verwendet hab ich ehrlich gesagt eigentlich so gut wie
nur, so gut wie ausschließlich ICQ
und bisschen IRC. In
98, ja. Tencent QQ.
Die China-Chinesen
sind jetzt auch ins Internet gekommen.
Siehste mal, Leute.
Muss ich mal vorstellen, die hatten 1999,
als bei uns
ICQ voll angesagt war und
MSN und sowas,
hatten die China-Chinesen
einen Messenger, der mehr User hatte.
Niemand hat davon gehört.
Das hat damals, ich mein, heute ja auch.
Heute kriegst du ja auch kaum was mit.
Aber immer noch mehr, was bei den Chinesen
im Internet so passiert.
Aber damals hast du ja wirklich gar keinen Plan
davon gehabt.
Das war noch mehr andere Welt als heute.
Guck mal hier.
Wie das abgeht.
So, MSN.
Ja, MSN, also ich,
kann mich noch dran erinnern, 2000 rum oder so.
Ich hatte auch ab und zu mal MSN.
MSN hatte, finde ich,
für die damalige Zeit, finde ich, ganz coole Emotes.
Aber,
AOL habe ich nie großartig verwendet.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass das so riesengroß
damals war. Also, es war
bei mir im Endeffekt zwischenzeitlich
dann drei Sachen. Das war ICQ,
MSN und immer noch für MMOs
immer noch IRC.
Und das hier war, glaube ich, so ein
Multi-Client-Messenger. Da konntest du dann
ICQ,
AOL und MSN in einem haben.
Jetzt geht MSN
aber ab. Und die China-Chinesen
überholen alles.
Also, ich habe ICQ,
glaube ich, noch verwendet.
Äh, lange.
Bis, bis, bis 2000,
bis 2004
oder so habe ich das, glaube ich, noch verwendet.
Oder bis 2005?
Boah, Alter!
Was zum Teufel geht mit MSN ab?
Wurde das dann mit Windows
ausgeliefert? Bei Windows 2000?
Oder warum ist das auf einmal so krass abgegangen?
iChat?
Das ist aber nix von Apple, oder?
Warum ist denn MSN? Das ist bestimmt gebundelt geworden
mit Windows. Ich wüsste nicht, warum das sonst so abgehen sollte.
Ach, der iChat ist Apple.
Alter, MSN flutscht.
Oh, ne. Oh, ne.
Oh, ne.
Ich glaube, Skype war der nervigste,
also der mieseste
von allen, der sich
aber dann teilweise fast
allein durchgesetzt hat. Es gab ja mal ne Zeit,
da hat quasi jeder Skype
verwendet.
Also, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, 2007
und 8, als ich mit
YouTube angefangen habe, da ging im Prinzip
90 Prozent
über Skype.
Guckt mal, guckt euch das mal an.
Skype flutscht.
Und jetzt gehen alle
China-Chinesen ins Internet.
Google Talk.
Ist das nicht auch eines der Sachen, die Google schon längst
wieder eingestellt hat nach ein paar Jahren?
Black... Ha! Blackberry!
Gut, an die erinnert sich heute keiner mehr.
Aber das AOL
bis 2006, 2007
noch so weit oben war, war mir gar nicht
bewusst. Gut, ich habe den ja auch nie verwendet.
Jetzt gibt es zwischenzeitlich...
Okay, guckt mal. Das ist so ein
typisches Microsoft-Ding,
das ist wohl mal kurzzeitig...
Ach, ne. Moment. MSN wurde umbenannt
in Windows Live Messenger.
Okay. Deswegen ist der jetzt da oben.
Das ist auch so ein Microsoft-Ding,
dass man Skype...
Gut, Skype war glaube ich ursprünglich zum
größten Teil ja VoIP.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, was das hier macht.
Das ist eigentlich so ein
Multi-Messenger gewesen, ja.
Aber das ist auch so ein Microsoft-Ding,
dass man wieder zwei Sachen hier zeitgleich hatte.
Okay,
ICQ ist eigentlich jetzt nahezu...
Naja, bedeutungslos kann man
nicht sagen, aber auf dem absteigenden Ast.
Auch wenn es noch steigt,
aber die anderen steigen stärker.
Blackberry müsste sich demnächst
dann auch schon fast wieder erledigt haben.
Und ich glaube so
in dem Dreh habe ich jetzt auch aufgehört
ICQ zu benutzen.
Stimmt, Microsoft hat Skype gekauft.
Du hast recht.
Es war ja gar nicht von Anfang an Skype.
Äh, nicht von Anfang an Microsoft Skype.
Aber die China-Chinesen gehen ab hier.
Guckt es euch an.
Blackberry. Ah, Blackberry!
Leute, das kann ich euch sagen. Blackberry hat sich bald erledigt.
Dauert nicht mal allzu lange.
Dann ist Blackberry wieder weg vom Fenster.
Okay, AOL
sinkt total schnell und ICQ
nimmt zu. Okay.
Rennen die alten AOL-Benutzer alle jetzt
zur ICQ, oder?
Was zum Teufel? Warum hat ICQ so viele Benutzer?
2008 war das doch schon
komplett auf dem absteigenden Ast, dachte ich.
Also zumindest ich habe es nicht mehr verwendet.
Also AOL habe ich nicht mitbekommen,
weil habe ich nie benutzt.
Die China-Chinesen
ziehen halt wieder... Oh, oh je!
WhatsApp,
das flutscht jetzt auch gleich.
Das war die Zeit, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern,
wo die ganzen Boomer
von WhatsApp erfahren haben.
Und wisst ihr, was die gesagt haben?
Oh, kennst du diese neue App?
WhatsApp!
Da kannst du kostenlos
SMS verschicken. Stellt euch das mal vor.
Kostenlos SMS!
Und man musste den Leuten damals schon
erklären, Leute,
ihr erzählt den absoluten Blödsinn.
Das ist keine SMS. Das ist eine Textnachricht.
Das hat mit SMS nichts zu tun.
Aber gut.
Die Leute haben es halt nicht gecheckt.
Kostenlos SMS konntest du damals verschicken.
Schreibt euch das mal.
Kostenlose SMS.
Und da sind die alle drauf aufgesprungen.
Gut, die haben es aber auch clever gemacht.
Die haben es ja aber auch clever gemacht.
Also ob die App was gekostet hat,
keine Ahnung.
Die haben es aber auch clever gemacht.
Die haben die Telefonnummer als ID benutzt.
Das war der erste
dieser ganzen Messenger hier, die wir sehen.
Gut, China-Chinesen-Zeug, weiß ich nicht.
Da konntest du dich wahrscheinlich auch mit deinem Fingerabdruck
damals schon registrieren.
Das waren aber die ersten, die es sinnvoll gemacht haben.
Und zwar mit der Telefonnummer.
Das ist vielleicht aus Datenschutzgründen nicht sinnvoll.
Aber aus Boomer,
einfachheitshalber User-Nutzungssicht
ist es das Beste.
Du brauchst keine zusätzliche Nummer.
Das ist ja auch
eines der Dinger, warum sich WhatsApp
aus meiner Sicht durchgesetzt hat.
China-Chinesen sind immer noch vorne.
WhatsApp, guckt es euch an!
Fiber.
Ist das...
Sagt mir gar nichts. Ist das was russisches?
Was ist Fiber?
Okay, jetzt ist ICQ komplett...
fast schon bedeutungslos
wieder.
WeChat, okay.
Die China-Chinesen
holen noch mehr auf.
Line sagt mir gar nichts mehr.
Tango, iMessage. Okay, iChat
wurde jetzt in iMessage umbenannt.
Jetzt kommen wir so langsam
in das, wie ich das auch im Kopf habe.
WeChat,
genau.
So langsam aber sicher müsste sich Blackberry
doch mal verabschieden jetzt.
Alter, wie WhatsApp flutscht, Mann.
Muss ich mal überlegen.
Die China-Chinesen haben jetzt doppelt.
Die hatten wahrscheinlich beides parallel
installiert, oder? Hier hatten sie noch
die Kontakte und das war das Neue.
Und WhatsApp. Alter, guckt mal
wie WhatsApp abgeht, Mann.
Most useless Ding überhaupt.
Oh.
War der Facebook-Messenger nicht früher auch
irgendwas anderes? Haben die das nicht einfach...
Haben die dafür nicht auch irgendwas übernommen?
Warum? Alter, was ist
mit dem Facebook-Messenger, Mann?
Alter.
Okay, jetzt kommt langsam Telegram.
Okay.
Aber WhatsApp?
Innerhalb von drei Jahren
von 0 auf 100.
Und hier unten sind die Leute so
Lull, ich hab doch nichts zu verbergen.
Warum braucht man sowas?
Nee, nee, wir bleiben bei WhatsApp.
Okay, Blackberry hat sich jetzt erledigt.
Snapchat!
Es gab doch... Moment, Leute.
Gab's nicht zwischenzeitlich auch mal
Kick-Messenger?
Also hat nichts mit diesen Billig-Klamotten zu tun.
Gab's nicht auch mal Kick-Messenger,
wo die Leute immer versucht haben auf den
ganzen Porn-Seiten die Leute zu scammen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jemals
verbreitet war, aber das gab's
doch mal.
Kick mal kurz zu sehen. Ja, Müll da.
Weg.
Man muss sich das mal überlegen.
Guck mal. 1,5
Milliarden User.
1,5
Milliarden.
Das ist übertrieben heftig.
Und wir reden jetzt hier...
Die Amis würden da Billion zu sagen,
aber die haben's bei sowas auch nicht mehr alle.
1,5
Milliarden User, Mann.
Und dass Facebook-Messenger so groß ist,
ist mir gar nicht bewusst.
Die ganzen Boomer dieser Welt sind
wahrscheinlich im Facebook-Messenger.
Leute, ich muss euch sagen, da seht
ihr mal, wie
rückständig ich eigentlich bin.
Und zwar,
ich habe weder WhatsApp
jemals installiert gehabt,
noch habe ich jemals den Facebook-Messenger
installiert gehabt, noch WeChat,
noch Tencent.
iMessage habe ich. Gut, kommt
mit dem iPhone.
Skype hatte ich auch.
Snapchat hatte ich auch noch nie. Viber noch
nie. Telegram noch nie.
Line noch nie. Und den Blackberry-Messenger
auch noch nie. Signal, ich weiß gar nicht,
ob Signal da jemals auftauchen wird.
Vielleicht ab 2020
oder so. Es zählen wahrscheinlich
alle Facebook-User. Ja, das kann
sein. Weil
ich kenne niemanden, der täglich den Facebook-Messenger
verwendet. Wobei ich das gar nicht...
Ich weiß, das muss existieren.
Ich habe halt keine Ahnung von Facebook.
Weil ich bin nicht auf Facebook aktiv.
Ich benutze Facebook und WhatsApp und Zeug
nicht. Also, ja.
Die ganzen Zoomer sind
bei Snapchat.
Und warum sind die bei Snapchat?
Weil man bei Snapchat ja
Bilder angeblich mit einem Verfallsdatum
versehen kann. Die Leute haben ja auch
damals... Wie blöd die... Wie
bescheuert eigentlich auch nicht nur
Boomer sind, ja. Ganz ehrlich,
die anderen sind auch nicht besser.
Die sind wirklich
nicht besser. Wer ernsthaft
glaubt, dass
man bei Snapchat keine Bilder
abgreifen kann, also...
Naja.
Alter, WhatsApp ist halt... WhatsApp
hat einfach jetzt seit langer Zeit
schon so die kritische Masse. Jeder hat jetzt
nur noch WhatsApp, weil alle
anderen bei WhatsApp sind.
Siehst du jetzt richtig.
Guck.
Die Leute müssen zu WhatsApp, weil alle
anderen bei WhatsApp sind.
Discord. Discord. Guck mal
da.
Man muss sich mal überlegen. Discord ist da drinnen
erst seit 2020
gar nicht so lange.
Also quasi hier jetzt, wo Corona
in vollem Gange war.
Line. Was ist eigentlich Line?
Ok, Telegram holt ein bisschen auf.
Guck mal, ganz im Ernst.
So in der... Wenn man hier
online aktiv und im Gaming-Bereich
aktiv ist, denkt man immer,
Discord
wäre so da oben
irgendwo. Ist es aber letztendlich
gar nicht. Weil Discord ist natürlich
trotzdem verbreitet. Muss man gucken.
Das hat 187 Millionen.
User.
Aber im Vergleich
zu den großen Plattformen,
Snapchat, iMessage, Telegram,
Facebook lasse ich mal außen vor.
Wahrscheinlich zählt jeder Facebook-Account auch als
Messenger-User. Und WhatsApp
ist es halt gar nicht so groß.
Nice.
Ja, fand ich tatsächlich ganz
interessant.
WeChat.
War es nicht so, dass die Leute
von WeChat gebannt
haben, weil sie bei Demonstrationen
mitgemacht haben?
Irgendwas wurde bei den China-Chinesen
gesperrt. Und wenn du irgendwie keinen Zugang zu WeChat
mehr hast, dann kannst du ja fast noch nicht mal
einkaufen gehen. Keine Ahnung.
Naja, das müssten schon mehr gewesen
sein als 5 Millionen.
Eher 5 Milliarden wahrscheinlich.
Weiß nicht, was das gekostet hat.
Facebook...
äh... Buy...
WhatsApp.
Was hat Facebook für WhatsApp? Was haben die gekauft?
Anfang 2014 schon.
17 Milliarden.
19. 19 Milliarden.
19 Milliarden, Leute.
Naja.
Das ist wahrscheinlich aus heutiger Sicht
absolutes Schnäppchen gewesen.
Und auch nicht Billion, wie die Amis immer so...
Also, die Amis sagen ja Billion. Ich meine aber
Milliarde.
Weniger als Twitter.
Ja, das stimmt voll.
Aber es war schon 2014.
Tja.
Oh.
Also, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Tja.
Kann man sich gar nicht ausdenken.
Es könnte nichts
damit zu tun haben, was die Leute
darüber schreiben.
Beziehungsweise, um zu analysieren,
was die Leute so machen und wollen
und tun und
ahnen. Weil die Daten werden selbstverständlich
nicht verwendet für irgendwelche Zwecke.
Das ist genauso wie Microsoft sicherlich
von Windows keine Sachen
schießt.
Du kannst Twitter gar nicht mehr kaufen.
Schau mal die Katz.
Wo? Welche?
Oldest Living Cat. Okay.
Ja. Oh.
Okay, der sieht auch schon alt aus.
Ah, es ist eine sie.
Okay.
Richtige Boomer Cat. Ja.
Ähm. Sie ist eine sehr schöne
Roommate. Und das ist Flossie.
Sie wurde gewählt für
die jüngste lebende Katze der Welt.
Lass mich mal raten.
Ach, okay. Wir wissen schon.
Alter. Die ist 25...
Ne. Sieben...
Bin ich jetzt plö... Sieben...
Ist die wirklich fast sieben...
Krass. Ne.
26 müssten es
dann sein.
Mal schauen, wann wir Dezember...
Ne, 2022 haben wir ja 27.
Alter.
Siebenundzwanzig
Quickmuffs. Ja.
She is 26 years old.
Sie ist fast...
fast 27.
I don't feel like
I'm living with a senior.
I was looking...
Die ist halt schon langsam und hängt ein bisschen rum. Ja.
Meine... Meine ist ja auch nicht die
jüngste. Meine ist glaube ich auch 14 oder so.
Jetzt 13... 13?
13 oder so müsste meine glaube ich jetzt
sein. Und...
Das merkst du halt schon.
Die ist halt nicht so schnell
und liegt halt den ganzen Tag rum.
...to adopt a senior cat
and... Die Katze macht auch
um 22 Uhr Bett. Genau.
...online on cats protection and she happened
to be the first senior cat that came
up and I just felt
like she was perfect.
I don't think I'll treat her any differently
because she's broken
a world record.
I adopted her on the sort of basis
that this is her retirement home
and she gets whatever
she wants. I want... So muss das sein.
Das ist nicht nur bei alten Katzen so.
Es gibt immer was die Katz will. Es ist ja nicht so als könnte
man sich das aussuchen. You know, make her
last years the best
that she's had.
I just wanna make sure she's having a good life.
Och ja.
Okay, das ist die alteste Cat.
Die alteste Cat,
Leute. Die älteste Katz.
Bin ich zu dumm zum Programmieren? Das denke ich mir auch.
Immer. Aber trotzdem kommt meistens
irgendwas raus.
Das Wichtige ist,
einfach fehlerfrei programmieren.
Dann braucht man keine
Dokumentation und keine Tests.
Damit spart man sich so
viel Geld und Zeit. Einfach
keine Fehler machen. Das ist ganz einfach.
Die Logik, oder?
Ist doch gar nicht vollkommen klar.
Einfach fehlerfrei
programmieren. Just...
Just fehlerfrei. Vorhaut.
Warum du den Boss erst am
nächsten Tag schaffst.
Wir waren alle schon mal an dem Punkt.
Okay, ne, doch nicht.
Wie geht's? Ach, mittlerweile bin ich wach.
Okay, wir können uns... Okay, was
gucken wir uns das Ding an?
Sveldkit 1.0 ist raus.
Ne, wir gucken uns jetzt das neueste Battlefield
Season Trailer an.
Pass mal auf hier, Hackerman Content.
Achtung. Bam. Und schon kann man sich's angucken.
Trotz Altersfreigabe. Habt ihr das
gesehen? Krasser Shit, oder?
Hier, guckt.
Gesperrt. Gesperrt.
Zack.
Aufrufbar.
Der neue Rechner, der steht hier ausgeschaltet hinter mir.
Okay, auf geht's.
Game Engine
Footage. Visual Quality depends on
your Hardware. Ja, das...
Also, wenn es auf meinem neuen Rechner nicht so aussieht.
Wait a minute, das ist doch...
Das ist doch die Map von der letzten Season, oder?
Ach, das ist ein Event.
Moment, das ist keine neue
Season, das ist ein Event.
Ich dachte, das ist eine neue Season.
Es ist die neue...
Ist die neue Map einfach bei Nacht, oder
wie?
Da spielt doch eh wieder keiner.
Oh ja, Breakthrough Chaos.
Das hab ich gebraucht, unbedingt.
Nice, 128
Spieler Breakthrough. Das hat mir echt noch
gefehlt in dem Spiel, Mann.
Ganz im Ernst, 128 Breakthrough war das mit
der schlechteste Spielmodus, die es jemals in
Battlefield gegeben hat.
Aber, muss ich Ihnen ja sagen, da hab ich mir wenigstens Mühe
gegeben, das zusammenzuschneiden.
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir nochmal reingucken.
Also, wir gucken auf jeden Fall...
Wir gucken auf jeden Fall zu Season 4 wieder rein.
Season 4 kommt wahrscheinlich aber erst
im Februar oder so.
Anfang 2023.
Ja.
New World Spielerzahlen, die waren
zwischenzeitlich gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Gucken wir mal schnell.
Sind natürlich wieder hart gedroppt, das ist klar.
Die haben hier quasi so eine Art Season gestartet.
So eine Art neue Season.
Man muss sich das echt mal vorstellen.
Von einer Million Spieler
runter auf zwischenzeitlich
26.000.
Das ist noch härterer Drop
als Battlefield 2042.
Minus 250.000, Mann.
Gerade ist es auch noch free.
Ich muss mal in meine Stonks reingucken.
Was machen meine Stonks eigentlich gerade?
Sekunde, Moment. Kurz die App aufmachen.
Mal kurz meine Stonks anschauen.
Ah, ich wurde ausgelockt.
Ich kann gerade nicht nachgucken.
Ich wurde ausgelockt.
Aber wir können mal gucken.
Wir können mal kurz
den Kurs uns anschauen.
Sechs Monate.
Naja.
Also Stonks sind immer noch ziemlich
im Minus hier.
Aber es hält sich in Grenzen.
Ich bin bei Scalable.
Weil es nichts kostet.
Zahlst du monatlich ein?
Ne.
Das ist recht unregelmäßig.
Aber dafür meistens
immer ein bisschen mehr.
Wie geht es der Katz?
Der geht es gut. Die liegt irgendwo rum und pennt.
Aber ich mache wieder E.
Keine Probleme.
Weil ich habe irgendwie hier so,
wo das ganz unten war,
habe ich nochmal glaube ich
für 8.000 Euro oder sowas gekauft.
Also insgesamt
bin ich wahrscheinlich immer noch ganz
ganz okay.
Wenn es jetzt noch weiter fällt, habe ich natürlich
gelitten.
Aber über lange Zeit wird sich das auch wieder
verbessern.
Warum sollte das verstorben sein?
Das ist wahrscheinlich immer noch das Beste, was man machen kann.
Wenn man keine Ahnung hat,
sich nicht damit beschäftigen will,
aber auch sein Geld nicht auf dem Konto vergammeln
lassen will.
Haha, schon Haarrisse.
Der neue PC, der funktioniert wunderbar.
Ich habe gestern das Kabel bekommen von Be Quiet.
Also das Grafikkartenkabel.
Dass ich nicht dieses komische Nvidia
Abfackelkabel verwenden muss.
Leute, ich habe echt zuständig gekriegt.
Das ist so lustig gewesen teilweise.
Wir haben hier
echte Experten am Start, Leute.
echte Experten unter Video am Start.
Was die Leute teilweise für einen Blödsinn erzählen,
ist der absolute Wahnsinn.
Du hast da teilweise Leute drunter.
Grafikkarte Schrott.
Lüfter Schrott.
Mainboard Schrott.
Für was du 5.000 Euro ausgibst.
Du hast hier einen Lüfter-Pit.
Hahaha.
Hups,
da wollte ich gar nicht draufklicken.
Das ist geil,
Alter.
Oh Mann.
Boah,
welcher Lüfter?
Das hat überhaupt keinen extra Lüfter.
Das hat eine Wasserkühlung.
Okay, die hat Lüfter.
Da sind dann echte Spezialisten
unten drunter, Mann.
Er, der meint,
dass du unbedingt Case modden musst
bei einem teuren PC.
Es ist teilweise echt schon lustig,
was da alles drunter steht.
Gut, dass die Kabel
ordentlicher hätte machen können.
Das stimmt schon, aber der Rest ist teilweise
echt...
Am besten ist der eine Typ gewesen,
der erzählt hat, er hätte sich
ein anderes Gehäuse dafür gekauft
und das Gehäuse, was er vorschlägt, würde gar nicht
die Wasserkühlung reinpassen.
Ach, was...
Ach ja,
was auch geil ist, warte mal.
Hier, gestern hat mich einer auch...
Warte mal,
da müsst ihr auch lachen, wenn ihr das seht.
Wartet mal.
Der Dude hier, John Brown.
Pass mal auf, pass mal auf.
Sag mal,
wie viel muss man gestört sein,
um nur was zu haten,
was ein Skin-Betriebssystem ist?
Ah, wie dumm kann man sein,
nur ein Betriebssystem zu ärgern,
weil es jetzt Lautstärke nicht
so gut gestört, kann man dafür sein.
Halt's Maul.
Windows 11 ist gut.
Mir gefällt das Video nicht.
Was für ein dummes Video.
Dann hat er festgestellt,
was mein Profilbild darstellen soll.
Dein Profilbild ist so,
als hätte man was abgebissen
und einen Kopfhörer aufgesetzt.
Ach nee.
Seriously, no shit.
Das wusste ich ja gar nicht.
Du hast überhaupt keine Ahnung
von Betriebssystemen und bist
irgendwie so ein Dödel im Internet,
der über Betriebssysteme redet,
aber dafür weißt du nächstes Mal
über Windows 11.
Dann hol dir halt Linux
oder hol dir einfach Windows 10
oder hol dir Chrome.
Hauptsache, tu nicht so schlecht
über Windows 11 reden.
Mein Freund hat Windows 11.
Chainlaw, bist du das?
Ist das ein Fake-Account von dir?
Wenn ich es einem zutrauen würde,
dann eh mehr.
Sein Cousin kommt vorbei, der ist eh blöd.
Nee, der ist eh dumm.
Cousin kommt vorbei, der ist eh dumm.
Es könnte auch gedrollt sein,
aber es ist so dumm,
dass es schon wieder wahr sein könnte.
Ja, Leute, man kann es sich kaum vorstellen,
aber es gibt Windows 11 Fanboys.
Unglaublich.
Unglaublich, aber wahr.
Cousin kommt vorbei, der ist dumm,
der macht das, genau.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Fanboys, also wie dieser Schrott
Fans haben kann, ist mir ja auch komp...
Also Fanboys, Fans verstehe ich ja noch irgendwie.
Wir haben uns ein Katzenvideo
angeguckt, Leute, jetzt will YouTube
Hahaha, jetzt will YouTube,
dass wir uns mehr Katzencontent angucken.
Ah, ja.
Hast du auf deinem neuen PC
Windows 10 oder Windows 11 installiert?
Windows 11.
Weil diese ganze
Geschichte aus Performance-Cores
und wie heißt das andere?
Efficiency-Cores, weil das
nur unter Windows 11
gescheit funktioniert.
Ja, exakt.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Jeden Tag im Wald.
Was verdient
ein Waldpädagoge?
Dazu müsste man jetzt erstmal wissen,
was ist ein
Waldpädagoge?
Ist das ein Lehrer, der im Wald...
Nee, das ist, das ist...
Okay, ich glaube, ich weiß es.
Das ist jemand, wo man dann beispielsweise
einen Ausflug hinmachen kann
mit seiner Schulklasse oder so
und er erzählt dann zum Beispiel
das hier ist ein giftiger Pilz und sowas.
Weißt du eigentlich, wie ich damals
2012 auf dich gekommen bin durch
dein geiles Diablo 3 Video, wo du
Demon Hunter spielst? Ich brauche mehr Hass.
Hahaha, ja.
Es...
Diablo 3, ja, das kann ich mich noch
dunkel dran erinnern.
Ich werde es mir höchstwahrscheinlich angucken,
auch wenn ich wirklich keine Hoffnung
habe, dass Blizzard da irgendwas...
langfristiges und...
ja, weiß nicht...
Gutes produziert.
Dass es beim ersten Mal
durchspielen Bock macht, kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass es ein Diablo wieder schafft, bei mir
so ein
Suchtreflexgefühl und
Monate, wenn nicht sogar jahrelanges
gekrinde auszulösen,
wie Diablo 2 damals zu Release.
Diablo 2
habe ich so viele Stunden gespielt.
Wobei, ich darf nichts sagen,
Leute, ich spiele ja gerade wieder
Dark auf einem Freeshot ein bisschen.
Und ich habe letzten Freitag angefangen
zu spielen und ich habe gestern mal
Played geguckt von meinem Char
und ich hatte, glaube ich,
fast 48 Stunden
Spielzeit. Also lasst uns
das doch mal kurz ausrechnen.
Lasst uns das mal kurz ausrechnen. Okay.
Der Freeshot ging, glaube ich, letzten
Freitag on.
Also...
Einen Tag habe ich gar nicht gespielt,
wegen Vorstellungsgespräch und alles mögliche.
Also, das ist hier. Das ging
Freitag Mittag...
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs,
sieben, acht, neun.
Gut, das zählen wir mal.
Zählen wir mal. Machen wir mal einen Tag weg.
Sagen wir mal acht, achteinhalb, sieben
Komma fünf. Sieben Komma fünf. Okay.
Sagen wir mal, ich habe zwei Stunden...
Also, ich habe
48 Stunden Spielzeit durch
sieben Komma fünf
sechseinhalb Stunden am Tag.
Kein Wunder, dass ich nicht gestreamt
habe, Videos gemacht habe oder sonst irgendwas
gemacht habe.
Und die sechseinhalb Stunden am Tag sind
Durchschnitt. Ich habe wahrscheinlich eher
manche Tage kaum was gespielt. Und gestern war ich
beispielsweise elf Stunden. Ich war elf Stunden
und ich bin um 22 Uhr ins Bett
und war ungefähr
11.30 Uhr eingeloggt. Habe den ganzen Tag
irgendwas gemacht.
Oh Mann.
Welches Betriebssystem benutzt ihr?
Das können wir machen.
Hast du dir schon mal Dark...
Ne, was ist das?
Kenn ich nicht.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein
Ego-Perspektiven-Diablo, sowas in der Richtung.
Tarkov, achso.
Oh, ja.
Also, ich habe es gerade auf Steam gefunden, da ist es
noch nicht, noch gar nicht am Start.
Was wollt ihr? Achso, Umfrage wollten wir machen.
Ah, ne, ist schon da.
Welches Betriebssystem nutzt ihr? Windows 10, 11,
Linux, Chrome, Arch...
Ich kann nicht selbst abstimmen, weil
ich hier nicht eingeloggt bin.
Kann man mehrere Sachen auswählen, weil
ich verwende, ich verwende beispielsweise
Arch, by the way, und Windows 10 parallel.
Mac, Mac
gibt es nicht, Leute. Mac ist
outdated, overrated,
in der Umfrage, gibt es nicht.
Motge, Motge müssen
auch noch wach werden.
Also,
ich dachte mir, dass die Verteilung ungefähr
so ist.
Es gibt Chrome, Chrome, ja, doch, doch.
Ja, aber dass die Verteilung
ungefähr so ist, dachte ich mir.
Windows 10 noch das meiste,
gefolgt von Windows 11, und wir wissen es,
hier sind auch einige Linux-User am Start.
Neue Umfrage,
Linux, äh, Windows, Mac, ne,
das kann ich dir ganz klar sagen, wie es ausgeht.
Windows ist auf Platz 1, und bei uns
würde ich fast vermuten,
ist immer noch Mac auf dem zweiten Platz
gefolgt von Linux, aber
bei uns ist der Linux-Anteil hier erstaunlich hoch.
Aber das ist ja auch, also,
also wir, wir, gerade auf diesem
Channel, ist,
das ist ja nicht
repräsentativ, nein, ich zocke
nicht ALP, ich spiel mit.
Ich bin, wir sind auch schon 50,
und ich bin vielleicht
heute fertig getempt, wenn ich alles
finde, und dann wird gebasht, Alter.
Zerg angesagt, ja, auf jeden Fall, dann
später, später wird Zerg, ist, ist
BG, RVR angesagt.
Oder solo irgendwelche
Leute beim Questen weghobeln.
Ne, nehmt, nehmt das Hausbetriebssystem.
Welches Linux würdest du für
ne Arbeitsplatzform empfehlen? Ich
nutze, ne, wieso?
Arch, Arch ist doch aufm Desktop wunderbar.
Wenn du einfach nur willst,
irgendwas willst, was funktioniert,
nehmt Ubuntu oder Mint, aber ich, ich mag
Arch aufm Desktop.
Bei dieser Umfrage hat Linux einen
erstaunlich hohen Anteil bekommen.
Vieles, vieles ist jetzt leider auch,
je nachdem wer fragt, nicht sonderlich aussagekräftig.
Das ist wie wenn ich im
Ubuntu-Forum frage, welches Betriebssystem
verwendet ihr so?
Ach, bei den GitHub, bei den GitHub-Umfragen
ist es auch immer nicht wirklich
repräsentativ. Da sind natürlich die
Mac- und Linux-User sehr hoch
immer dabei. Bei GitHub,
bei GitHub-Umfragen. Aber
das sind ja halt auch Leute, die
in technischen Berufen arbeiten,
Zeug programmieren oder
Sachen
administrieren müssen und sowas. Da ist natürlich
der Linux-Anteil und auch der Mac-Anteil höher
als Windows. Aber
naja.
Ach, Quatsch. Ubuntu von
Windows funktioniert wunderbar. Ich mag ehrlich gesagt
Ubuntu Desktop nicht wirklich.
Und Snaps sind auch abartig.
Aber dass die Verteilung
so oder so ähnlich ist, habe ich mir gedacht.
Wir haben theoretisch mehr
Linux-User, weil wir müssen ja Arch
beide bei Linux zusammenzählen.
Wir haben theoretisch hier mehr Linux-User
als Windows 11-User, aber
Windows 10 ist natürlich einsam an der Spitze.
Eine geile UI für Linux,
da wirst du lange suchen.
Ich mag GNOME überhaupt nicht.
Und KDE
auch nicht. Ich mag eigentlich keine
Oberfläche unter Linux. Das einzige, was
ich mag, ist I3, weil es eben keine
Oberfläche hat.
In dem Sinn.
Windows 10, das dachte ich mir,
dass das gewinnt.
Okay, jetzt schauen wir uns mal an,
was verdient ein
Waldpädagoge? Da müssen wir uns jetzt erstmal
erklären lassen, was genau
eigentlich ein Waldpädagoge macht.
Du möchtest dich als Arch
User von anderen Arch-Usern abgrenzen.
Oh, dann musst du...
Da hast du zwei Varianten. Okay, okay.
Also, pass auf.
High-IQ-Tipp. Wenn man sich als Arch-User
von anderen Arch-Usern abgrenzen muss,
du kannst in zwei Richtungen gehen. Entweder
du nimmst noch
nischigere Sachen, also nimmst
Herbstluft-WM oder irgendwie sowas,
was keine Sau benutzt.
Also nimmst quasi so
die Nischenprodukte der Nischenprodukte,
dann kannst du dich abgrenzen. Oder
du nimmst Mainstream-Shit.
Dann kannst du dich auch abgrenzen, weil
Arch, by the way, verwendet natürlich kein
Mainstream-Gedöns.
Also nimmst du... Wenn du einfach
sowas wie Arch mit
KDE verwendest, dann
ist das
schon ziemlich, ziemlich abgehoben
für Arch-User. Das heißt
wirklich so. Kein Mensch verwendet's, aber das gibt's.
Dankeschön für den
Sub. Ich hab wieder die Hälfte
vergessen vorzulesen. Kann das sein?
Oder hat heute einfach noch keiner gesubbt?
Das kann natürlich auch sein. Doch.
Mario, dankeschön für den Sub.
Take Viagra, die hard.
Virus BLN.
Danke, Leute, für die Subs. Hab ich irgendwie nicht gecheckt.
Oder du lässt es auf Wayland
laufen und hast in der VM
das Problem, dass es gar nicht funktioniert. Aber
muss man mit leben, ja.
Slimebeats,
dankeschön für den Sub.
Denkt dran, Leute.
Lasst euren Prime-Sub nicht verfallen.
Gibt es irgendjemand auf Twitch?
Aber überweist es nicht direkt an
Jesus.
Also, wenn ihr den Prime-Account verknüpft habt.
Ansonsten lasst das bleiben.
Prime-Abo
ist ab dem 1. Januar verfügbar.
Keck, wait.
Lennox, dankeschön
für den Sub. So, schauen wir uns
mal an. Also, was verdient ein
Waldpädagog? Ich hoffe, die erklären uns jetzt noch,
was ein Waldpädagoge eigentlich ist.
Tierheim am
Limit. Leute, ich hab ein Video
drüber gemacht. Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
Ich hab ein Video drüber gemacht.
Anfang von Corona.
Michi, dankeschön für den
Sub. Ich hab Anfang von Corona ein Video
drüber gemacht, dass sich
viele Leute, also, dass die Leute sich Gedanken
machen sollen, ob sie sich jetzt
in der Corona-Zeit, wenn sie daheim sitzen,
ein Tier aus dem Tierheim holen
und ob sie da wirklich Zeit für haben.
Weil du kannst das halt nicht ein- und
ausschalten. Und viele Leute werden nach
Corona merken, dass das doch
nix für sie ist, weil es hatte wahrscheinlich
seinen Grund, dass sie vorher auch
kein Haustier hatten. So, und wenn du
wenn sich jemand ordentlich Gedanken drüber macht,
sich dann eins holt und dann auch
das behält, dann ist da nix dagegen einzuwenden.
Aber die Leute, die einfach wieder komplett
Brain-AFK durchs Leben laufen,
was ja irgendwie locker 60,
70 Prozent der Bevölkerung macht,
und sich denkt, ach ja,
jetzt hab ich ja Zeit und ja,
jetzt wär's natürlich schön mit dem Haustier daheim,
sie ein Haustier holen
und wenn sie dann keine Zeit mehr haben,
sagen, wir geben es wieder ab.
Das ist halt richtig und das ist halt unter aller Sau.
Deswegen ist auch das Einzige, was
ich irgendwie spende, immer ans Tierheim.
Kann man einen Hund leasen?
Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn das sogar
geht. Die holen die Tiere
nicht mal aus dem Tierheim. Ja, das ist noch blöder.
Das ist noch blöder.
Und dann geben sie sie im Tierheim ab.
Ja, und gerade jetzt, wo alles teurer
geworden ist,
ich spende ans Tierheim.
Mich interessieren arme Kinder in Afrika nicht,
aber mich interessiert's, ob's
dem Tier in dem Tierheim gut geht.
Ich mein, kann jeder machen,
was er will mit seinem Geld.
Toss. Warum ist das toss?
Ich kann mit meinem Geld machen, was ich will.
Und ich geb's lieber fürs Tierheim aus.
Ihr wisst, ich hab's mit Menschen eh nicht so.
Also, wenn ich die Auswahl hab,
für allgemeinnützige Sachen zu spenden
oder für Kinder in Afrika oder für Schulen
in Bangladesch oder
was weiß ich, für
Erdbebenopfer oder
sonst was, vergesst,
ich spende lieber ans Tierheim.
Deswegen hast du auch WhatsApp?
Ja, deswegen hasse ich WhatsApp, korrekt.
Ich ficke nicht, Ceylo,
ich ficke nicht die dritte Welt,
sondern die erste
und die zweite auch noch.
Die interessieren mich genauso wenig.
Das ist auch eine gute Idee.
Das ist wichtig,
dass er sich sein Porsche leisten kann.
Gucken wir mal, was macht ein
Waldpädagoge?
Das ist auch ein Grund dafür,
da sehe ich nämlich, was passiert.
Ich spende beispielsweise
auch ganz gerne mal an
was weiß ich,
eine Katze braucht eine OP oder so.
Ich meine, was ich nicht mache ist,
irgendwie Indiegogo oder sowas
oder was wie GoFundMe
oder was es da gibt,
weil dort ist leider
irgendwie,
ich kann es prozentual nicht sagen,
aber da ist leider so viel Fake dabei.
Ich habe mir da schon
manchmal die Seiten angeguckt
und ich dachte mir schon öfters, ey, wenn das
wirklich echt ist, würde ich dafür tatsächlich
gerne spenden, aber du weißt es halt nicht.
Und dementsprechend, dafür mache ich das nicht.
Wenn ich spende, ist es entweder bei mir
hier ans Tierheim, da wo ich Chico her habe,
an die Katzenhilfe in Karlsruhe
habe ich schon einige Sachen gespendet
oder auch von
irgendwelchen Tierheimen, wo dann beispielsweise
steht, hier wir haben jetzt
was weiß ich, drei super
abgemagerte Katzen gefunden,
wurden irgendwie zurückgelassen,
die eine braucht irgendwie eine OP,
kostet 300 Euro und sowas.
Da spende ich dann auch mal ganz gerne was für.
Und da sieht man ja dann auch direkt, was da
mit gemacht wird und dass es was bringt.
Einfach auf Onlyfans spenden,
ja.
Wo ist eigentlich das Emote?
Das wurde entfernt, oder?
Gibt kein
Wanke Emote mehr.
Wanke
wurde entfernt.
War zu tos,
das Emote.
GPT
ist absolut High IQ Sache.
Wir haben letztens
Chat GPT sogar
befragt, was man gegen
Backseating im Chat machen kann.
Und die Antwort war tatsächlich gar nicht so
schlecht. Ja, Salami
ist auch nicht mehr
als Emote.
Also wir gucken uns mal an, was macht denn ein Waldpädagoge?
Ich hoffe, die erklären uns erstmal, was ein
Waldpädagoge überhaupt ist.
Natur geht da oft in
Vergessenheit und da ist es eine
wichtige Aufgabe, das den Menschen
näher zu bringen.
Okay, den ganzen Tag mit Menschen und noch
mit Kindern zu tun zu haben, das wäre
schon mal nichts für mich.
Ich kann mir mit meinem Geld nicht vorstellen,
eine Familie ernähren zu können.
Ich wollte mietfrei sein.
Ich wollte irgendwie was eigenes haben.
Und dann ist mir die Idee mit den Tiny Houses.
Was geht mit der Musik?
Was?
Was zum? Moment.
Schmoll. Schmoll Haus.
Jetzt habe ich es wieder nicht gesehen.
Chat. Was ist denn das?
Das ist eine
Hütte auf der Seite.
Das sind quasi zwei Hütten aneinander.
Hehe.
Das hat irgendwie was.
In Wirklichkeit ist er da hinten drinnen.
Genau.
Das hat irgendwie was.
Es ist halt nicht sonderlich breit.
Okay.
Grüß euch, ich bin der Andreas.
Ich bin 28 Jahre alt.
Forstwirt und Waldpädagoge
hier im Walderlebniszentrum
Fernfeld.
Quasi Schlauchlevel.
Ja.
Die Wasserstation auf.
Da bringen wir jetzt das Material hinter.
Das ist die Vorbereitung
für die Klasse 30.
Warum ist... Alter, Leute.
Das sieht nicht bei euch nur so schlecht aus.
Die Bildqualität ist mega, mega mies.
Weil es doch recht viel...
Also das Pixel ist...
Ich habe noch nie eine Führung
später angefangen, weil ich nicht vorbereitet war.
Aber das kann man...
Guckt euch mal das Gepixel an.
Das kann man von der ARD bzw. vom BR
natürlich auch nicht erwarten.
Dass sie wissen, wie man Videos encodet.
Guckt euch mal den Hintergrund an, Mann.
Seht ihr das? Kannst du nichts erkennen.
Also kann man nicht erwarten, dass dort jemand weiß, wie man Videos encodet.
Guck mal hier hinten.
Da ist uns aufgefallen, dass da ganz appetitlich
ein Tier drauf gemacht hat.
Ach ja, nice.
Ich muss mal schauen, dass ich das da irgendwie noch...
Dass die Kinder da sitzen können.
Erstmal schön draufgestuhlt.
Ja.
Also es ist...
Was man ja wirklich so nennt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das Wort dafür finde.
Also so dieser gemütliche Waldspaziergang ist...
Rauchgeschissen auf deutsch.
Also jetzt sind wir an der Riechstation.
Das war jetzt unglücklicher Übergang.
Erst die Kacke entfernt
und dann sind wir an der Riechstation.
Also was?
Also der Holunder, der schaut
nicht mehr gut aus. Die Minze schaut nicht mehr gut aus.
Die holen wir mal neu.
Alles da.
Okay, das war's.
So, jetzt haben wir...
Jetzt haben wir knapp eine Viertelstunde noch Zeit.
Das ist genau das, was ich wollte.
Dass man jetzt nochmal was essen kann, was trinken kann.
Ähm...
Acreegel.
Nochmal durchatmen, nochmal den Kopf...
Essen und Trinken ist immer Top-Priorität, sehe ich auch so.
Das ist mir halt persönlich immer wichtig.
Deswegen am Anfang ein bisschen hetzen
und dann ist man ein bisschen entspannter.
Erst hetzen und dann essen.
Das ist ne gute Kombination.
Gibt's jetzt noch ne Butterbreze.
Was auch sonst in Bayern.
...was losgehen hat.
Hä? Die wollte ich doch gar nicht.
Na ja.
Also während der Schulzeit war mir schon klar,
dass ich ins Handwerk will.
Dass ich einen handwerklichen Beruf möchte.
Auch mit Holz.
Mit Holz? Da ist er!
Der endlich einer, der was mit Holz macht.
Für mich war das ja nix.
Ich hab da aber dann
grad so als Geselle dann
gemerkt, dass es nicht das ist, was ich mir
eigentlich als Schreiner vorgestellt hab.
Und hab dann überlegt, was ich anstelle
machen könnte und dann ist mir so gekommen,
wo bleibt immer die Natur Natur?
Wo werde ich immer ein Holzprodukt haben?
Und das ist ein Wald.
Da ist was dran.
Ohne Holz
kein Wald.
So, ihr dürft euch mal
so hinsetzen,
dass ihr zu uns schauen könnt.
Wunderschöne
Die sind...
unrealistisch brav,
die Kinder.
Da schreit keiner rum.
Da macht keiner irgendeinen Scheiß.
Da rennt keiner irgendwie weg.
Da versteckt sich keiner.
Das ist wirklich sehr sass.
Ja, die sehen auch überhaupt nicht gelangweilt aus.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich
wirklich daran, weil die aufgenommen werden,
dass sie sich benehmen, ja.
Aber jetzt habt ihr schon gehört,
es geht um Stationen,
die wir jetzt heute machen werden,
weil obwohl jetzt so viele Eltern dabei
sind und wir so viele sind
und noch ein Kamerateam mitläuft,
werdet ihr heute...
Achso, die Eltern sind dabei, deswegen sind die so brav.
...ganz alleine durch den Wald laufen.
Ja.
Aber...
Aber wir laufen heute...
...nur auf den gelben Hasen.
Also immer der Schnauze nach,
da wo der Hase hinläuft, da läuft sie auch hin.
Welcher Hase?
Ah, das da.
Und dann kommt's hier
an Stationen.
Also dürft ihr ganz gespannt sein,
was euch da erwartet.
Das Encoding ist wieder on point im Hintergrund.
Kommt mal her zu mir.
Ja.
Jetzt habe ich hier fünf Gegenstände liegen,
da wollte ich jetzt mal von euch wissen,
welche Gegenstände ihr haben wollt.
Ihr dürft mal eure Hand...
Und auf welches davon hat heute Morgen der Dachs geschissen?
...ausziehen, weil das ist jetzt hier die Fühl- und Riechstation
und da braucht ihr eure Hände.
Ihr müsst jetzt diese fünf Gegenstände
am Geruch und am Fühlen
wiedererkennen
und umso mehr ihr erkennt,
umso mehr Punkte kriegt ihr.
So.
So, jetzt haben's alle gehabt.
Auf drei dürft ihr sagen. Eins, zwei, drei.
Wohl.
Richtig, sehr gut. Dann machen wir den nächsten Gegenstand.
Bei mir in meinem speziellen Fall
war mir von Anfang an klar,
dass ich gerne mit Kindern arbeite,
dass mir das unglaublich viel Spaß macht.
Das ist das Schlimmste,
was ich mir vorstellen könnte mit Kinderarbeiten.
Also generell mit Menschen arbeiten
wäre schon Horror,
aber dann auch noch mit Kindern,
wäre noch schlimmer.
Trotzdem beides einbringen kann.
Ich kann mein Handwerk einbringen,
ich kann da ganz normal für mich arbeiten
und kann aber trotzdem immer wieder mit den Kindern arbeiten
und habe dadurch eine super Abwechslung.
Was mit Holz und Menschen?
Max, Traumjob.
Das sind zwei Sachen,
wo ich wirklich sagen muss,
es gibt ja Jobs,
die könnte man theoretisch noch machen,
aber das ist ja doppelt schon schlimm.
Es ist was mit Holz
und es ist was mit Menschen
und es sind auch noch Kinder.
Das ist ja dreifach schlimm.
Ja, also da lang durch den Wald wandern
und so, das würde ich auch machen,
aber halt ohne Kinder.
Ihr müsst diese Puzzle wieder zusammenbauen.
Und was jetzt noch dazu kommt,
diese drei Baumarten
haben unterschiedliche Rinde.
Das sind wahrscheinlich
die einzigen drei,
die sich halbwegs benommen haben.
So, letzte Station,
dann habt ihr es geschafft.
Okay, dürft ihr mal hier herkommen
und ihr dürft ja mal verraten,
was ihr hier schon an Tieren erkennt.
Wir fangen da oben an.
Also ich wäre eher für ein Twitch-Emote-Quiz.
Also ich verdiene jetzt
ungefähr 3.000 Euro brutto
und das macht dann ungefähr
1.900 Pound-Parts verquetschte netto aus.
Also ich kann mir mit meinem Geld
nicht vorstellen,
eine Familie ernähren zu können,
aber die Arbeit macht mir unglaublich Spaß
und es wäre wirklich traurig,
wenn es aufgrund des Verdienstes
enden müsste.
Machen wir hier noch mal
einen großen Kreis.
Ja, jetzt ist das spannend.
Jetzt sieht es aus,
als würde man sich mal
in den Wald bewegen.
Jetzt ist die Frage,
wie viel Monatsgehälter?
Wahrscheinlich 12.
Ihr habt super toll mitgemacht.
Ihr wart eine tolle Klasse.
Man hat gemerkt,
ihr kennt euch schon super aus im Wald.
Ihr seid teilweise richtige Waldspezialisten.
Bleibt daran, macht es weiter so.
Habt weiterhin Interesse vom Wald.
Ich wünsche euch jetzt
einen schönen Nachhauseweg zurück in die Schule.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Alles klar.
Auf Wiedersehen Scherenfeller Schule.
Die sind wirklich nur so brav,
weil die Kamera dabei war.
Das ist die perfekte Mischung.
Jetzt kann ich genau das,
was ich sechs Jahre lang in der Berufsschule gelernt habe,
mit beiden Ausbildungen zusammen hier anwenden.
Gibt es auch nur so.
Kann man jetzt auch nicht mit einer normalen
Forstwirtsarbeit vergleichen,
kann man nicht mit einem normalen Schreiner
vergleichen, weil der das nicht hat,
sondern das gibt es wirklich nur hier
im Walderlebniszentrum.
Im Walderlebniszentrum.
Immerhin, eins muss man ja mal sagen,
auch wenn es überhaupt nicht
ein Job für mich wäre,
das ist ja auch alles in Ordnung,
der arbeitet den ganzen Tag.
Also
ein Trend, den ich in diesen Videos
feststelle ist,
es gibt eine riesen Diskrepanz
zwischen Jobs, wo tatsächlich
gearbeitet wird
und wo so getan wird,
als ob gearbeitet wird.
So irgendwelche Bullshit
Schwätzerjobs, die
irgendwie den Eindruck machen,
als sind sie so super, super beschäftigt
und den ganzen Tag am Machen,
aber eigentlich machen sie den halben Tag nichts
und Jobs, die tatsächlich von morgens bis abends
unterwegs sind und am Arbeiten.
Wenn man das hier mal durchguckt,
wir haben jetzt total viel Zeug
uns schon angeguckt,
da hast du zum Beispiel
solche Sachen hier
zwischendrin wie
der E-Commerce
Junior Manager, den hatten wir
zum Beispiel, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Der hat
irgendwie den halben Tag lang
eine
HTML,
was war das, der hat irgendwie einen Button
einen Button in HTML
copy-paste den ganzen Tag.
Da denke ich mir so, was macht der eigentlich den ganzen Tag
und hier auf der anderen Seite haben wir den Typ,
der die Klos repariert, der war den ganzen Tag unterwegs.
... den Schulkindern
erzählen, dass man
was gegen Klimawandel machen muss
und dann fährt man selber...
Ja, als jemand, der den ganzen Tag arbeitet
...
Das liegt aber auch daran,
das habe ich aber auch schon öfters gesagt,
dass du, wenn du einen Beruf
hast, wo du dich
konzentrieren musst,
also wenn du beispielsweise irgendwas
nehmen wir an, du musst irgendwas programmieren,
du kannst das nicht 8 Stunden am Tag machen.
Niemand kann sich 8 Stunden am Tag geistig
komplett konzentrieren, um da
sinnvolle Sachen
auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
Das kriegst du vielleicht 2-2,5 Stunden am Tag hin
Der Rest ist halt dann beiweg, dass gemacht werden muss, ja, von Daily Meetings bis Gruppenrunden, bis Retrospektive, bis Ticketbearbeitung, bis irgendwelche Sprintplanung, bis irgendwelche anderen Absprachen und solche Geschichten, also du bist schon den ganzen Tag irgendwie beschäftigt, aber so wirklich produktiv arbeiten machst du vielleicht zweieinhalb Stunden am Tag, weil du kannst dich auch einfach gar nicht länger am Stück konzentrieren, das funktioniert nicht.
Wenn ein Auto steht, da habe ich halt immer eine Ausrede gefunden, dass man Auto fährt.
Die Kündigung ist noch nicht raus, die Kündigung ist dann, ist hier raus, also die werde ich wahrscheinlich hier abgeben nächste Woche dann.
Gut, ich will Werkzeug mitnehmen, auch heute will ich danach direkt zum Einkaufen fahren und so bin ich halt doch jedes Mal mit dem Auto gefahren und dann habe ich gesagt, wenn, dann muss man es konsequent machen, Auto verkaufen und nur Fahrrad fahren, ja, dann habe ich halt mein Auto verkauft und das Fahrrad gekauft.
Chainlaw, gute Idee.
Schönen Feierabend.
Da flitzt's, das flitzt.
Leute, habe ich euch erzählt, dass ich mein Auto kaputt gemacht habe, wo ich den gerade Fahrrad fahren sehe?
Habe ich euch erzählt, dass ich mein neues Auto kaputt gemacht habe?
Den Reifen, den Reifen und die Felge ein bisschen, also.
Ich habe das Auto jetzt seit drei Monaten ungefähr und ich habe es geschafft über einen Bordstein zu fahren, so mit 50 kmh ungefähr.
Und da ist der Reifen geplatzt.
Ja, richtig, richtig Threehead, aber richtig, Leute, ja.
Da ist der Reifen geplatzt.
Oder was weiß ich, ob der geplatzt ist, aber der hat ein Loch gehabt, vielleicht hat er sich auch aufgerieben oder so.
Ich glaube, der ist geplatzt.
Der Reifen hat ein Loch an der Seite.
So, und ich habe den dann versucht zu fixen mit diesem mitgelieferten Reifen-Fix-Kit, dass ich zur Werkstatt komme, das hat natürlich nicht funktioniert.
Weil das Loch an der Seite.
Ja, das ist komplett aufgerissen, riesengroß, kannst du vergessen.
Ja, komplett, komplett im Arsch.
Zumindest, ich bin dann quasi mehr oder weniger auf der Felge heimgefahren, in die Werkstatt, die haben dann gesagt, hey, wir müssen jetzt gucken, ob die Felge kaputt ist und Ersatzreifen gibt es nicht mehr, habe ich nicht mehr.
Und außerdem kann ich Ersatzreifen auch nicht einfach auswechseln, das Auto ist mega schwer, so, zumindest haben die mir dann erzählt, vielleicht ist die Felge kaputt.
Zumindest haben die mir dann erzählt, vielleicht ist die Felge kaputt.
Kostet irgendwie nochmal 400 Euro extra.
Dann muss der Reifen getauscht werden.
Plus, theoretisch empfiehlt Fiat, beide Reifen zu tauschen.
Nope.
Fiat empfiehlt beide Seiten Reifen zu tauschen an einer Achse, auch wenn nur einer kaputt ist.
Weil, ähm, ansonsten das Bremssystem irgendwie Probleme machen könnte.
Oh, easy.
So.
So, jetzt haben wir das hier in der Werkstatt abgegeben, zwei Tage später konnte ich es wieder abholen, war gefixt.
Und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Wisst ihr, was ich danach festgestellt habe?
Ich hätte nichts davon machen müssen.
Ich hätte nichts davon machen müssen, weil ich habe eigentlich, ich habe eigentlich das hier, während ich, während ich noch in der Garantie bin.
Und ich habe, ich habe in meinem Auto einen Assist-Knopf an der Decke.
Guckt mal.
Ja, den sieht man jetzt.
Den sieht man jetzt hier nicht.
Am Spiegel ist ein Assist-Knopf, den hätte ich einfach draufdrücken müssen.
Und, dann hätten die mir jemanden vorbeigeschickt, hätten mich abgeschleppt, hätten mir sogar ein Ersatzfahrzeug gegeben für zwei Tage.
Aber auch nicht for free, doch.
Glaube ich zumindest.
Ja.
Also, habe ich jetzt halt verkackt, aber auf der anderen Seite, jetzt habe ich das Auto wieder und alles ist gut.
Was hat er denn, was hat er denn geschrieben?
Okay, das war so schlimm, dass das gelöscht werden musste.
Okay, okay.
Okay, Achtung, Achtung.
Jetzt muss ich, ich, ich, Mods, Modgis, kann ich mir das angucken, ohne, ohne, dass was passiert?
Ich bin jetzt neugierig, was hat er denn geschrieben?
Egal, ich gucke jetzt drauf.
Ist nicht schlimm.
Ich habe sogar selbst auf Twitter geschrieben, ich bin der schlechteste Autofahrer.
Das geht.
Ich kann, ich kann euch sogar, ich kann euch sogar erklären, wie ich das, wie ich das auf die Reihe gekriegt habe mit gegen den Bordstein fahren.
Also, es ist ja relativ kalt draußen, ja.
Und an dem Tag war auch, also es war glücklich.
Sicherweise morgens um acht, da ist keiner unterwegs.
Also, Scheibe war am Anfang gefroren.
Ich habe das Auto vorklimatisieren lassen und alles gut.
Und da passiert es halt, dass, wenn es kalt draußen ist, dass die Scheibe nicht nur außen gefroren ist, sondern innen sich auch so ein bisschen Wasser bildet.
Und es läuft dann so die Scheibe runter.
Also, was habe ich gemacht?
Ich habe einen Lappen genommen, während ich am Fahren war.
Und wollte die Scheibe an der Seite abholen.
Und wollte die Scheibe abputzen.
Und aus irgendwelchen High-IQ-Gründen bin ich auf die Idee gekommen, das in so einer leichten Kurve zu machen.
Und ich habe schon rum, also ich habe nicht genug rumgelenkt.
Ich habe rumgelenkt, habe den Lappen genommen und wollte die Scheibe abputzen.
Und ich habe halt dann nicht weit genug rumgelenkt.
Und dann bin ich dann quasi auf so eine, mit dem Reifen auf so eine, so eine, so eine, so eine, so eine Scheibe.
So eine Scheibe.
Bordsteinbegrenzung draufgefahren
und ich hab das auch direkt
gemerkt, also
es hat ordentlich gemacht, wumms
ist dann so ein bisschen abgeprallt davon wahrscheinlich
und es hat ordentlich gemacht
wumms
und ich hab direkt danach gemerkt
auf der rechten Seite fühlt sich's aber
irgendwie komisch an
und nach ein paar hundert Metern mehr
hab ich schon
gemerkt, dass es sich komisch anhört
und dann dachte ich mir auch, fuck
hoffentlich hab ich keinen Plattenreifen
und nach noch ein paar hundert
Meter mehr hab ich schon gehört
wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp
oh ja, scheiße
Alter, Dubstep Reifen
ja, aber die Felge war
nicht kaputt, doch
doch, doch, zeigt er auch
der hat dann auch Warnung angezeigt, Tire Pressure
Tire Pressure
Low
doch, hat er angezeigt, Tire Pressure Low
und sogar in der App
hat man's gesehen, zumindest
die Felge hat's überlebt
das einzige, was an der Felge jetzt noch ist
ein paar Kratzer
Warnung im Zabbix bekommen
ne, aber in meinem Home Assistant hab ich tatsächlich
die Warnung angezeigt bekommen, weil
in meinem Home Assistant
hab ich ja ein Dashboard
was ungefähr so aussieht
und da sieht man hier Reifendruck
da hat dann hier Reifendruck
Reifendruck
gestanden
da stand da nicht Error, da stand irgendwas anderes
hab vergessen, was da stand
das hat er angezeigt
zumindest die Felge ist nicht kaputt, die hat aber Kratzer
ist aber nicht schlimm
die haben das in der Werkstatt überprüft
meint, die ist alles noch gerade
und funktioniert noch
ich frage mich, aus welchem Material
die Felgen sind
ich hab das Gefühl, die sind
nicht mehr rein aus irgendwie Metall
sondern das ist irgend so ne Mischung, weil
die sind
die sind so ein bisschen gebröselt
also an der Seite
an der Seite, wo ich dagegen gefahren bin
ist so ein bisschen abgebröselt
von der Felge
gut, vielleicht ist das auch, weil es Alu ist
also es hat sich
es hat sich nicht
es hat sich nicht irgendwie verbogen, sondern es ist einfach abgebröselt
an der Stelle, wo zu viel Druck
drauf, also zu viel
wo der Aufschlag war
komisch, weiß ich auch, was die sind
wir können gucken, aus was meine Felgen sind
Moment
wir gucken
wir gucken einfach mal aus, was meine Felgen sind
verkaufst du deine alte 1080Ti
1080Ti, nö
konfigurieren
äh, nein, nein, nein, nein
den 500E brauchen wir
500E, wo ist er denn überhaupt
da
sag mal, ist
wie, wie, wie bescheuert
hä
ok, da kann man jetzt nämlich die Felgen auswählen
also hier
Leichtmetall Felgen mit Diamant Finish
sind das die, die ich auch hab, zeig mal her
sieht, sieht ein bisschen, sieht ein bisschen so aus
ne, die sind anders aus
meine Felgen sehen anders aus, Leute, das sind die nicht
ok
ich will jetzt wissen, was ich für Felgen hab
Sekunde, Sekunde
konfigurieren
hä, ne
wähl ich, wähl ich das falsche Auto aus
kann das sein
bin ich zu blöd, mein Auto auszuwählen
ne, so sehen meine Felgen auch nicht aus
sieht man die jetzt hier
ja, so sehen meine, das sieht man nicht aus
so sehen meine, das, so sehen die aus
so sehen die aus, so sehen die aus
ok
so sehen die aus
16, 16 Zoll Leichtmetall
ja gut, da weiß ich jetzt aber trotzdem nicht
aus was die, aus was die sind
ist immer Alu, alles klar
Six Head Chat weiß Bescheid
ja, für den Preis
hab ich das ja auch nicht gekauft
am besten war mein
also ich hab bezahlt
ich glaub 25.500
ach, 23.000, Chat, ich hab's euch erzählt
ich sag mal 25.000 ungefähr
hab ich glaub ich bezahlt
warte mal, ich hab's auf Twitter
ich weiß es, ich, auf Twitter hab ich's gepostet
was gekostet war
also aktuell hab ich irgendwie
7.500 Kilometer oder sowas
25.200 hab ich bezahlt
also mal, also
Prämie und so gibt's ja dieses Jahr noch
ist, ist natürlich ne ordentliche Summe, ja
ja, ja 2021
k, könnte sogar 2022 sein?
2022 Baujahr sein
ich weiß gar nicht genau
die Umweltprämie gibt's
weiterhin, ist aber weniger
tja, weiß ich auch nicht
warum ich das aktiviert hab
ja, aber da guck ich jetzt nicht rein
Husa, Dankeschön für den Sub
so, ok, also
das Problem mit der Umweltprämie ist
dass es nicht um das
abschließen quasi
des Vertrages geht, sondern
dann wann du das einreichst
was halt ziemlich bescheuert ist, also zum Beispiel
wenn ich jetzt
ein Auto verbindlich kaufe
dieses Jahr noch
bekomm ich die Umweltprämie
erst, wenn ich es habe
und den Antrag eingereicht
habe und es zählt quasi wann der
Antrag dort eingeht, das heißt ich krieg auf
jeden Fall nicht mehr
die volle Prämie für dieses Jahr
und dementsprechend glaub ich
haben sich da bestimmt noch ein paar Leute zurückgehalten
die sich gedacht haben, keine Ahnung ob das noch was
wird oder nicht
was wegfällt ist
für Hybridautos fällt es
mit der Prämie komplett weg
und ich glaub für Elektroautos
ab 40.000 Euro
fällt es glaub ich auch weg
oder waren es 60.000 Euro
weiß ich aus dem Kopf jetzt grad nicht
gibt man noch Zuschuss
für Ladestationen, ne das gibt's nicht
aber es gibt die Möglichkeit an manchen Stellen kostenlos
zu laden, zum Beispiel beim Ikea
kannst du kostenlos laden
natürlich sollte man dann
nach Möglichkeit auch in Ikea
gehen, weil die machen das ja nicht einfach
aus Nächstenliebe
also
das ging noch
ich bin aber auch schon vor
2 oder 3 Monaten da gewesen
das ging noch beim Ikea
wenn denn frei ist
was meistens nicht ist
hat deine Arbeit keine Ladestation, ne
über 50.000 war es
ja
also ganz ehrlich, ich habe überhaupt keine Probleme
mit der Reichweite
weil ich das Auto ja absichtlich gekauft habe
weil ich nur hier bei mir in der Gegend rumfahre
wenn ich jetzt ein Auto
sagen wir mal ich wäre jetzt irgendwie Versicherungsvertreter
oder sowas
würde ich im Leben nicht machen
theoretisch angenommen
ich wäre super krasser IT-Konsultant
und wäre den ganzen Tag quer durch Deutschland unterwegs
dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich auch kein Elektroauto
kaufen, also wenn ich wirklich jeden
Tag mehrere hundert Kilometer fahre
dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich kein Elektroauto kaufen
auch wenn das theoretisch vielleicht
geht, weil die Ladeinfrastruktur
ist ja mittlerweile ganz brauchbar
ich gucke ja immer in der App
also ist immer irgendwo was in Reichweite
aber ganz ehrlich, dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich
kein Elektroauto kaufen
aber ansonsten ist das für mich das beste
Auto, ich fahre am Tag
wenn ich überhaupt am Tag fahre
ja
mal, also wahrscheinlich
ist es pro Tag gerechnet bei mir auch bescheuert
weil ich fahre
viele Tage gar nicht
und wenn, dann fahre ich was einkaufen mal irgendwo
zu wandern hin, also alles immer
weit unter 100 Kilometer
dafür ist das super
also eine Sache muss man aber halt auch sagen
jetzt im Winter, jetzt wo es so richtig kalt
ist, ist die Akkuleistung
ein bisschen geringer
also man verbraucht ein bisschen mehr, weil man eben
Heizung und alles anhat und der Akku
muss ja auch geheizt werden und so Zeug
aber auch
der hat auch gefühlt ein bisschen weniger Kapazität
also
sonst wenn ich so zum Wandern fahre
brauche ich
naja sagen wir mal so 7-8%
vom Akku
also in eine Richtung
und jetzt brauche ich teilweise 15-16%
vom Akku
aber jetzt ist halt auch
minus 8 Grad
Heizung an, alles, also das ist schon ein Unterschied
ja, das merkt man, also
man kommt deutlich weniger
weit, wenn es kalt ist
was aber für mich kein Problem
ist, weil das alles immer noch wunderbar in den
in der Reichweite liegt
das kann ich dir so genau nicht sagen
aber so über den Daumen gepeilt sind 7-8%
vom Akku
ob das jetzt nur bei
von 100 auf 90 ist
oder auch von 50 auf 40
das kann ich dir so im Kopf nicht sagen
vielleicht, aber insgesamt fährst
du trotzdem, wenn es kalt ist
kannst du nicht so weit fahren
ne, aber Elektroauto war sinnvoll
und was halt auch cool ist, zum Beispiel, dass ich
die Heizung anschalten kann
oder so, ja
dass ich die Heizung anschalten kann
über Home Assistant, beziehungsweise über die App
das ist halt praktisch
gerade jetzt, minus 8 Grad
draußen, ich guck mal kurz, wie kalt es hier
draußen ist, lass mal kurz schauen
es ist minus
minus 7,22
ich habe eine Wetterstation
draußen hängen, bei mir mittlerweile im
Hof, am Dach
minus, minus 7,5 Grad
und da
ist natürlich immer die Scheibe dicht
immer, kannst du gar nichts dagegen machen, Scheibe ist dicht
und da drücke ich einfach bei mir
in der App oder im Home Assistant auf
Heizen
dann gehe ich 5 bis 10 Minuten später
ans Auto
und die Scheibe ist frei
das Tor
kann ich gerade nicht machen
ich will ja mein Hoftor automatisch öffnen
und schließbar machen, das kann ich gerade nicht machen
es ist mir zu kalt draußen
hast du keine Garage, doch
ich habe eine Garage
aber da passt das Auto nicht rein
die Garage hat der Opa mal irgendwann gebaut
für seine kleine Karre
und da ist das Auto zu breit für
du würdest vielleicht
vielleicht mit eingeklappten
Spiegeln, würdest du
vielleicht gerade so reinkommen
aber dann kriegst du die Tür nicht auf
ja
der ist zu breit
also mein altes Auto
war
mit Außenspiegel
ungefähr
so breit
wie mein neues
ohne Spiegel
es ist schon links und rechts so
30 cm breiter
das Ding insgesamt
ungefähr so über den Daumen
20 cm
aber das passt nicht in die Garage rein
oder 30 cm
das ist halt schon ein Unterschied
passt nicht in die Garage rein
ist aber auch nicht schlimm
weil das rein und raus fahren mit der Garage ist eh eklig
ich fahre in den Hof
weil im Hof hängt auch die Ladestation
hehehe
ja klar links und rechts
und dann fällt die Wand runter
ähm
die Ladestation hängt ja auch im Hof
bisschen unterm Dach
ich fahre einfach in den Hof rein
und schließe das da an
deswegen will ich ja auch das Hoftor elektrisch machen
kann ich dann draußen
auf dem Display
vom Auto drücken
Hoftor öffnen oder Knopf drücken oder so
oder Voice Assistant sagen
Hoftor auf
ne interessiert mich das überhaupt nicht
juckts mich
äh ne kein Ding ich hab den Motor schon
Neue Garage bauen
ja wenn ich irgendwie nochmal
15.000 € oder so ausgeben will
keine Ahnung was es kostet eine Garage zu bauen
dann würde ich das machen aber ne
das lassen wir bleiben
es gibt keine neue Garage
nur elektrisch
äh ich brauch keine Sensoren
weil ich hab die Möglichkeit
ähm
das über die Fiat App zu machen
also beziehungsweise
über meine eigene selbstprogrammierte Home Assistant Integration
weil ich mitbekomme
wenn der Fiat
GPS
gewisse GPS Koordinaten rein fährt
da kann ich auf und zu machen
alternativ
kann ich es über Voice Command öffnen
oder mit nem Knopf
oder übers Display
mit Kamera Kennzeichen
Erkennung
ne ich brauch keine Kamera Kennzeichen Erkennung
weil
das nur für mein Auto funktioniert
also
ich bin ja eingeloggt bei Fiat
und ich hab dort über den Account die GPS
Koordinaten und man kann in der App
ein Radius definieren
wo es dann eine Benachrichtigung
schickt wenn das Auto sich
in diesen Bereich begibt
oder aus dem Bereich
herausfährt und auf diese
Benachrichtigung kann ich reagieren mit Home Assistant Integration
und dann könnte ich da drüber
das Hoftor auf und zu machen
mach ich aber nicht
ich machs höchstwahrscheinlich über Voice Command
ich hab ja nen Voice Command Button auf dem Lenkrad
drückste drauf
oder man kann auch sagen Hey Fiat
richtig cringe alter
ich benutze nie dieses Wake Up Word
Hey Fiat klingt richtig bescheuert ne
ich könnte dann auch sagen
Hey Fiat mach das Hoftor auf
oder sowas in der Richtung
wobei das halt nur funktioniert wenn du ein iPhone
Android per Carplay oder Android
Android also drüber gepairt hast
aber gut
das muss ich ausprobieren
das muss ich ausprobieren wie das am besten funktioniert
wahrscheinlich werde ich am Ende einfach einen Knopf drücken
ok was können wir uns denn noch anschauen
also wir haben den Waldpädagoge noch gar nicht
fertig geguckt
was verdient er denn am Ende jetzt
ich wollte mietfrei sein
ich wollte irgendwie was eigenes haben
das ist ja wirklich ein Mini Haus
Tiny Haus
mobiles Tiny Haus
das ist mobil ach das kann man bewegen
das Haus oder
Februar wohne ich drin
vor August letztes Jahr habe ich angefangen das zu bauen
und dann
habe ich jetzt hier das Grundstück selber gekauft
das ist jetzt mein eigenes
gebaut ist es auf einem Sattel
Aufflieger auf einem 30 Tonner
ach man kann das fahren
ja man sieht es ist natürlich immer noch nicht fertig
also seitdem der Rohbau
eigentlich steht und vor allem seitdem ich im Februar
drin wohne ist nicht mehr viel passiert
ist halt immer wieder mal so
was ich schaff schaff ich
was ich nicht schaff schaff ich nicht
also man sieht auch von innen
dass noch nicht alles fertig ist
aber cool ist das irgendwie schon
ich meine ich würde wahrscheinlich nicht drinne wohnen wollen
auch wenn es wahrscheinlich recht eng und gemütlich so ist
aber ich glaube ich hatte nicht genug Platz
für mein ganzes Zeug
aber er hat irgendwie was
mir ist wichtig
in meinem Haus gewesen
dass ich alles so hab wie in einem normalen Haus
mir war wichtig dass ich eine Küche hab
wo ich zu dritt oder zu viert kochen kann
was da leicht möglich ist
mir war wichtig dass ich hier zu viert essen kann
ey ohne Scheiß von innen
ok die Wand sieht dann
aber von innen sieht das gar nicht so klein aus
und auch hier zu viert mit Freunden
rumsitzen kann ohne dass es jetzt eng wird
mir war wichtig dass ich ein normales Sofa hab
was ich nutzen kann
das war eigentlich so das wichtigste
High IQ Musik im Hintergrund
aber das hat er doch nie im Leben
das kannst du doch gar nicht alleine bauen oder?
der hat da bestimmt viel gemacht
aber das schaffst du doch arbeitstechnisch
gar nicht so ein Haus alleine zu bauen
oder?
ich kann das schlecht einschätzen aber das kannst du doch gar nicht alleine machen
ja?
na gut er ist Schreiner
vielleicht
die Bergwacht
da hatten wir mal
einen echten Einsatz gehabt
alter der ist aber echt aktiv
der ist von morgens bis 16 Uhr
im Wald und macht da Zeug
und dann macht er abends noch irgendwie
freiwillig Bergwacht
der hat aber echt was zu tun
und da wollen wir das Szenario nochmal durchspielen
der hasselt
ich werd sie jetzt mal abtasten wenn sie irgendwo Schmerzen haben
dann einfach Bescheid geben ok?
auf Stunden gerechnet habe ich es noch nie
es ist
Ehrenamtsarbeit die unglaublich viel Spaß macht
die wunderschön ist
ehrenamtlich
es ist auch ein Ausgleich zur Arbeit
also
das würde ich nie in Stunden
aufrechnen was das ist
also ich finde meine Tätigkeit
lohnt sich schon
auf jeden Fall von dem was ich mache
und was ich machen darf
mit den Kindern zu arbeiten
dieses Feedback zu bekommen
aber auch diese
also der ist wirklich von morgens bis abends am Start
was ich mir noch wünschen würde
ist wirklich eine finanzielle
Anerkennung
für das was wir hier machen
aber ich will hier eigentlich ungern weg
ich hoffe dass es noch die
Aufstiegschancen mit dem Meister gibt
und dass wir die geschaffen werden
der Waldpädagogen Meister
da kannst du wirklich nicht allzu große Sprünge
mitmachen
bleibt nicht viel übrig
der ist am Ende
auf Null
was er fährt
er fährt eh Fahrrad
und halt wahrscheinlich muss er ja
irgendwie auch in Wald
das wird er mit dem Auto machen
ja schön dass ihr da wart
das war mein Tag hier im Walderlebniszentrum Schernfeld
hier gehts jetzt zum anderen Video
von einem Floristen
so wissen wir auch was ein Waldpädagoge macht
ich wusste bis vorhin gar nicht dass überhaupt sowas existiert
what your boss can track about humans teams
pff keine Ahnung ist mir wurscht
in Deutschland dürfen sie die Hälfte eh nicht
ist die Musik vielleicht ein bisschen flotter
ja
bisschen was zackiges
ein bisschen was längeres
Witcher 3 Next Gen before you buy
hat jemand schon gebyt?
lohnt sich das?
mich interessiert die Chat Einschätzung mehr
als was irgendein Typ auf Youtube sagt
lohnt sich das Next Gen Upgrade?
ja ich weiß es ist umsonst wenn man es hat
16 FPS
nice
das wär doch mal ein richtig geiles Spiel
für meine 40 90 zum Einstieg oder?
Was Next Gen Update benutzt
eine API von Microsoft
von der Microsoft
was sagt man soll sie nicht für 3D benutzen
hä wie was was benutzen die
es würd mich jetzt interessieren was
die machen
aktuell idelt die nicht mal
aktuell ist sie ausgeschaltet
nein mach ich noch nicht
der steht hinter mir
ich muss das
Kabel für die Grafikkarte noch austauschen
die Festplatte endlich einbauen
und noch
die Kabel jetzt ein bisschen anders machen
ja Staubfänger
Staubfänger 5000 Euro Staubfänger
easy
und als Notfall also Leute
ich hab ja da drinnen die
All in One Wasserkühlung
und wenn du volle Pulle
also wenn du Benchmarks aufmachst
und du hältst die Hand oben drüber
das ist ein Heizlüfter wie im Bad
nicht ganz so krass wie im Bad aber es ist ein Heizlüfter
ja das die mit
Unreal das machen wollen das weiß ich aber das hat man ja bei
Cyberpunk gesehen das sie mit ihrem eigenen
Kram nicht zurecht kommen ja
komm wir gucken uns zwei
Wildkid an
oder das
hast du dein
13900k Undervoltet
nö ich glaube auch das es
keine so gute Idee ist in dem Fall den zu
Undervolten weil der ja
schon mit ein bisschen mehr Takt als
Stock Takt läuft und wenn ich den zusätzlich
noch Undervolte
ich mein wir können das mal ausprobieren da kann ja nix
kaputt gehen aber
ich hab da so meine Zweifel das
der nicht Stable ist
ne ich hab aber auch
die Spannung nicht angehoben
und ich hab auch nicht super heftig übertaktet
oder so weil das ist
selbst mit dieser
3x 140mm
Lüftergeschichte ist es
jetzt nicht so das ich viel Spielraum habe was
Übertakten angeht also ich hab
ich hab den jetzt
standardmäßig plus 100
MHz laufen
also der ist dann quasi
wenn alle Kerne beschäftigt sind
hat er maximal 5,5 GHz
anstatt 5,4 GHz
das hab ich auch durch
durchgenudelt mit
Prime95 und hatte überhaupt keine Probleme mit
ähm
aber mehr
würde ich da jetzt
also ich hab ihn mal übertaktet bis auf
5,7 und da
ist er halt relativ schnell
an den 100 Grad dran und taktet schon
ne sogar 5,8 ich hab 5,8
gg ich hab 5,8 gemacht
5,8 weil der höchste
ich mein 5,8 muss er nämlich
schaffen allein schon von der Theorie her weil
der höchste Boost glaub ich
standardmäßig 5,8 ist
das heißt er sollte theoretisch auf allen
Kernen 5,8 schaffen aber halt
nicht bei allen gleichzeitig
so und deswegen hab ich auf 5,8 übertaktet
und das Ding das war relativ instant an 100 Grad
dran und hat sich runter getaktet auf
5,7 5,6 immer wieder
also so viel Luft
hab ich da gar nicht nach oben
selbst mit der fetten Wasserkühlung drauf
ich mein ich könnte es mal ausprobieren
wenn ich den wenn ich den
Ander wollte
ob der noch Stable ist
bei plus 100 Megahertz
ne hab ich nicht
wie schauts in Sachen Leistung aus
das ist brutal alter ich hab bisschen
übertaktet ich hab äh
40.500 Cinebench
Punkte das ist mega krass
das Ding also meine
meine Wasserkühlung
pustet nicht auf die Grafikkarte
weil die zieht die Luft
raus das einzige was man halt sagen könnte
ok die würde die zieht halt dann
theoretisch warme Luft raus von der Grafikkarte
aber das ist jetzt nicht so
nicht so wild gewesen bis jetzt
zumal da vorne zwei Lüfter
drin sind die frische Luft da rein
glasen das Video hab ich gesehen
und das hat er nicht gezeigt
da hat gezeigt dass die mit 90 Watt
Powerlimit sehr energieeffizient
ist und man
nicht so viel Leistung einbüßt
dass die genau so ist hat er nicht gezeigt
ob die CPU oder die GPU
heiser ist ne das hab ich tatsächlich noch nicht ausprobiert
was davon
mehr Hitze verursacht
muss ich mal ausprobieren
was ist denn der beste Grafikkarten
Temperatur
Test
früher gab es dieses was Haare berechnet hat
wo man so Teppich
Teppich äh Fasern berechnet hat
ich weiß nicht mehr wie das heißt
ja genau das meine ich doch
genau das meine ich ja ja ja
ja das meine ich ist das immer noch
ist das immer noch angesagt für Grafikkarten
Temperatur
oder was nimmt man denn so wenn man
maximale Grafikkarten Temperatur testen will
ja hier das mit den
das mit den Haaren
genau wahrscheinlich
nicht aber warum
möchte man das machen
wahrscheinlich machst du kürze oder lang
die Pumpe kaputt kann ich mir
vorstellen es gab
vor ein paar Jahren nochmal dieses komische
bei wo war das
bei Toms Hardware oder so
den PC in Öl
einlegen so als Geheimtipp wo ich
mir auch gedacht habe mein Gott seid ihr bescheuert
Alter das wurde damals so als Geheimtipp
verkauft leg dein leg dein PC
doch in Öl Alter bleib da schön kalt
passen eigentlich das Video
vom Bauer hier dazu
ähm
wir tauchen ein PC in destilliertes
Wasser
Uwuntu
ja die Daseinsberechtigung davon habe ich
noch nicht verstanden weil es ist ja noch nicht mal
sonderlich sonderlich
webisiert
ne das genau stimmt allein schon
wegen den Schläuchen könntest du da wahrscheinlich kein Öl rein machen
kennst du das
Linux Technik Video über Tastatur und der Spülmaschine
ne
aber ich könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen dass das funktioniert
würds vielleicht nicht machen
zumal
eins muss man aber echt sagen
seitdem ich hier so ne
mechanische Tastatur am Start habe
das verdrecken
ist deutlich besser als bei dieser
Oldschool
mit diesem Gummi
Zeugs drunter
das Gummi Zeug hat total oft
einfach Dreck durch die Ritzen bekommen
und
war dann verdreckt nach ein paar Jahren
von Staub bis vielleicht paar Krümel
vom Essen
und mit den mechanischen Switches
da ist ja kein Loch quasi
das ist halt einfach ein Switch drauf
Rubber Dome genau
so
komm eine Sache können wir uns mal angucken
wir gucken uns mal ich muss mir das neue SvelteKit Video angucken
Fireship muss uns was erklären
SvelteKit 1.0 ist jetzt raus
das ist ein
wer hätte das gedacht ein weiteres
Javascript Framework
allerdings ein gescheites
damit kann man Server Side Rendering
Client Side Rendering und alles in einem machen
und Svelte ist Epoch
lass uns das mal angucken was Fireship dazu erzählt
das ist Java
nicht Javascript
ups falscher Button
which is a full stack framework
for the world's most loved UI library
ist das so ist Svelte most loved
ok
was ist was ist denn da sonst
Blazor alter warum mögen die Leute
Blazor ich kanns nicht verstehen alter
Blazor ist echt Pains Champ
und warum ist
Vue.js so schlecht mittlerweile
wobei nicht so schlecht
immer Top 10 hier guck mal ASP.net
mögen die meisten Leute
nicht aber wahrscheinlich weil
die meisten Leute ASP.net
noch kennen aus ASP.net
Zeiten und nicht ASP.net Core
ach ne Moment
ASP.net Core ist ja da oben
habe ich verguckt ja ok das verstehe ich
ASP.net Core finde ich
nämlich ziemlich nice und ASP.net
ist abartig warum Microsoft
die Sachen wieder mal so beschissen benannt hat
weiß nur Microsoft
Ruby ist genau in der Mitte Rails
ist aber wirklich cool also ich mag Rails
Rails ist nice Laravel ist auch nice
komm mal weiter
W damn Musikloos
level 17
Let's take a look at some code and see if it lives up to all of these innuendos.
SvelteKit is very similar to other JavaScript Metaframeworks like Next.js, Remix and Nuxt.
Like Next.js 13...
Ich kann es mir einfach nicht merken bei dieser Bezeichnung, Alter.
Ich kann es mir einfach nicht merken.
...Remix and Nuxt.
Also, Next.js ist React.
Nuxt.js ist Vue, oder?
Und Remix ist dieses Facebook-Ding.
Nee, nicht Facebook.
Ähm, Airbnb.
Oder...
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Was war Remix?
U? War das Uber?
Airbnb? Nee, was war Remix?
Ach, was war... Ich blick da nicht mehr durch.
Warum gibt es tausend verschiedene JavaScript-Metaframeworks?
Die Zahl ist noch deutlich untertrieben.
Das ist jetzt neu.
Das war früher noch nicht so.
Die letzte Version, die ich verwendet habe, war das noch nicht so mit diesem File-Based Routing und dieser Benamung.
Das ist jetzt neu.
Das habe ich noch nicht benutzt.
...File that has significance to the framework is prefixed with a plus sign.
There's been a lot of discussion around this approach and not everybody likes it.
Because you end up with tons of files in the project with the exact same name.
Which can lead to migraines if you expand all the directories in your editor.
On the other hand, though, these conventions keep your project clear and consistent.
Page.svelte contains a component that will be server-rendered when you navigate to that file.
After the initial page load, it will hydrate and then the client-side router takes over from there.
Was ich gut finde, ist, dass man jetzt einfach ein- und ausschalten kann pro Seite, ob man server-side rendern will oder nicht.
Warum macht Max kein JavaScript-Metaframework?
JS-Champ.
This is what we call SSR and I think it's the most sensible default.
Der Name wäre auf jeden Fall schon mal gesetzt, ja.
However, in Spellkick you can mix and match other rendering strategies.
Like you can pre-render static HTML for Jamstack-style websites.
Or if no server is required, you can use client rendering to do everything in the browser.
Or on the flip side, if you don't want any JavaScript at all, you can render everything on the server like a traditional multi-page application.
What's awesome, though, is that you can choose the best rendering strategy for a page with a simple configuration option.
You're not locked in to just one rendering paradigm.
That's awesome, but the other big thing you'll want to know about the developer experience is how the data fetching works.
Was ist das? Was ist das? Was ist das?
Satisfies page load?
JavaScript?
Was ist das schon wieder?
Was ist das für ein Wort?
Was ist das?
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Was ist das schon wieder für eine komische Syntax?
Ah, nee, das ist TypeScript.
Das ist irgendein TypeScript-Ding.
Dass du es in irgendein TypeScript stellst.
Ah, okay.
Ich meine, mich wundert mittlerweile bei JavaScript nichts mehr.
Also, da ist alles möglich mittlerweile.
Ich könnte auch einfach CraftQL verwenden
und das
in der Page.svelte-File
jemand anderes für sich machen lassen.
Ja.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
Also, dass das Standardmäßig im Framework dabei ist.
Ja.
Aber schon lief, hat er.
Aber schon lief.
Ja.
Alles klar, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid über SvelteKit.
Ne, die Stimme ist nicht elektronisch, der liest immer so vor.
Das hört sich immer so an.
Das hört sich alle Videos von dem so an.
Max erfindet den Champ-Stack.
Oh ja, das wäre eine gute Bezeichnung.
Ich wüsste bloß nicht, für was er stehen soll.
Also, was ich ja gerne verwende ist SvelteKit, Frontend, ASP.NET Core im Backend.
CraftQL verwende ich ganz gerne.
Also, wie könnten wir, das müssen wir jetzt mal gucken, wie könnten wir den Champ-Stack daraus zusammensetzen?
Also, Svelte bzw. SvelteKit.
Dann, ähm, okay.
Dann haben wir CraftQL, mache ich ganz gerne.
Das Hot Chocolate heißt die Library, vielleicht bringt die uns was.
ASP.NET Core als, ehrlich gesagt, als Datenbank.
Entweder Postgres oder SQLite könnten wir da einbauen.
Okay, Leute, wie könnten wir, wie könnten wir daraus Champ, wie könnten wir, wie könnten wir daraus Champ bauen?
Den Swag-Stack gibt es schon.
Wie können, P, P ist Postgres, okay.
P, P ist Postgres, das ist schon mal okay.
A, ASP.NET Core ist A.
Okay, aber, aber C.
C, H und M.
Wie kriegt man das da jetzt irgendwie rein?
Gar nicht, oder?
Ah ja.
C ist C-Sharp, ja, das ist gut.
Das ist gut, das ist gut, das finde ich, finde ich nice, okay.
Aber Svelte hat kein M und hat kein H drinne.
CraftQL kann...
Nee, das ist blöd.
CraftQL, also, das...
Svelte.
Der Cap, der Cap-Stack.
Ja, ich glaube,
da brauchen wir eine bessere Bezeichnung für.
Das, das, das wird so nix.
Das, das wird so nix.
Wir nennen das einfach in Melt um.
Genau, wir forgen das nur,
dass ich den Champ-Stack erstellen kann.
Wobei, S-H gibt es doch schon bestimmt.
Champ-Stack.
Die Leute haben doch bestimmt schon sich sowas ausgedacht.
Champ-Stack, GitHub.
Okay, das ist anscheinend noch frei.
Nee, da fällt mir jetzt nichts zu ein,
wie man daraus Champ machen kann.
Okay, okay.
Nee, C haben wir schon.
Vielleicht können wir noch irgendwie Cloud oder so,
oder so mit reinbauen.
Da ist nirgendswo ein H und ein M drinne.
Nee, keine Chance.
Helmcharts, aber es hat damit überhaupt nix zu tun.
By the way, warum heißt das eigentlich...
Hat irgendjemand verstanden, warum Helm,
warum das Charts heißt,
obwohl es eigentlich so mit Graphen überhaupt nix zu tun hat?
Warum heißt das eigentlich Charts?
Das sind ja überhaupt keine Graphen.
Das ist ja im Prinzip so eine Sammlung,
wie installiere ich verschiedene Container zusammen.
Darf man auch Deployment sagen.
H ist Hetzner Cloud.
Okay, das würde tatsächlich funktionieren.
Das würde tatsächlich funktionieren.
Aber wir müssen irgendwie unser JavaScript-Zeug noch reinkriegen.
Da bleibt bloß noch M übrig.
Also wir müssen das Weltkit irgendwie in M...
mit reinbekommen.
Irgendwas mit M.
Mobile, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Da fällt mir nix ein.
Most loved.
Tatsächlich.
Was ist Most loved?
Most loved.
Ich hab keinen Account.
Im Prinzip ist diese Benamung eh immer ziemlich hängen geblieben.
Also ich verstehe unter Chart immer sowas wie beispielsweise Tortendiagramm.
Ja, ich will ja nicht irgendein Framework, was mit M ist.
Das heißt, der Twitch-Chat ist auch ein Graph, weil es eine Ansammlung von einzelnen Textnachrichten in einem Chatraum ist.
Leute, Craft-driven Twitch-Chatting.
Haben wir noch irgendwas, was wir uns anschauen können?
Was ist das denn hier?
Reddit vs. Wall Street.
Oh, nee.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
14 Minuten, Alter.
Da ging kurzzeitig die Welt unter.
Ach, das haben die sogar da drinnen stehen, warum das so...
Aha.
So.
Na dann.
Ach, das sagt Chat-GPT.
Weil ich hab mich nämlich gerade gefragt...
Ich wollte nämlich gerade sagen, wo da die Visual Representation von sein soll.
Aber okay.
This could potentially stand for Cloud Hosting, Amazon Web Services, MySQL und P...
Okay, das ist...
Aber Chat-GPT ist schon ziemlich high IQ, oder?
Dass die sowas rauskriegt.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Okay, gucken wir uns Wall Street...
Wall Street Bets an.
Auf geht's.
Da hast du ja wunderbare Beute.
Ich gebe dir dafür zwei...
Ist das...
Ist das Voice-Acting aus Gothic?
Alte paar stinkende Stiefel und einen hässlichen Stein.
Das ist GameStop.
Eines der bekanntesten Videospielläden der Welt.
Berühmt dafür Leute in absolut...
Das ist der Skyrim-Sprecher.
Das hätte auch eins zu eins aus Gothic sein können.
Wobei der sich noch ein bisschen anders anhört.
Das ist aus Skyrim.
Naja, gut, da lag ich falsch.
Aber...
Eines muss man ja sagen.
Also...
Die NPC...
Also gerade die deutsche Synchro von Gothic war halt schon cool.
...unerträglichen Preis für Spiele und Konsolen zu geben.
GameStop hat nicht den besten Ruf.
Ausraster wegen Überstunden.
Ausraster wegen schlechten Preisen.
Oder halt solche Ausraster.
Oh ne, an das Video kann ich mich noch erinnern.
Once again it's man.
Woah.
Aber das ist nochmal ein Thema für sich.
Und ab 2015 kam das dunkle Zeitalter für GameStop.
Die Digitalisierung.
Durch die Digitalisierung und der Möglichkeit Online-Spiele zu kaufen sinkten die Zahlen...
Leute, seriously?
Ich war, glaube ich, noch nie in meinem Leben in einem GameStop.
Wem geht's auch noch so?
...neuen GameStop-Läden immer mehr ins Negative.
Und Leute waren immer weniger daran interessiert...
Noch nie.
...in Leben zu gehen, um ein physisches Spiel zu kaufen.
2019.
Zwei Unternehmer, Michael Burry und Keith Gill, investieren trotzdem in die schlecht dastehende...
GameStop-Aktie.
Michael Burry.
Großinvestor, Arzt und Schauspieler aus dem Film The Big Shot.
Und Keith Gill.
Ein Reddit-User mit einem kleinen YouTube-Kanal zum Thema Investing und einer Vorliebe für Katzen-T-Shirts.
Keith Gill entschied sich dazu, sein Investment in einem Subreddit namens r slash wallstreetbets zu posten.
Auf Reddit gibt es wie gefühlt alles auf der Welt ein Subreddit.
Für Katzenfotos, für Fußfotos, für Leute...
Für Reddit, das stimmt wohl.
Leute, es gibt Zeug auf Reddit, das will man...
...die die Russen hocke machen...
...das besprechen wir hier lieber nicht.
...vögel mit Armen, Wölfe...
Oh nein, Chainlord, poste nicht dein Zeug, sonst timeraue ich dich wieder.
Verdammt, habe ich etwa meine Pillen wieder vergessen.
...und halt eben Wallstreetbets.
Ein memelastiges Subreddit für Hobby-Investoren, in dem Leute ihre Gewinne oder meistens Verluste...
...posten können.
Hauptsächlich werden aber WoW-Gifs gepostet und Leute regen mit Shit-Posten und Memes zum Investieren an.
Und die Leute in der Community nehmen sich gegenseitig Retards und Apes.
Verständlich.
Denn beispielsweise gibt es da den User AnalPharma2, ein arbeitsloser Student mit 110.000 Dollar in seinem Account.
Verdammt.
Verdient durch Online-Business.
Macht einen sogenannten YOLO-All-In-Move in einer Aktie und macht über eine halbe Million Dollar mit 19 Jahren.
Nur um dann alles davon in einem weiteren All-In-Move zu verlieren.
Easy.
Für die Leute auf Reddit war das pure Unterhaltung.
Und ihm wurde daraufhin geraten, einfach einen grünen Stift zu nehmen und eine Linie auf das Handy zu malen.
Passt schon so.
Oder der User ControlTheNarrative, der in seiner Trading-App einen Infinite-Money-Glitch fand...
...daraufhin dann alles live verlaufener Kamera verlor...
...und somit...
Was?
Okay, bei den Videos weißt du ja nie...
...was jetzt ein bisschen dazu gedichtet ist.
Aber das kann schon alles sein.
...einer lebenden Legende in WallStreetBets wurde.
Ein User hat komplett aus Versehen 110 Tage gemacht.
Infinite-Money-Glitch, Alter.
Und es gibt natürlich noch den WallStreetBets-Discount.
Keith Gill postete seinen GameStop-Kauf im Subreddit und wurde für seine dumme Investition belächelt und runtergevotet.
Doch er war der Meinung, dass GameStop gar nicht so schlecht aufgestellt ist, wie man meinen könnte.
Die Firma hat genug Geld für die nächsten Jahre.
Die neuen Konsolen kommen mit CD-Laufwerken raus.
Die werden außerdem immer größer.
Und Leute fangen deshalb wieder an, CDs zu kaufen.
Doch 2020 kam Corona.
Leute prügelten sich um Klopapier, verkrafteten den Lockdown überhaupt nicht...
...und die Läden schlossen somit auch.
Und dadurch sank auch der Wert von GameStop.
Doch Keith Gill und Michael Burry hielten die Aktien.
Denn sie glaubten an ihren Erfolg in der Zukunft.
Und ihre Geduld zahlte sich...
Warum genau muss der Typ eine Zigarre rauchen im Stream?
Weil das krasses Business ist und so richtig krasse Business-Typen Zigarre rauchen.
Oktober 2020 stieg die Aktie von 8 Dollar auf 13 Dollar.
Keith Gills investierten 50.000 Dollar, sind mittlerweile 2 Millionen wert.
Und Leute auf Reddit fingen an, ihn für einen Propheten zu halten.
Und investierten auch in die Aktie.
Und somit wurde die erstmals kleine...
Moment, Moment, Moment, das muss ich jetzt verstehen, was?
Keith Gills investierten 50.000 Dollar und ihre Geduld...
...tick.
Der Sieg...
Wie ist?
...tick.
Also, es ist gestiegen von...
...und ihre Geduld zahlte sich aus.
Am 8. Oktober 2020 stieg die Aktie von 8 Dollar...
Ok, von 8 Dollar...
...auf 13 Dollar.
...auf 13.
Das ist...
Irgendwie...
Was sind das?
60 Prozent oder so, hä?
Quick...
Quickmuffs.
Keine Ahnung.
Ähm...
Keith Gills investierten 50.000 Dollar, sind mittlerweile...
Warum...
Wenn...
Wenn das um 60 Prozent steigt...
Da müssen wir die ganzen Stonkskenner unter euch das ja mal erklären.
Wenn es um 60 Prozent steigt, warum sind dann aus 50.000 Euro 2,2 Millionen geworden?
Das kommt jetzt, ok.
2 Millionen wert.
Und Leute auf Reddit fingen an, ihn für einen Propheten zu halten.
Und investierten auch in die Aktie.
Und somit wurde die erstmals kleine GME GameStop Gang gegründet.
GameStop bis zum Mond.
GameStop Gang.
Kauft GameStop.
Wird sich bald vervielfachen.
Einfach Leute, die diese Aktie lieben.
Der Kurs fing hier und da dann an zu schwanken.
Keith postete weiterhin monatliche Updates von seinem Investment.
Und die Leute vertrauten ihm.
Wenn er noch drin ist, dann bin ich es auch, hieß es.
Und dann fiel den Leuten etwas auf.
Ein extrem großer Anteil der Investoren und Hedgefonds setzte gegen GameStop, also auf
den Fall der Aktie.
Hedgefonds sind quasi große Investorenverbände, bei denen die Leute alles aussehen wie der
Typ von Monopoly.
Diese haben beispielsweise damals Milliarden auf den Fall von Toys R Us gesetzt und somit
dafür gesorgt, dass es diesen Laden heute nicht mehr gibt.
Du hast uns gute Dienste erwiesen, mein Freund.
Außerdem manipulieren sie die Börsennachweise, die schon seit Jahren haben technische Mittel,
die der kleine Reddit-Anleger nicht hat und können somit regelmäßig konsequenzlos Milliarden
an Geld anmachen.
Die waren sehr unbeliebt bei den Redditen.
Die Hedgefonds versetzten also Milliarden an Dollar auf den Fall von GameStop.
Und Leuten fiel auf, dass ein gewisses seltenes Börsenphänomen entstehen könnte.
Der Short Squeeze.
Sehr einfach erklärt.
Ein paar Investoren-Krokodile setzen darauf, dass der Preis von Bananen fällt.
Wenn das passiert, machen die Krokodile eine Menge Geld.
Ein paar Affen merken dann, oh, die setzen darauf, dass der Bananenpreis sinkt.
Lasst uns viele Bananen kaufen.
Dadurch steigt der Preis der Bananen an und die Krokodile machen Verlust.
Ein paar Krokodile sagen sich dann, okay, wir sind raus aus dem Geschäft und müssen
aussteigen, bevor wir noch mehr verlieren.
Dadurch und durch ein paar sehr komplizierte Börsenprinzipien steigt dann wiederum der
Preis an und noch mehr Krokodile müssen aussteigen und es entsteht eine riesige Kettenreaktion
und der Preis der Bananen könnte in die Höhe schießen und das bis in unendliche.
Bruder.
Bananen.
Leute machen dann auf das Phänomen aufmerksam und ungefähr zur selben Zeit kommen auch
die neuen Konsolen auf den Markt und werden ordentlich gehypt.
Und ein Typ, der eigentlich Hundespiezel produziert, wird Vorsitzender bei GameStop.
Zwei gute Zeichen für die Firma und der Preis kletterte von 19 Dollar auf erstmalig 40 Dollar.
Also wenn der Typ schon mit 60 Prozent so viel gemacht hat, der ist jetzt ja multi-hunderten-Millionen-Millionär.
Er kassierte seine Millionenprofite weiterhin auf Reddit.
Leute machten die ersten Gewinne damit und die Aktie wurde von der jetzt noch größeren
Affenhorde auf Reddit weiter hochgehypt.
Das Magazin VICE widmete dem kleinen Hype den ersten Artikel.
Doch der Mainstream und die großen Hedgefonds der Wall Street hatten immer noch nicht die
leiseste Ahnung, was eine kleine Gruppe an Leuten im Internet da fabriziert.
Doch dann kam der erste Boss.
Der Unternehmer Andrew Left, der selber gegen GameStop setzt, warnte die Leute von Reddit
offen in einem Livestream, dass sie keine Ahnung haben, was sie da tun und der Preis
bald wieder auf 20 Dollar fallen wird.
Dann hat er wahrscheinlich Angst um sein Geld gehabt.
Dann nahm ihn nicht ganz so ernst.
Sowas kannst du nicht posten in der heutigen Zeit.
Das wird ja zu Tode gememt dann.
Wie daraufhin bei Tinder angemeldet, taggten sie seinen Twitter-Account und bestellten ihm nachts Pizza an die Tür.
Sie wollten TV-Pizza, richtig?
Oh Mann.
Doch ein paar Reddit-Usern wird die Situation dadurch zu heiß.
Und sie schlossen ihre Position.
Es gibt ein weit verbreitetes Konzept bei Wall Street-Bets.
Diamond Hands.
Diamond Hands heißt die Aktie halten, bis man am Ziel ist.
Auch wenn Krisen und Hindernisse kommen.
Das war das Motto der Redditor.
Und somit stieg der Preis immer weiter an.
Es war wie ein Lauffeuer.
Erstens gab es mehr Memes und Shitposting.
Dann bekam er Leute davon mit.
Investiert in GameStop.
Ist Diamond Hands quasi das Gegenstück zu HODL, wenn es um Krypto-Zeug geht?
Ist das das Gleiche, nur anders ausgedrückt?
Cheers, everybody!
Cheers, welcome!
Die Aktie erreichte schließlich 76 Dollar.
Und die Armee der Affen war nicht mehr aufzuhalten.
Hört sich das im Wall Street-Bets-Discord wirklich so an?
26. Januar.
Elon Musk tweetete GameStonk und verlinkte das Subreddit.
Elon Musk.
Und die Aktie schoss nach oben.
Erst auf die 243 Dollar.
Dann auf die 360 Dollar.
Und die Medien fingen überall an, davon zu berichten.
Außerdem sagten sie, dass Andrew Left's Firma ihre Verkaufsposition geschlossen hat.
Genauso wie eines der größten Hedgefonds der Welt.
Doch für die Monkeys auf Reddit war das eine Falle.
Sie glaubten, das sei Fake News, um Leute dazu zu kriegen, zu verkaufen.
Die Redditor kannten die Regeln.
Sie haben sich jahrelang durch sehr intensives Online-Training auf diesen Tag vorbereitet.
Und somit hielten sie weiter die Aktien.
Diamond Hands.
Die Redditor kauften noch mehr.
Sie wollten noch höher.
Sie wollten bis zum Mond.
GameStop.
Hier ist das erste deutsche Fernsehen.
Bislang konnten die großen Player an der Börse nach Belieben agieren.
Jetzt haben die kleinen Anleger sie mit ihren eigenen Waffen geschlagen.
Nice.
Der Preis stieg schließlich auf 500 Dollar.
Es war wie David gegen Goliath.
Kleine Reddit-User mit Namen wie PotatoInMyAss
zwingten die größten Investoren der Welt
Den gibt's wahrscheinlich wirklich.
durch Shitposting und Memes in die Knie.
Goldman warnte daraufhin, dass eventuell die ganze Wirtschaft zusammenbrechen könnte.
Und die Underground-GameStop-Aktie wurde schließlich neben Tesla und Apple
eines der meistgehandelsten Aktien der Welt.
Auf dem Weg zum Mond riss die Aktie außerdem andere Firmen wie AMC oder Nokia mit.
Und der ganze Markt spielte verrückt.
Es herrschte absolutes Chaos auf der Wall Street.
Und doch plötzlich passierte etwas Unerwartetes.
Auf jeglichen Broker-Apps in jedem Land der Welt
verschwand plötzlich der Kauf-Button.
Viele Leute kriegten daraufhin Panik und verkauften sofort.
Denn wenn keiner mehr kaufen kann, kann auch der Preis nicht mehr ansteigen.
Außerdem schlossen ein paar Trading-Apps automatisch die Position der Kleinanleger.
Und somit fiel der Aktienpreis innerhalb ein paar Stunden zurück bis auf die 120 Dollar-Mark.
Kurz vor dem Moment, in dem viele Leute fast Millionäre geworden wären.
Ist die Börse etwa manipulierbar?
War sie. Schon immer.
Okay, erstmal.
Robin Hood bekam den Shitstorm ihres Lebens.
Denn immerhin warben sie damit dem Kleinanleger eine Chance zum Investieren zu geben.
Doch jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr.
Robin Hood wurde zum Sheriff von Nottingham.
Zur gleichen Zeit versuchten die Massenmedien die GameStop-Geschichte aus den Köpfen der Leute auszutreiben.
Erst hieß es, dass Redditor anstatt sich auf GameStop jetzt auf Silber fokussierten, was einfach nicht stimmte.
Dann sind die GameStop-Investoren auf einmal weiße Nazi-Männer und zahlreiche Newsportale zeigen...
Na wenn sonst nix geht, das geht immer.
...wie gefährlich es ist, Geld zu investieren.
Die Verkäufer der Aktie sind plötzlich die Helden.
Und zahlreiche Investoren beklagen sich live über die dummen Affen aus dem Subreddit, die die Börse durcheinander gebracht haben.
Daraufhin hakelte es negative Bewertungen von Reddit-Usern für die Trading-Apps, nur damit Google diese mit einem Klick komplett entfernt ist.
Der komplett überflutete Wallstreetbets Discord-Server wurde daraufhin wegen Hassrede einfach aus dem Nichts gelöscht.
Und eine Vielzahl an Bots wurde im Subreddit gefunden, die Leute dazu anregen sollten, ihre GameStop-Aktien zu verkaufen.
Die Leute auf Reddit hatten das Gefühl, dass sie sich diesmal mit den großen Mächten angelegt haben.
Es war eine tragische Story.
Leute, die späteingestiegen waren, verloren teilweise ihr ganzes Erspartes.
Geld für die geplante Hochzeitgeberin...
Naja, also ganz ehrlich, da musst du auch schon wirklich nicht ganz dicht im Kopf sein, wenn du dann sagst,
ach ja, guck mal, ich hab keine Ahnung, was da eigentlich gerade abgeht, aber lass doch mal kurz 350.000 Euro reinstecken, alles was ich hab, easy.
Also, da fällt es mir wirklich schwer zu sagen, also nicht zu sagen, selbst dran schuld.
... ihr Erbe verzockt oder verloren ihre Lebensversicherung.
Und die Zweifel auf einen erneuten Anstieg wurden immer größer.
Schließt du deine Position und verhinderst, dass du noch mehr verlierst, verrätst aber die Leute im Subreddit oder erhältst du und nimmst damit in Kauf, eventuell noch mehr zu verlieren.
Und so vergeht eine Woche.
Ich kann übrigens unser Haus nicht mehr bezahlen, warum? Ich hab GameStop gekauft.
Und noch eine Woche.
Und der Kurs blieb weiterhin unten.
Und nachdem Redditu seine Sammelklage gegen Robin Hood eingereicht haben, weil sie vermuteten, dass Hedgefonds und Robin Hood unter eine Decke steckten, gab es am 28.02. eine Anhörung.
Auch Keith Gill war dabei, angeklagt von einem pleitegegangenen Investor, weil er angeblich Leute dazu getrieben hat, mit ihm zusammen den Markt zu manipulieren.
Ob gemeinsame Sache gemacht wurde, weiß man bis heute nicht.
Aber Robin Hood und ein Hedgefond namens Melvin Capital profitieren schon seit Jahren voneinander und haben zufällig einen Tag vor dem Entfernen des Knopfes miteinander kommuniziert.
Hat jemand aus ihrem Unternehmen Robin Hood kontaktiert, um den Kauf von GameStop Aktien zu verhindern? Gab es da jemanden?
... absolut nicht.
Ja.
Ich meine...
Wahrscheinlich stehen die auf der...
Außerhalb der Kamera steht wahrscheinlich gerade schon einer mit der Sniper auf ihn gerichtet.
Sag jetzt nichts Falsches, Alter.
Keith Gill sagt im Livestream, er hält die Aktie und glaubt immer noch an sie.
Während im Hintergrund ein motivierendes Katzenbild und das berüchtigte rote Bandana zu sehen ist.
Ein paar Dinge, die ich nicht bin.
Ich bin kein Katzen.
Ich bin kein institutioneller Investor.
Wie bei mir, mag ich den Stock.
Ich bin so wütend, wie ich jemals bei einem potenziellen Turnaround für GameStop war.
Und ich bleibe in der Firma investiert.
Danke.
Tschüss, alle.
Und das postete er auch auf Reddit.
Er hält.
Weiter hält.
Trotz eines 15 Millionen Verlustes.
Und somit entstand an diesem Tag eines der meistgeliktesten Reddit-Posts of all time.
Der König davon hat gesprochen.
Und seine Armee stand hinter ihm.
Wenn er noch drin ist, sind sie es auch.
Und diesmal hatten sie Verstärkung.
Denn mittlerweile ging es um viel mehr als nur Geld.
Es ging um Gerechtigkeit gegen die korrupte Börse.
Und die Redditor waren diesmal vorbereitet, wie noch nie, sich ihr Geld zurückzuholen.
Alles zum f *** GUT!
Ha ha ha.
Wir gehen nicht f *** kommen!
Als für mich mag ich den Stock.
Fast wieder zurück.
Wir lieben den Stock.
Stonk's.
Dieser faire Teilhandel ist ein verdammtes Konzept.
Wir kaufen Game Sto...
So, Leute, wir haben es.
So, Leute.
Wir haben es, Leute.
Wir haben es.
Die Leute schafften es mit geballter Kraft, den Preis nochmal auf 350 Dollar zu bringen.
GameStop war überall.
Melvin Capital verlor Milliarden an Dollarn und ging komplett bankrott.
Verdicht gefolgt von anderen Hedgefonds an der Börse.
Reddit-User schlugen die Investoren mit ihren eigenen Waffen.
Und das Mitleid für die dadurch pleitegegangenen Hedgefonds war ziemlich gering auf Reddit.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Du bist ein Hedgefonds-Manager.
Und ab hier fing der Preis über die nächsten Monate an zu schwanken, mit der Tendenz bis heute zu fallen.
Denn viele Leute verkauften, bezahlten ihre Rechnungen damit oder mussten nie wieder arbeiten gehen.
Arme Reddit-User konnten plötzlich ihre medizinische Versorgung bezahlen und sich das erste Mal im Leben Luxus geben.
Manche kauften sich ihr Traumauto oder nutzten ihr Geld für einen guten Zweck.
Ah ja, und sehr viele im Subreddit haben angefangen, Gorillas zu adaptieren, weil Affe und so...
Doch wie immer bei der Börse gab es auch einige Leute, die sich in die Aktie verliebt haben, weil sie hofften, dass sie irgendwann nochmal ansteckt.
Denn so eine Trennung, eventuell der Minus, kann für einige echt teuer werden.
Und danach haben Hedgefonds noch versucht, ein paar Redditor anzustellen.
Voraussetzung?
Hohes Reddit-Karma, guter Meme-Geschmack, keine Ausbildung, ja gut.
Und eine riesige Harambe-Statue wurde in der Wall Street aufgestellt, sinnbildlich für den Kampf der kleinen Redditor.
Der immer noch aktienhaltende Kiefgild postete dann noch ein letztes Update und die Affenarmee löste sich.
So langsam, bis auf ein paar verbleibende, auf.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das denen am besten beibringe, aber was soll ich machen, ja?
Das andere Angebot hat einfach zu viele Vorteile.
Es ist näher und es gibt viel mehr Kohle.
Was soll ich sagen?
Letztendlich gehe ich nicht nur just for fun arbeiten, sondern ich will auch Geld verdienen.
Wie laufen die ETFs?
Naja, so semi-nice.
Ich sag das immer wieder, ich bin bestechlich, Leute, was das angeht.
Also wer noch Prime-Subs hat, kein Problem.
Ne, also...
Ich mach das immer wieder.
Ich hab da schon Abstriche.
Also ich würde mich durchaus auch für ein...
Also wenn ich die Auswahl habe, ja?
Zwischen einem und zwischen zwei Arbeitgebern.
Und der eine bezahlt ein bisschen weniger, aber dafür ist bei dem alles drumherum viel, viel besser und toller.
Also ich...
Leute, wenn ich besser klarkomme, bessere Homeoffice-Regel, alles besser.
Dann würde ich mich auch für den entscheiden, obwohl es unterm Strich weniger Geld gibt.
Aber die Frage stellt sich diesmal nicht.
Die in Frankfurt haben wirklich guten Eindruck auf mich gemacht.
Und...
Die bezahlen...
So viel mehr.
Dass sich da die Frage für mich gar nicht gestellt hat mehr.
Bestechung.
Danke schön, Murksau.
Massive.
Jetzt bist du in der Abo-Falle.
Du bist quasi in der Gruppe.
Danke für den Sub.
Icefreak.
31 Monate.
Du bist ja schon richtig lange dabei.
Danke für die Subs.
Magst du jetzt über 100k?
Ja, aber knapp.
Aber wirklich knapp.
Aber es ist jetzt sechsstellig.
Allerdings, wie gesagt, vorne ist noch eine Eins.
So viel zähle ich euch.
Mehr sage ich erst mal nicht, weil ich keine Ahnung habe, wie das da, ob das, ob man das darf oder ob das gewollt, aber gut, dürfen darf man es rechtlich, kann man da eh nix dagegen machen, aber soll nicht sein.
Nee, auf 40 Stunden gerechnet, selbstverständlich.
Jaja.
Auf fünf Tage gerechnet.
Ich rechne es ja immer auf fünf Tage.
Ich arbeite aber plus 80%.
Also ich arbeite nur vier Tage.
Ja, also natürlich, natürlich.
Musst ja auch einen anderen Job suchen.
Es werden gerade händeringend überall Leute gesucht.
Und wenn du Ahnung hast, dann findest du was.
Natürlich jährlich.
Nicht monatlich.
Ich meine, ich habe keine GameStop-Aktie.
Nee, nee.
Selbstverständlich jährlich.
Nee, ich habe ja Urlaub seit November.
Also ich war wenig Urlaub jetzt im November.
Und war es noch nie hier.
Sieht so aus, ja.
Weil, ich habe ja Urlaub im Dezember.
Also ich bin eigentlich, ich war erstaunlich wenig am chillen in meinem Urlaub bis jetzt.
Ich habe auch wenig Streams gemacht.
Das hat einfach nicht hingehauen.
Und jetzt muss ich auch noch MMO-Kreisel-Crime machen nebenbei.
Also sieben Stunden am Tag.
Das ist auch keine Zeit.
Aber ich mache ein Video zu meiner aktuellen Jobsituation, wenn ich unterschrieben habe.
Und das unter Dach und Fach ist, weil sonst sage ich ja was, was nicht stimmt.
Und da erzähle ich ein bisschen was drumherum.
Wie gesagt, Namen werden nicht erwähnt.
Genaue, konkrete Zahlen werden auch nicht erwähnt.
Aber was so gelaufen ist.
Machst du beruflich?
Da würde ich dir empfehlen, guck dir mal bei mir auf YouTube auf dem Channel.
Da habe ich ganz viele Videos zu diesem Thema schon gemacht.
Ja.
Zum Beispiel das da.
Das, was mache ich auf der Arbeit und sowas.
Oder das da.
Kannst du ja auch was mit Noel zusammen gemacht haben.
Gibt es ein paar Videos zu.
Welches MMO wird Kreisel gecrindet?
Dark Age of Camelot auf dem Freeshard.
Hier.
Game von 2002.
In 2022 einfach ein fucking 20 Jahre altes Game, man.
Aber es sind immerhin schon 1400 Leute auf dem Server.
Was um die Uhrzeit relativ viel ist.
1400 Leute.
400 Leute auf dem Server.
Dark, bestes MMO ever.
Wie viele Stunden hast du die Woche?
Ich habe vorhin ausgerechnet.
Ich glaube, ich habe im Durchschnitt, jetzt auf die Tage, wo ich gespielt habe,
im Durchschnitt irgendwie 6,5 Stunden gespielt.
Manche Tage mal mehr, aber manche Tage weniger.
Was ist ein Kreiselgrind?
Wie erkläre ich, Chat, wie erkläre ich, was ein Kreiselgrind ist?
Entweder man weiß, was ein Kreiselgrind ist,
oder man weiß nicht, was ein Kreiselgrind ist.
6,5 Stunden am Tag ungefähr, im Durchschnitt, im Durchschnitt.
Gestern waren es 11 Stunden.
Welches MMO?
Dark Edge of Camelot auf dem Free-Shot.
Also, was ist ein Kreiselgrind?
Man grindet im Kreis.
Man...
Ja, ja, okay, okay, das ergibt eigentlich Sinn.
Genau.
Man macht wiederholt, man macht wiederholt, man grindet, man macht wiederholt irgendwas,
zum Beispiel Monsterkill in einem MMO.
Und das halt im gleichen...
Gebiet im Kreis.
Wobei das auch ausgedehnt werden kann auf mehrere Gebiete.
Mit dem Griechen als Leader, ja, der gibt's immer noch.
Der ist immer noch am rumflamen.
Der Grieche, ja, der flamt immer noch rum.
Bulemo.
Der ist immer noch am Start und flamt immer noch die Leute,
wenn sie nicht drauf hören, was er sagt, ja.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich kann dir nur empfehlen,
guck dich, guck dich mal ein bisschen um.
Guck dich, guck dich mal ein bisschen um.
Du wirst aktuell an jeder Ecke was finden.
Und da muss halt passen, ein Kollege von mir hat sich auch wo beworben.
Der wurde richtig gebetet.
Hör, hör, hör dich das mal an.
Und zwar, der hat sich beworben auf eine Stelle.
Die haben geschrieben, in der Stellenanzeige,
also ist jetzt nicht mich, ist jetzt nicht von mir, ja,
von jemand bei mir auf der Arbeit, der sich auch grad woanders bewirbt.
Also, der hat sich auf eine Stelle beworfen, beworben,
irgendwas, äh, Senior,
Senior-Customer, frag mich nicht.
Es war nicht First Level, es war so, ich weiß gar nicht, in welche Richtung,
das war irgendwie, irgendwelche Support-Fälle,
nicht direkt mit Endkunden, sondern irgendwelche Support-Fälle optimiert bei Arbeit,
frag mich nicht genau.
Da hat sich irgendwie als Senior-Support-Happiness-Specialist,
frag mich nicht, wie das, wie das hieß, beworben.
Das war ja auch ganz gut.
Weil der arbeitet bei uns auch im Support.
Zumindest hat er sich beworben.
Und die hatten in der Stellenanzeige stehen,
Gehaltsspanne, was ich schon cool fand, dass das in der Stellenanzeige drin stand.
Zumindest hatten die, hatten die wohl in der Stellenanzeige drin stehen,
Gehaltsspanne 95k bis 105k.
So.
Stand da drin, hat er mir erzählt.
Dann hat er sich dort beworben.
Lief auch richtig gut.
Ähm, dann sollten, dann hat er zusammen mit denen so ein paar Support-Fälle,
ähm, ein paar Support-Fälle.
Ähm, dann sollten, dann hat er zusammen mit denen so ein paar Support-Fälle.
Dann hat er sich dort beworben.
besprochen sowie wie würden sie folgenden fall bearbeiten und sowas in
der richtung waren sie auch alle von ihm begeistert und haben gesagt jawohl sie
schicken ihm jetzt ein angebot und jetzt kam der tschi bait jetzt kam der tschi
bait dass das des jahres sie haben ein angebot geschickt für 75
k und da meinte er moment ihr habt doch in
eurem wir haben die ganze zeit doch von 95 bis 100 k gesprochen und sogar in
eurer stellenanzeige stand was drin und da meinten die seriously drauf als
begründung dafür ja wir haben leider das budget für eine seniorstelle nicht
genehmigt bekommen jetzt wegen ist das jetzt eine normale was ein beschiss was
ein beschiss du machst erst mal das komplette bewerbungsverfahren und so
durch in dem glauben es passt am ende was was ein beschiss
macht
, ich frage mich hat er hat er gemacht also er ist nicht aufgestanden und
gegangen er hat gesagt ne kommt für ihn da nicht in frage und fertig was ein
beschiss oder muss dir mal vorstellen was was erwarten die sich denn davon
denken die dann die leute sagen da habe ich jetzt schon so viel energie
reingesteckt ich gebe ich gebe mich dann auch damit mit was was was erwarten was
denken die sich und vor allem wie planlos muss der laden dann intern sein
wenn sie eine stelle ausschreiben die noch gar nicht genehmigt ist und so was
also da habe ich mir auch an den kopf geklopft als er mir das erzählt er dachte
mir was zum teufel was ist denn mit denen los
exakt für die exakt gleiche stelle ja richtig twe hat ja ich frage ich bin mir
gar nicht sicher ob das überhaupt zulässig ist also das war da habe ich
vielleicht also als er mir das als er mir das erzählte habe ich auch ganz ein
Alter, die wollen einen wirklich, das ist ja schon fast Scam.
Und ob es wirklich überhaupt zulässig ist, weiß ich gar nicht.
Das müsst ihr mir jetzt irgendwie mal fragen, der sich da mit Job- und Arbeitsrecht und sowas auskennt.
Keine Ahnung, ob das überhaupt erlaubt ist.
Das war richtig, war richtig Beschiss.
Ne, es war noch nicht mal Headhunter-Scam.
Es war direkt von der Firma selbst.
Musstest du Programmier- oder Coding-Interviews machen?
Nein, musste ich bis jetzt noch nicht.
Aber ich habe mich auch noch nie als hauptberuflicher Entwickler beworben.
Ihr wisst, dass ich gerne Sachen programmiere und Sachen bastle und Tools entwickle und sonst was.
Ich meine, ich habe nicht umsonst ein paar...
Wie viel hat eigentlich der Fiat Champ mittlerweile für Sterne?
Guck mal, 38 Sterne.
Richtig stonks.
Geht steil, der Fiat Champ auf GitHub.
Tja, ne, aber musste ich noch nicht machen.
Ich musste mir allerdings schon die ein oder anderen Fragen stellen lassen,
wie ich spezielle Sachen...
wie ich die Szenarien händeln würde, ja.
Zum Beispiel, wie ich Cloud-Kosten kontrollieren würde.
Sowas in der Richtung, ja.
Da kann man dann zum Beispiel als Antwort geben.
Ja, muss man halt gucken, was man für eine Plattform verwenden kann,
ob man Limits setzen kann.
Ansonsten kann man das natürlich auch automatisch überwachen.
Man kann Trends sich angucken.
Aber Limits ist natürlich das Beste, um auf jeden Fall sicher zu gehen,
dass man nicht über Nacht 40.000 Euro für sinnlose Sachen ausgibt.
Und man sollte nach Möglichkeit keine Cloud-Functions verwenden,
die sich gegenseitig aufrufen.
Und das dann auch im Kreis.
Ich hatte mich als...
Okay, was sagt Stripes hier?
Er hatte sich als Entwickler beworben und die Stelle war Junior Backend Dev.
Mit 60 keine Anzeige.
Angewohnt wird dann später...
Das ist natürlich für die nicht...
Ja, okay, wenn du damit zufrieden bist, ist ja okay.
Aber ich find's immer...
Also, ich find das schon ein bisschen shady,
immer diese Sachen so anzupreisen und am Ende zu sagen,
ach, nee, nee, haben wir uns vertan oder...
geht jetzt doch nicht.
Ah, das Budget ist nicht da.
Dann frag ich mich halt immer, was intern da an der...
bei der Koordination falsch läuft,
wenn das denn wirklich stimmt.
Vielleicht ist es einfach auch vorsätzlicher Scam,
dass man Leute günstiger kriegt.
Also, gerade mit...
mit...
Azure Functions
oder AWS.
Wie heißt...
Lambda heißt da, glaub ich, genau.
Oh, so ein ganzes Server...
Da kannst du ganz schnell extrem viel Geld loswerden, wenn man will.
Ah, nee, was heißt, wenn man will?
Auch, wenn man nicht will.
Nee, wie gesagt, wenn du damit am Ende zufrieden bist, ist ja gut.
Ja, Junior zum Berufseinstieg ist das schon alles okay,
du lernst auch...
Also, du lernst die ersten 1-2 Jahre...
Gut.
Ich meine, nicht jeder, aber ich gehe davon aus,
wenn man...
wenn man sich auch wirklich dafür interessiert
und das nicht einfach nur macht, weil es sonst nichts anderes gibt,
die ersten 1-2-3 Jahre so viel,
dass sie einen dann auf jeden Fall aufstocken müssen,
sonst bezahlen die anderen deutlich mehr.
Checkmk...
Ja, Checkmk kenne ich.
Das war früher eine Nagios Fork.
Mittlerweile bin ich...
Mittlerweile weiß ich gar nicht,
was da noch so geht.
Lange nicht...
Lange nichts mehr mitgemacht.
Letzter Zeit hauptsächlich Prometheus, Grafana und ein bisschen Zabbix.
Ja, das sind so Sachen, die noch irgendwo okay sind.
Man muss es halt im Vorfeld wissen.
Leute, ich kann euch nur eins viel sagen.
Ich habe die Gehaltsberechnung bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber...
oder wahrscheinlich neuen Arbeitgeber nicht so ganz gecheckt.
Das mussten sie mir 30 Minuten lang erklären,
wie sich da was errechnet aus Grund und Bonus und Fest und sonst was.
Aber ich glaube, jetzt habe ich es gecheckt.
Nice.
Okay, dann skaliert das wahrscheinlich deutlich besser als eine einzelne Zabbix Instanz.
Weil Zabbix skaliert nicht so richtig gescheit.
Das skaliert nicht diagonal.
Und wir wissen ja, die einzig wahre Skalierung ist diagonal.
Weil dann hat man horizontal und vertikal gleich mit drin.
Und man muss nur einmal skalieren.
Da sind wir uns einig, oder?
70 Server.
Ordentlich.
Nicht zwangsläufig.
Ich glaube, da ist auch vieles Motivation drin.
Weil wenn du zum Beispiel so ein bisschen das ganze erfolgsabhängig ist,
also wie gut geht es der Firma, wie gut hast du deine eigenen Sachen gemacht,
ist das sicherlich für viele Leute ja durchaus auch Motivation,
zu sagen, okay, ich strenge mich jetzt besonders an.
Finde ich ja auch nichts Verwerfliches dran.
Kann man ja machen.
Sind 55k für Bachelor Informatik ein Jahr Berufserfahrung im DevOp Backend gut?
Also es klingt durchaus in Ordnung.
Ja.
So als Berufseinsteiger ist das, denke ich, ganz okay.
Es kommt natürlich immer auf die Region an, was man genau macht, wie viel Plan man hat und alles drumherum.
Kann man so pauschal natürlich nicht sagen.
Aber klingt doch erstmal in Ordnung.
Natürlich müssen sich die nächsten Jahre über, muss ich dann ein bisschen was tun, das ist ja klar.
Aber zum Einstieg.
Also ich kann euch sagen, was ich zum Einstieg verdient habe.
Wollt ihr es wissen?
Und zwar, also Ausbildungsgehalt kann ich euch nicht mehr sagen.
Habe ich wirklich keine Ahnung.
Aber ich kann euch sagen, was ich damals zum Einstieg verdient habe.
Beim Internetprovider.
Wo ich nach der Ausbildung angefangen habe.
Und ich habe 33.500 Euro im Jahr verdient.
Das war aber 2010.
Also schon 12 Jahre her, nach der Ausbildung.
Oder 2009 könnte es sogar gewesen sein.
Ne, 2010 war das relativ sicher.
Da habe ich mit 33.500 Euro angefangen beim Provider.
Habe ich ein Jahr gemacht.
Dann bin ich gewechselt.
Für deutlich mehr.
Wie lange für Caddy?
Caddy ist richtig Porgas, ja.
Sofern man nichts Advances machen muss.
Was manchmal ein bisschen schwierig ist, teilweise gar nicht geht.
Also wenn man, für das was es ist, ist Caddy wirklich top.
Keine Ahnung.
Zu Softwareentwickler kann ich nichts sagen.
Klingt aber erstmal echt nicht übel, das Einstieg.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, nice, nice, nice.
Ja.
So muss es sein.
Die müssen, die müssen ja ordentlich, die müssen noch mal ein bisschen was, da muss ich mal ein bisschen was rumkommen.
Gerade in der heutigen Zeit.
Ich bin da, ich gehe stark davon aus, dass viele Unternehmen so günstig wegkommen, weil die Leute so faul sind wie ich.
Und sich nicht umschauen.
Obwohl sie eigentlich wissen, dass es woanders zur Zeit richtig, richtig gut Kohle abgibt.
Und Kohle abzusahnen gibt.
Weiß nicht, wer von euch ist auch noch faul as fuck?
Seid mal ehrlich, Leute.
Was heißt faul?
Faul ist das falsche Wort.
Gewohnheitstiermäßig as fuck halt, ja.
Bei mir hat es erst, hat es das jetzt halt erst gebraucht, dass ich erstens eh schon ein paar Sachen habe, die mir beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber auf den Keks gehen.
Und halt die ganze hin und her, was Homeoffice angeht.
Das ist das, was mich halt jetzt im Endeffekt dazu gebracht hat, wirklich mal nach was anderem umzugucken.
Und es hat sich auf mehreren Ebenen jetzt schon gelohnt.
Erstens ein bisschen die Erfahrung wieder, was, was Bewerben, Vorstellungsgespräche angeht.
Und den neuen Job, den ich jetzt gefunden habe, ist sowohl von dem, was ich bisher gesehen habe, arbeitstechnisch sehr nice und bezahlungsmäßig auch sehr nice.
Also insofern, es lohnt sich eigentlich fast immer.
Es ist, es ist ein bisschen Voraussetzung.
Das ist aber auch wichtig, dass IT-Leute faul sind.
Faul auf eine ganze gewisse Art und Weise.
Nämlich faul in der Form, dass man dadurch...
Dass man dadurch, dass man faul ist und nicht eine Sache 3, 4, 5 mal machen will, sie ordentlich macht, beziehungsweise so durchdacht macht, dass sie nicht wieder kaputt geht.
Das heißt, eine gewisse, sage ich ja auch immer, eine gewisse Faulheit ist für Admins und Programmierer gar nicht verkehrt.
Der Lebenslauf wird in Markdown geschrieben.
Also ich habe den Lebenslauf tatsächlich nicht in Markdown geschrieben, weil ich den Lebenslauf mit einer Vorlage gebaut habe.
Ähm, meine Skill-Liste habe ich aber in Markdown geschrieben.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
Korrekt, so sieht es aus.
Effizient muss man sein, beziehungsweise das Wichtigste ist, durchdachte, durchdachte Lösungen sich überlegen, ja.
Also Sachen, die halt nicht morgen wieder kaputt gehen, einfach nur, dass es schnell fertig ist.
Sondern irgendwas, was effizient gemacht ist, aber auch durchdacht genug, dass es eben halt nicht, wenn man hinguckt, gleich wieder zusammenfällt.
Max, hast du eigentlich ein Wiki?
Du meinst, wo ich Zeug bei mir aufschreibe?
Ja, ich habe ein Doku-Wiki bei mir lokal, wobei, das verwende ich eigentlich nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, das kann ich auch mal abschalten.
Ich schreibe das einfach in Notiz, Notizen auf und gut ist.
Weil, dass es im Browser ist, ist gar nicht so wichtig.
Ob ich es jetzt in einem Notizprogramm habe oder im Browser, ist eigentlich zweitrangig.
Wie gesagt, genau, genau sage ich es dir nicht, aber nachdem mich der Chat ja vorhin schon gelöchert hat.
Beim neuen Job ist es dann sechsstellig, aber genaues erzähle ich nicht.
Muss ich erst mal abwarten.
Was, was?
Ja, wie offen man dort gegenüber ist, wenn man Sachen erzählt im Internet, weiß ich ja noch nicht.
Ich meine, an sich ist es nichts Geheimes.
Ja, es ist nichts Geheimes.
Rein rechtlich gesehen darf einem das der Arbeitgeber auch gar nicht verbieten, über Gehalt, Geld zu sprechen.
Das machen viele, sagen so, wird nicht erzählt.
Darf man aber eigentlich nicht.
Ach so, ich arbeite nur 80 Prozent.
Ja, ja, und mit 80 Prozent sind es keine 100k.
100k oder nicht über 100k.
Ja, auf fünf Tage gerechnet, auf fünf Tage gerechnet.
Ich schenke es ab.
Ja, ich muss auch gucken, wo ich bleibe.
Gasrechnung, Heizungsrechnung, 5000 Euro neuer Rechner.
Irgendwie muss ich das ja alles bezahlen.
Weiß dein neuer Arbeitgeber?
Ja, theoretisch wissen die das und ich habe es in meinem Lebenslauf stehen.
Ich habe im Lebenslauf stehen, dass ich nebenberuflich, nebenberuflich selbstständiger Webvideoproduzent bin.
Ja, so gut wie, ich habe den Vertrag, ich habe alles schon, ich habe bloß noch den Vertrag noch nicht in der Post.
Du findest, denke ich, eine Ausbildung.
Also aktuell ist es im IT-Sektor wirklich gut.
Wie es in der Ausbildung aktuell aussieht, Ausbildungsplätze zu finden, weiß ich zurzeit nicht mit beschäftigen müssen.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es auch ausbildungstechnisch zurzeit recht gut ist.
Hehehe, nice.
Ja, das ist übrigens, weil die Frage öfters kommt, das ist Christmas Nintendo Music, Happy Tunes for Holidays, Wintersongs.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich die Frage.
Also bei mir in der Ausbildung, also das Unternehmen, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe, das war auch nicht normal.
Es gab nämlich an sich keine Ausbildung.
Die Ausbildung war, so du bist jetzt Azubi bei uns, mach jetzt mal.
Und da hattest du die Chance, entweder...
Lernst du was und machst, oder du sitzt drei Jahre rum und hast am Ende nichts gelernt.
So eine wirkliche Ausbildung gab es da nicht, ja?
Ähm, nein, nein, nein, nein, kenne ich keins zu.
Du musst aber mal Battleship.
Wenn du sowas suchst, guck mal in diese Liste.
Guck mal in diese Liste rein.
Da sind immer ganz gut self-hosted Projekte, also ohne Cloud drin.
Natürlich ist es nicht top aktuell und manche Sachen fehlen auch, aber das ist schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Tipps fürs Bewerben. Bin nach Ausbildung und zwei Jahre Berufsverfahren als Softwareentwickler auch zu überlegen.
Okay, lass mal überlegen. Tipps sich zu bewerben.
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt absolut den Easy Mode, ja?
Ich kannte jemanden, der mich quasi empfohlen hat, das ist natürlich immer...
Aber aktuell muss man sich...
Also eine Sache muss man sich vergegenwärtigen, bevor man Bewerbungen schreibt, ist...
Dass gerade in der aktuellen Zeit im IT-Sektor, wo es ja nur wirklich ziemlich schwierig ist, für die Unternehmen Leute zu bekommen,
vor allem noch schwieriger ist, Leute auch mit Ahnung zu bekommen, die dann auch noch zu dem passen, was sie suchen,
dass sich in beide Richtungen beworben wird.
Also du musst nicht ganz zu sehr Arsch kriechen, ja?
Also du musst dich bewerben, aber es muss dich auch ansprechen, weil du hast genug Auswahl aktuell.
Das muss man sich erst mal ein bisschen im Kopf rufen.
Also...
Man soll sich nicht auffühlen wie die Axt im Walde oder so, das meine ich nicht.
Aber du musst jetzt nicht alles mitmachen, wenn da irgendwie einer von dir will, dass du zusätzlich da noch Wochenendschicht machst,
zusätzlich Nachteinsatz machst, zusätzlich hier und jenes und das und das am besten noch kostenlos und ohne bezahlten Überstunden.
Da sagst du, nö, dann könnt ihr euch jemand anderes suchen.
Also es muss...
Du hast...
Du hast Auswahl.
So, und dann als...
Okay, Tipps.
Was habe ich...
Habe ich überhaupt sinnvolle Tipps zum Bewerben?
Also meine Bewerbungserfahrung sieht ja wirklich mau aus.
Ich habe eine Ausbildung gemacht, da habe ich mich beworben drauf, habe mehr oder weniger gleich beim zweiten Anlauf oder fast schon der erste Anlauf eigentlich die Ausbildungsstelle gekriegt.
So, dann bin ich gewechselt.
Das ging auch...
Die kannte ich schon, da musste ich auch nicht großartig schreiben.
So, das heißt, ich habe mich jetzt seit über zehn Jahren zum ersten Mal richtig beworben.
Und jetzt, wo es geklappt hat, auch noch...
Also beides mal auf Empfehlung.
Also, ich habe eine Ausbildung hin von jemand, der schon dort arbeitet.
Also, ich glaube, so die richtigen Hardcore-Tipps kann ich dir jetzt nicht geben.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die mir aufgefallen sind.
Also, das erste ist, guck dir immer, bevor du in Vorstellungsgespräch gehst, guck dir immer an, deine eigene...
Also, nimm es am besten mit zum Spicken, ja.
Nimm deine eigene Bewerbung mit, deine eigene Skill-Liste, deinen eigenen Lebenslauf, nimm den mit.
Oder wenn es Remote ist, mach es dir auf.
Mach dir die Stellenanzeige an.
Mach dir die Stellenanzeige auf, weil die fragen dich dann manchmal auch Sachen, wo sie sich irgendwie auf die Stellenanzeige beziehen.
Und im ersten Bewerbungsgespräch hatte ich die Stellenanzeige nicht offen.
Und er hat mich gefragt, ja, sie haben ja die Stellenanzeige sicherlich genau gelesen.
Und da steht drin und ich mir so, äh, was?
Keine Ahnung, was da drin steht jetzt aus dem Kopf, Mann.
Aber ich habe da nebenbei auf...
Das war Remote, aber ich habe da nebenbei aufgemacht.
Also, ja, das würde ich dir empfehlen, also sich da ordentlich darauf vorzubereiten.
Es kann tatsächlich auch nicht schaden, mal den Wikipedia-Artikel des jeweiligen Arbeitgebers oder die Seite von dem sich anzugucken, einfach mal so ungefähr in welche Richtung es geht.
Weil das, es hilft einfach, ja.
Wenn die schreiben zum Beispiel auf ihrer Webseite, ja, sie benutzen hauptsächlich Azure und Microsoft Cloud oder sie machen hauptsächlich Linux mit den und den Technologien, was auch immer.
Dann ist es nicht verkehrt, das immer mal wieder anzumerken.
Dass man sich ja damit auch auskennt.
So, auf der anderen Seite bewerben die sich genauso bei dir.
Also, die müssen dich natürlich auch von sich überzeugen.
Gerade in der heutigen Zeit wachsen die, wachsen die Bewerber ja auch nicht gerade auf dem, auf dem Baum.
Oh, ansonsten kann ich dir wahrscheinlich gar nicht allzu viel raten, ehrlich gesagt.
GitHub-Profil ist nicht verkehrt.
Gerade, wenn du dich als Softwareentwickler bewirbst.
GitHub-Profil.
Falls du eins hast.
GitHub-Profil mit ein paar, mit ein paar Projekten drauf.
Ich habe das hier beispielsweise auch angegeben.
Ich habe tatsächlich den Fiat Champ in meiner Bewerbung angegeben.
Und das war auch Thema im Vorstellungsgespräch.
Und zwar, dass ich, dass ich Hobbymäßig halt Heimautomatisierung bei mir daheim ziemlich übertrieben habe, ja.
Ja, aber du hast ja die Abschlussprüfung gemacht als AE, oder?
Ja, Pferdeinformatik, Albumentwicklung.
Du kannst es natürlich auch über irgendeine Vermittlerbude machen.
Ja, keine Frage.
Also, wenn du dir LinkedIn Account machst.
Das ist wahrscheinlich der, der beste Tipp tatsächlich.
Mach dir LinkedIn Account, schreib drauf, was du kannst und du kriegst am Tag 450, 420 Recruiter-Anfragen, die wahrscheinlich zu 99% Mist sind.
Aber du kriegst viele Anfragen.
Also, ein anderer Kollege von mir, von dem ich weiß, dass der sich auch gerade was sucht.
Ihr werdet euch fragen.
aber verdammt viele, Max, wo du
aktuell arbeitest, sich einen neuen Job. Und ja,
das ist richtig. Ich weiß von mindestens
sieben Leuten
in der IT bei uns. Von sieben Leuten.
Also nur von denen, wo ich öfters mit
was zu tun habe. Mindestens sieben Leute,
die gerade sich einen neuen Job suchen.
Mach dir ein LinkedIn-Profil.
Oder lass dir
von irgendeinem Recruiter da was vermitteln.
Schadet auf jeden Fall nichts. Anhören kann man
sich das. Dein Vater ratet
dir immer zu viel Arsch zu kriechen. Ich hasse
Arschgegrieche.
Ich krieche
keinem in den Arsch.
Sowohl im praktischen Sinne
als auch im übertragenen Sinne nicht.
Also,
ich finde das unsinnig.
Weil, ganz im Ernst,
man muss ja nicht unfreundlich sein.
Ja, das heißt ja gar nicht.
Also, man muss jetzt nicht,
also, wenn man nett ist,
beziehungsweise die Sachen ein bisschen
ja, freundlich
formuliert,
das hat ja
über, das schadet,
das schadet ja wirklich keinem, ja.
Also, man muss ja nicht sagen,
das, was ihr euch da immer ausdenkt, ist totaler
Scheiß. Wie kann man nur so dumm sein,
sowas zu machen? Ja, das muss man
vielleicht nicht so sagen. Aber man kann
durchaus sagen, wenn man das
für bescheuert hält,
aus Gründen A, B,
C, kann man das ruhig sagen.
Warum man das blödsinnig findet.
Also, man muss nicht immer nur, weil
irgendwie einer gesagt hat, ja, das ist jetzt so
das Beste, auch da immer
zustimmen.
Und gerade das ist es meiner Meinung nach
auch, was Lösungen
technisch besser werden lässt,
wenn nicht alles unhinterfragt
umgesetzt wird, nur weil
sich irgendeiner das mal so ausgedacht
hat. Sondern wenn man feststellt, dass man
da Sachen besser machen könnte oder vielleicht auch
feststellt, das kann so gar nicht funktionieren,
dass man das sagt.
Und wenn man das irgendwo nicht mehr sagen
kann, dann hat die, dann hat
dieses Unternehmen wirkliche Probleme, was
innovative Sachen angeht und
wahrscheinlich auch, ja,
keine, über längere Zeit, eine
keine allzu gute Zukunft, weil
sobald du sowas nicht mehr ansprechen kannst, also
Sachen, die objektiv nicht gut sind,
was übrigens auch eine der Probleme ist, die ich dort
habe, wo ich gerade aktuell arbeite,
dann ist das, sieht das nicht so gut aus.
Also, Rumgeschleime finde ich nicht gut.
Man kann nett sein zu den Leuten, das finde ich immer,
ich finde wichtig, dass das Arbeitsklima gut ist
und die Leute permanent
anzukacken, ist sicherlich nicht
the way,
aber wenn was nicht gut ist, kann man das schon
sagen. Würdest du sagen, man hat in der
IT noch Zukunftschancen? Ja, klar, wenn,
wenn da, wo sonst?
Nein, das ist
Blödsinn, das wird nicht passieren.
Das, das wird nicht passieren.
Es wird
in Zukunft eher noch schlimmer werden,
weil, also, es gibt einen Grund,
das habe ich ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt, es gibt einen Grund, warum ich glaube,
dass es sogar noch zunehmen wird. Das ist folgendes.
Es gibt einige Branchen,
ja, denkt, denkt mal an
Bergarbeiter oder sowas. Gut, die braucht man jetzt
gar nicht mehr, ja, aber denkt mal beispielsweise
an irgendwelche fließbaren
Tätigkeiten oder in der Fabrik.
Es gibt viele Arbeiten,
die wurden bis vor kurzem
oder werden immer noch
von Hand oder von,
sag mal, zumindest
Leuten, die, ja,
mit manuellen Handgriffen da involviert
sind, ausgeführt. Diese Jobs
werden in den nächsten Jahren auf jeden Fall
immer weniger werden
und es wird zwar nicht im
gleichen Maße, aber
in, was weiß ich,
ich muss das anders sagen, also,
sag mal, aktuell stehen
am Fließband zehn Leute und
stellen irgendwas her. Das wird
jetzt automatisiert. Dann brauchst
du nicht zehn Programmierer und
Wartungsleute
für die Automatisierung, aber
du brauchst vielleicht zwei.
Also, sag mal, es fallen zehn Leute
weg am Fließband, aber
du brauchst neue Leute zum Programmieren,
zum Entwickeln, zum Warten.
Also, du brauchst neue Techniker oder IT-Leute.
Also, sag mal, zehn fallen weg,
zwei neue IT-Jobs gibt's. Das heißt, es gibt
zwar insgesamt weniger Jobs, vielleicht in dieser
Branche, aber es
gibt insgesamt mehr IT-Jobs und
das wird in nächster Zeit noch deutlich
zunehmen. An vielen Stellen sind
wir teilweise in Deutschland ein bisschen rückständig.
Also, sprich, da werden
noch Faxe verschickt, allein,
dass es sicher zugestellt ist und solche Sachen.
In dem Sektor werden auch mehr IT-Jobs
entstehen und gebraucht werden. Viele
werden jetzt schon gebraucht, können nicht besetzt werden.
Also, ich gehe davon aus, dass
in Zukunft sogar noch schlimmer wird.
Klar, es werden auch Leute ausgebildet,
es gibt auch
Leute, die Informatik studieren, es gibt
schon neue Leute,
die da jetzt reinkommen, aber ich glaube nicht,
dass es das Verhältnis
überschreitet von, es kommen immer mehr Leute nach
zu dem, was neue Stellen gebraucht
werden. Also, ich glaube, in nächster
Zeit wirst du überhaupt keine Probleme
haben, in der IT Leute
Jobs zu finden.
Die werden eher Probleme haben, Leute
zu finden. Und die Unternehmen, die immer
noch der Meinung sind, sie sind
irgendwie die 08155-Mann-Klitsche,
um die Ecke, sind aber das nächste Google.
Auch mit ihren Vorstellungen
und leider nicht bei den
Gehaltsvorstellungen, die werden schlicht
und ergreifend keine Leute finden.
Wenn es so schlimm ist, wieso
zahlen die Unternehmen so schlecht? Tja, die
kriegen auch keine. Die kriegen keine
Leute, die schlecht bezahlen.
Das Einzige, warum die schlecht sich erlauben können,
schlecht zu bezahlen, ist, weil Leute
dort arbeiten, die so faul sind wie ich
und das mitmachen.
Was ja auch
nichts Verwerfliches ist. Also, Geld
ist ja auch nicht alles. Also, wenn man da
super zufrieden mit ist
und prinzipiell mit der Bezahlung
gut über die Runden kommt, spricht
da ja eigentlich auch nichts dagegen. Kann man ja
machen. Ja, aber woanders würdest du wahrscheinlich
mehr Geld kriegen. Ich bin auch zu faul.
Mach dir keine Gedanken drüber. Wir sind alle zu faul.
Ich hab gerade im Chat gefragt, sie sind alle zu faul.
Ich auch. Bei mir
war jetzt aber der Punkt überschritten, als sie
bei mir wieder gesagt haben, Leute sollen alle ins Büro
kommen. Wo ich gesagt hab, was?
Man hat die letzten zweieinhalb Jahre gesehen, wie gut
das funktioniert. Das ist für alle Beteiligten besser.
Was ist mit euch?
Und die können sich das eben
nicht erlauben, schlecht zu bezahlen, weil die, die schlecht
bezahlen, plus auch
nichts zu bieten haben, bekommen schlicht und ergreifend keine
Leute. Ja.
Ich muss gerade mal
den Chat aufholen.
Was ist denn ein Gesellenbrief als Anwendungsentwickler?
Ich kenn nur die IHK
Abschlussprüfung.
Berufsstunde ist für den Arsch, ja.
Ja, das ist, das ist halt
Tobi aber oft so.
Das würde ich aber gar nicht so sehen, dass du als billige
Arbeitskraft benutzt wirst.
Das wirst du. Das werden alle
Azubis letztendlich.
In meinem Ausbildungsbetrieb war es auch so,
wir hatten keine Ausbildung. Entweder hat man
was gemacht und dann was gelernt oder nicht.
Aber meistens
hast du in dem Fall,
das ist ein Gesellenbrief, okay,
meistens hast du in dem Fall die Chance,
wenn du als billige Arbeitskraft
benutzt wirst, dass du wirklich
was lernen musst. Also entweder
machst du halt einfach nix, weil
du nix lernst und dann hast du zwar nach drei Jahren die Ausbildung
fertig, aber hast keine Ahnung. Oder,
du lernst wirklich was,
weil du selbst was machen musst.
Und danach machst du dich einfach vom Acker.
Du musst die Ausbildung benutzen, wirklich
Ahnung zu haben danach, weil
ganz im Ernst, der Ausbildungstitel
am Ende,
alleine bringt der dir auch nicht viel.
Du musst schon ein bisschen
Ahnung haben. Also du kannst
jetzt nicht sagen, Leute, ich hab eine Fachinformatikerausbildung
fertig, aber ich hab
keine Ahnung. Also wenn die beispielsweise jemanden
suchen, sagen wir jetzt
Windows-Entwicklung, wenn die beispielsweise
jemanden suchen, der sich mit
Java, Java ist beliebt im Enterprise-
Umfeld, der sich mit Java
auskennt und dort mit, was weiß
ich, Spring Boot und
Web Services und hast du nicht gesehen
und du sagst, ja, aber ich kann bloß
in Windows 3 Assistenten auf
Next, Next, OK klicken,
dann bringt das nix.
Also du musst in deiner Ausbildung was lernen und da
gibt es eigentlich nix besseres dazu,
wie wenn du wirklich selbst was machen musst.
Und wenn der Laden Kacke ist, dann haust
du danach einfach ab. Und
ob du überqualifiziert bist, das kannst
du, weiß ich nicht, meinst du damit,
du kennst dich schon zu gut aus? Also ich hab viele
Azubis erlebt, die
der Meinung waren, sie haben den super
krassen Plan
und die haben dann
versucht, beispielsweise im Rechenzentrum
eine, einen
eigenen File-Sharing-Dienst zu hosten und sowas.
Also mir sind Azubis
prinzipiell suspekt, die selbst denken,
sie haben den allerkrassensten Plan.
Es geht halt auch im Job
oftmals nicht rein um die Technik,
sondern dass man eben lernt, wie das,
wie man diese Technik im Business Enterprise
Umfeld anwendet.
Weil es ist ein Unterschied, ob du beispielsweise
Anwendungen daheim als
Hobby, just for fun,
mit dir alleine
entwickelst, ja,
die am Endeffekt auch keiner wirklich benutzen
wird und du alleine dran bauen kannst, wie du willst,
oder ob du das im Team mit
15 Leuten machst und im Endeffekt gehen
Millionen verloren, wenn das mal irgendwelche Probleme gibt.
Ja, die Sprache
ist die gleiche, die Frameworks sind die gleichen,
im Prinzip das, was du machst, ist das gleiche,
aber so dieser Enterprise
Business Faktor dabei, der ist nicht zu
unterschätzen und das lernt man
tatsächlich nur mit Erfahrung
und halt auch nur auf der Arbeit.
Das kannst du nicht alleine lernen.
Das ist jetzt nicht nur
im Anwendungsentwicklungssektor
so ist, wenn du Systeme
administrierst, also wenn du System
Integrator bist, also quasi
meist Leute sind ja sowas wie Server Admin dann,
da ist das ähnlich. Es ist ein Unterschied,
ob du bei Hetzner 3 Kisten bei dir
hast, daheim und da machst du ein bisschen was drauf,
oder ob du 5000
Linux Server hast, worauf
wichtige Systeme
laufen, wo dann im Endeffekt die Abrechnung
nicht mehr funktioniert für euren Außendienst, oder
wo dann vielleicht sogar die ganze
die ganze, das ganze
Trading nicht mehr funktioniert oder was in der
Richtung.
Da hängt halt ein bisschen was anderes dran,
wie bei deinen 3 Hetzner Servern.
Und das lernt man halt daheim nicht, das lernt man
tatsächlich nur da im Business Umfeld,
zumal es oftmals auch die Zusammenarbeit
ist, die sich schwierig gestaltet.
Du musst dann gucken,
irgendjemand programmiert die Anwendung,
irgendjemand ist für
Wartungsarbeiten, Change Koordination zuständig,
du musst auf dem Server XY
machen, das lernt man halt nur im Business
Umfeld und das ist wichtig, dass man das auch während der Ausbildung
lernt, weil
Technik auf der einen Seite schön und gut,
aber du musst doch wissen, wie du die Technik
im Business Umfeld anwendest.
Es hört sich jetzt ein bisschen abstrakt an,
aber ich glaube, man weiß, wie ich das meine.
Aber das wichtigste ist
natürlich immer noch, dass man von der Technik Ahnung
hat, da gibt es nichts.
Da muss man einen Plan haben. Gibt es bestimmte
Branchen, in denen die IT-Aufgaben besonders
spannend sind? IT-Aufgaben können überall
spannend sein.
Kommt auf das Unternehmen an
und selbst wenn es auf den ersten Blick wie der
langweiligste Laden aller Zeiten aussieht, können
die Aufgaben trotzdem spannend sein.
Hängt natürlich auch ein bisschen was von deinen
Kenntnissen, deinen Vorlieben ab
und was am Ende ist, es kann so
überall sein.
Was hältst du von einer Karriere als
IT-Consultant? Nichts.
Was hältst du von Kununu? Finde ich nicht
verkehrt. Ja, finde ich
nicht verkehrt.
Gucke ich auch immer.
Wobei manche
Wertungen da wirklich
die schreien schon fake.
Wenn ich bei Kununu manche Bewertungen lese,
denke ich mir auch, was zum Teufel ist da los?
Das ist dann so richtig
in personaler
Deutsch geschrieben schon, wo du dir denkst,
da hat sich einer von der Personalabteilung hingesetzt
und sich selbst eine gute Bewertung
verpasst, so nach dem Motto.
Wisst ihr,
wenn Bewertungen geschrieben sind auf die
gleiche Art und Weise wie Stellenanzeigen
geschrieben sind so, dann denkst du dir schon, da kann doch
was nicht stimmen.
Ein Top-Unternehmen
mit einem jungen, dynamischen,
motiviertem Team, hier
erreicht man noch
gemeinsam seine Ziele. Ein
ganz tolles Unternehmen.
Und wenn du solche Bewertungen siehst bei Kununu,
dann weißt du schon immer, Moment,
da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Das ist irgendein Typ, der dort
arbeitet und wahrscheinlich sich selbst
5 Sterne geben will.
Aber die Seite an sich
finde ich sehr praktisch.
Also die Sache ist halt die,
dann geht es dir wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen wie bei mir.
Ich war eigentlich zufrieden mit dem,
was ich verdiene. Darum ging es mir
gar nicht. Ich habe aber auch gesagt,
hey, wenn man sich mal umschaut,
das habe ich ja schon die letzten paar Jahre
gemacht, wenn man sich umschaut, woanders
gibt es eine ganze Ecke mehr.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie doppelt so
viel oder so, aber es ist schon ein bisschen mehr.
Und es gibt da noch
ein paar andere Faktoren, die mich da gestört haben.
Und ich habe das jetzt, ich habe das
total oft angesprochen bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Also, dass ich mit den Homeoffice-Regelungen
nicht zufrieden bin, wie es mit Geld
aussieht, mit Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten,
hat sich nie was getan.
Ja, Arbeitskolleg von mir,
übrigens, by the way, der,
der sich jetzt mit mir dort auch beworben hat,
bei der neuen Stelle,
dem haben sie zweimal, muss man sich mal
vorstellen, da ist er glaube ich auch schon acht Jahre
oder so da gewesen,
bei dem Laden. Und
sie haben, das muss man sich vielleicht mal
auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, ja,
er hat auch schon mehrfach dort Sachen angesprochen,
die nicht gut funktionieren.
Und man hat ihm versprochen,
dass man sich den Problem
annehmen wird und auch
schaut, was Schulung angeht, was
Weiterentwicklungsmöglichkeiten angeht,
was Gehalt angeht und solche
Geschichten. Und da hat man mit ihm einen
zweieinhalb-Jahres-Plan war
das, glaube ich, gemacht. So.
Die haben mit ihm quasi
was ausgehandelt über zweieinhalb Jahre.
Und jetzt ratet mal, was passiert
ist davon. Okay,
ich muss euch anders fragen.
Ratet mal von diesen vier, fünf
Punkten, die in diesem Plan drin
standen, wovon ihm persönlich
eigentlich nur zwei Punkte wirklich wichtig
waren. Wie viel von diesen,
also wie viel der zwei Punkte, oder ist
eines dieser Punkte erfüllt worden
nach zweieinhalb Jahren? Nichts,
korrekt. So.
Daraufhin ist nichts, also
bei den anderen Punkten ist was passiert,
aber das waren so, so beiläufige,
so, so beiläufige Sachen, ja.
Ähm,
so, also bei den wichtigen
zwei Punkten, um die es ihm ging, ist nichts passiert.
Dann hat er sich
darauf eingelassen, dass sie nochmal
einen Zweijahresplan gemacht haben.
Danach nochmal,
gleich, aber gleich, gleich kommt
der Hit, da lacht er, da lacht er euch kaputt.
So, sie haben nochmal einen
Zweijahresplan mit ihm gemacht, und
davon wurde ein Punkt
nach diesen zwei Jahren, ein
Punkt wurde so
naja, halbherzig erledigt.
Und zwar ging es darum, er hat sich immer
drüber beschwert, ist übrigens jemand, der
im Support arbeitet,
und er hat sich immer drüber
beschwert, dass sie
im Endeffekt von so vielen Technologien
Ahnung haben müssen, zumindest überblicksweise
Ahnung haben müssen, dass
also mit Support meine ich nicht
Endkunden-Support, sondern eigentlich ist es eher
quasi so Eskalation
und Entstörung, also
sprich, die überwachen
unsere Systeme 24-7,
müssen, wenn es Fehler gibt, einschätzen,
wie kritisch ist das Ganze,
und dann Entstörung in die Wege leiten,
und Leute anrufen nachts,
und das koordinieren, also das ist tatsächlich nicht
ganz so ohne, es ist nicht
Hallo, hier ist der Vodafone Support oder so
was.
Und der hat sich schon jahrelang drüber
beschwert, dass sie so viele verschiedene
Technologien hier im Einsatz haben, und die Firma
es einfach nicht auf die Reihe bekommt,
dass man
halbwegs Schritt hält,
bei ihrem,
bei ihrer Ahnung im Endeffekt, also zum Beispiel,
dass neue Technologien eingesetzt werden,
aber die sind dann
immer live, obwohl noch nie
irgendjemand ihnen was erklärt hat dazu.
Und zum Beispiel auch
was Cloud-Sachen angeht, hat er schon
seit Jahren erzählt, lasst uns doch
mal wenigstens für alle Leute
die Basic-Azure-Schulung
machen, dass die Leute zumindest so die Grundlagen
einschätzen können. Das hat die Firma
alles nicht auf die Reihe bekommen, richtig?
Und
man hat das jetzt halbherzig
gelöst, diesen Punkt,
also es ging ihm noch nicht mal wirklich um mehr Geld
oder sowas, jetzt erst in dem
einen Punkt, sondern einfach nur,
dass er seine Arbeit tatsächlich besser machen kann,
so und wisst ihr, wie sie das jetzt gelöst
haben? Es gibt jetzt ein
so Seminarbuchungssystem,
da kann man sich für Schulungen eintragen.
Wann die Schulungen stattfinden, steht
komplett in den Sternen.
Geile Lösung, ja, super. So und
jetzt kommt der Hit. Das ist übrigens jemand,
mit dem ich mich super verstehe
und
wo es wirklich schade gewesen wäre, wenn wir nicht
mehr zusammenarbeiten können, und das ist
derjenige, mit dem ich
mich zusammen beworben hab,
dort, bei der anderen Firma jetzt.
Und wir gehen
beide jetzt quasi zu einer anderen
Firma und
wisst ihr, was der Hit ist?
Jetzt, wo der gesagt hat, Jungs,
ich mach mich vom Acker.
Und ich hab ja auch gesagt, Jungs, ich mach mich dann
demnächst vom Acker. Jetzt, wo er
gesagt hat, ich mach mich vom Acker,
kam sie um die Ecke,
das ist kein Spaß, haben sie
zu ihm gesagt, wir arbeiten
gerade an einem neuen 3,5
Jahre Plan.
3,5 Jahre Plan.
Also, was zum Teufel.
Also, man hat ja schon gesehen,
wie gut, wie gut die letzten
Pläne funktioniert haben.
Und jetzt 3,5 Jahre Plan,
Alter, was zum Teufel, Mann.
Das ist also,
da sind sich der Management echt gar nichts
zu schade, ey.
Also, keine Ahnung,
wie ich jetzt da drauf gekommen bin, aber
ja, mit dem fang ich demnächst zusammen
beim neuen, bei dem neuen
Unternehmen an, ja.
Ich bin echt froh,
weil mit dem versteh ich mich super
und wenn ich mit dem Sachen zusammen mache,
kommt noch immer gutes Zeug bei raus.
Ja, ihr kennt, als war ich, wie ich drauf gekommen bin, genau.
Ja, das ist bei uns auch, bei uns werden
die Leute auch immer hingehalten. Du musst
letztendlich irgendwann sagen, Alter, ist mir
zu wenig oder manche andere Sachen gehen mir auf den Keks.
Ich such mir was Neues und entweder,
was sein kann,
dass sie dir dann ein ordentliches Gegenangebot
machen, wobei man dann halt immer sagen muss,
die Probleme, die dir auf den Keks gegangen
sind, wenn sie nicht nur finanzieller
Natur waren,
sind ja immer noch da, deswegen ist das
mit Gegenangebot annehmen immer so ein bisschen fraglich.
Aber natürlich,
die machen das auf Sparflamme, wenn die denken,
die Leute hauen dich ab. Und in der aktuellen Zeit
ist es so, gerade wenn du Ahnung hast,
du hast wirklich viele Möglichkeiten,
was IT angeht.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß von sieben Leuten dort,
wo ich aktuell arbeite, dass sie sich was Neues suchen.
Hast du schon mal was vom
Microsoft WoF-Programm gehört?
Was ist denn das
Microsoft WoF-Programm?
WoF?
Workforce of the Future!
Ne.
Kenn ich nicht.
Der Name ist schon ein bisschen cringed, oder?
Workforce
of the Future.
Upskilling.
Upskilling heißt Umschulung, oder?
Upskilling, die schöne Variante von Umschulung.
Also quasi, man nimmt
jemand und bringt ihm was bei,
was jetzt gerade sehr gefragt ist.
Ja, ja, ist so was in der Richtung.
Keine Ahnung, hab schon nie
was von gehört.
Warum die keinen bekommen? Ja, genau.
Du denkst dir schon das Richtige.
Warum die Leute niemand bekommen,
warum die Unternehmen keine bekommen,
ist doch ganz einfach.
Es ist meistens eine Kombination,
aber ist doch ganz einfach.
Ein Versuch in Kombination mit
die Stelle ist nicht interessant genug,
beziehungsweise nicht attraktiv genug.
Also irgendwas muss ja sein.
Meistens ist es halt eine Kombination daraus.
Die Stelle kann sich nach super
nervig anhören, aber sie bezahlen halt
mega krass, dann sagen trotzdem Leute
ja, egal, gib wenigstens Kohle.
Oder die Stelle hört sich gut an,
so geil,
dass die Bezahlung nicht so gut sein muss,
oder aber, so wie es hier Unternehmen machen,
die auch Leute kriegen,
die Stelle hört sich gut an
und die Bezahlung ist gut.
Und dann sagen die Leute,
ja, da geh ich doch dahin, wo beides zusammenkommt.
Ich musste hier im Chat fragen, hatten wir vorhin
ein paar Leute,
kann ich so nicht, weiß ich nicht.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich Blödsinn.
Also wenn man das wirklich so gesagt hat,
ist das natürlich bescheuert.
Von einem Azubi kannst du nicht erwarten,
dass der super, super krass die Sache macht.
Also das Einzige, wisst ihr was das Einzige ist,
was ich von einem Azubi erwarte?
Was ich von einem Azubi erwarte?
Das Einzige, ich erwarte nicht,
dass er super krasse Vorkenntnisse hat.
Oder dass der schon alles kann in der Ausbildung.
Ratet mal, was ist denn das Einzige,
was ich wirklich von einem Azubi erwarte?
Mal gucken, ob der Chat bei mir anfangen könnte.
Dass er Bock hat, richtig.
Das ist tatsächlich,
im Prinzip, ihr habt im Prinzip das alles,
ihr habt alles das Gleiche,
ihr habt alle mit unterschiedlichen Worten
das Gleiche geschrieben, dass er Bock hat.
Das ist tatsächlich die beste Beschreibung dafür,
dass er Bock hat.
Das ist tatsächlich das Einzige,
was ich vom Azubi erwarte.
Dass er Bock hat.
Der Azubi muss nichts großartiges können vorher,
er muss Bock haben,
beziehungsweise auch in der Lage sein,
das zu lernen in seiner Ausbildung.
Und dazu muss er Bock haben.
Ja gut, das ist halt Berufsschule.
Berufsschule bringt nichts.
Berufsschule ist komplett für den Arsch.
Also der, der,
wie heißt das auch so?
Der Moment, der mir am meisten
als Wirtschaftslehrer über mein DS-Ladekabel
gestolpert ist.
Das ist der Moment, der mir am meisten,
das sagt schon alles, oder?
Wenn der Moment, der dir am meisten in der Berufsschule hängen geblieben ist,
dass das Stolpern des Lehrers
über dein DS-Ladekabel ist,
dann weißt du Bescheid.
Wir haben Mario Kart Multiplayer
gespielt auf dem DS.
In der Berufsschule.
Ich musste halt aufladen.
Ja, Bundeslandbranche ist tatsächlich
sehr entscheidend. Also ich kann euch sagen,
dass der Versicherungs- und Bankensektor
in Frankfurt natürlich recht
lukraktiv ist.
Aber gibt es bestimmt auch noch mehr.
Übrigens eine Sache.
Wisst ihr, was ich gelernt habe in meinem Vorstellungsgespräch?
Wisst ihr,
zu welcher Gruppe
ich gezählt wurde?
Und zwar, ich wurde weder
als Zoomer
noch als Boomer gezählt,
sondern als, haltet euch fest,
Best Ager.
Wurde ich da,
wurde ich dazu gezählt.
Ich kannte dieses Wort bisher noch gar nicht.
Aber jetzt weiß ich. Best Ager.
Also, im Prinzip
heißt das unterm Strich,
ich bin noch nicht so alt, dass ich bald in Rente gehe,
aber ich habe schon Ahnung von dem, was ich mache.
Und so im Nachhinein ist es ja
gar nicht verkehrt, ja.
Ich bin jetzt 38.
Bin 1984 geboren.
Pock Ager.
Genau.
War nicht nice, habe ich noch nie gehört,
den Begriff vorher.
Abstand.
Ja, nix.
Mir gibt es ja noch mehrere Zwischensprünge.
Junior ist halt quasi ein Einsteiger.
Dann gibt es noch den gleichen Beruf
ohne Senior oder Junior davor.
Und dann gibt es den Beruf,
die Stelle mit Senior davor.
Also du kannst quasi, sagen wir mal so was wie
Junior Softwareentwickler sein
oder du kannst Softwareentwickler sein
oder du kannst Senior Softwareentwickler sein
oder du kannst Architekt
oder Expert oder sowas noch sein.
Wie das dann auch gesteigert werden kann.
Oder Professional.
Ja, das machen alle so ein bisschen anders.
Wisst ihr, was für mich auch
tatsächlich ein Faktor
ist, den ich beim Senior sehen würde?
Dass ein
Senior in der Lage ist,
es teamübergreifend
gut
zu, zu, zu,
wie soll ich sagen, gut zu verkaufen.
Oder besser gesagt, sich auch
teamübergreifend einbringen zu können.
Zum Beispiel,
dass da irgendeine neue
Technologie XY
gebraucht wird.
Ja, und es gibt irgendwelche Diskussionen
drüber. Die Anwendungsentwicklung
hätte gerne Produkt A,
weil es eine tolle API hat.
Easy und super Java und so.
Ja, dann hätte beispielsweise
die
BWL-Leute hätten gerne das,
weil dieses eine Feature kann
Serveradministrator
Serveradministration hätte gerne XY,
weil es besser ist, dass man sich
sowas
sinnvoll beteiligt. Ich finde,
das ist auch was,
was ich eher bei einem Senior sehen würde.
Wobei man sagen muss, ich würde es noch nicht mal
zwangsläufig rein als Kommunikationsskill
sehen, weil ihr kennt mich. Ich bin da jetzt auch, was
zwischenmenschliche Sachen angeht, vielleicht nicht unbedingt
der allerbeste immer, aber
auf technischer Ebene
kann ich glaube ich sowas mittlerweile ganz gut.
Ich präsentiere beispielsweise mittlerweile
Sachen auch gerne. Habe ich euch ja schon ein paar Mal
erzählt. Sachen, das habe ich
früher total ungern gemacht. Am Mittleren
der Weile stelle ich mich tatsächlich gerne hin und präsentiere
mal was. Das ist wirklich was, was ich auch
eher bei einer
Senior-Position sehen würde, dass man halt
auch die Sachen irgendwo gut verkaufen kann.
Und zwar unabhängig von
technischer Ahnung und sowas.
Wärst du grundsätzlich bereit, nebenberuflich
jemanden auszubilden? Das kann ich,
das darf ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht
und würde ich auch nicht machen. Wie soll ich das nebenbei machen?
Würdest du sagen, es lohnt sich auf Fullstack-Stellen
zu bewerten, wenn man als Backend-Arbeitstechniker nichts mit
schreibt? Kommt drauf an, was
die unter Fullstack verstehen.
Mein Fullstack heißt ja nicht
zwangsläufig,
zwar meistens heißt es das, aber es heißt ja
nicht zwangsläufig
Backend-Server-Anwendung
und Web-Frontend.
Zu 95%
schon, aber das muss es ja
nicht zwangsläufig heißen.
Das kommt halt drauf an, was die machen.
Und ob die TypeScript verwenden,
ist halt die Frage.
Also, ob du dich auf eine
Fullstack-Stelle bewerben solltest, hängt davon ab,
was in der Fullstack-Stelle drinsteht und
ob du denkst, das passt oder nicht.
Also, wenn die jetzt beispielsweise schreiben,
dass du als Fullstack Ahnung
von Postgres haben sollst,
Ahnung von ASP.NET Core haben sollst
und Angular beherrschen
sollst,
und du allerdings nur Laravel
und, ähm,
keine Ahnung, SQLite kannst,
dann vielleicht eher nicht.
Es muss halt
irgendwo passen. Letztendlich, ganz im Ernst,
neue Technologien
sind schnell gelernt, wenn man sich
mit ähnlichen Sachen auskennt.
Also, eine Sache,
die
viel wichtiger ist, aus meiner Sicht,
ist, dass die Leute gut
ins Team passen,
die man sich an
lacht,
auch wenn die vielleicht
nicht alle Sachen gut abdecken.
Aber teaminterne
Stimmung und dass die Leute miteinander
gut klarkommen, ist ein
nicht zu unterschätzender
Faktor. Also, ich
bin glücklicherweise nicht an dieser
Position, dass ich das entscheiden müsste,
aber ich würde lieber jemand
einstellen, der gut in
mein Team passt, als
jemand, der vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr Ahnung von den Technologien
hat, die wir verwenden,
aber wo ich schon gleich merke, das ist ein Depp
und da geht mir jetzt schon auf den Keks.
Bzw. würde nicht mit meinen Leuten klarkommen.
Weil, in Technologien eingearbeitet
bist du schnell. Stell dir mal vor,
jemand hat in seiner, bleiben wir mal bei
irgendeiner Frontend-Geschichte,
stell dir mal vor, irgendjemand sagt, er hat Erfahrung
mit
C-Sharp, ASP.NET Core
und Vue.js
und du suchst aber jemand, der Spring Boot,
Java und
ein bisschen
Frontend mit React macht.
Ja.
Das kriegt der hin, kannst du
davon ausgehen. Nicht am
ersten Tag, aber das kriegt der in relativ kurzer
Zeit hin. Gerade wenn er sich gut ins
Team einfügt und die Leute
sich gut verstehen, dann lernt er das auch schneller.
Das kriegt der hin, da würde ich mir keine Gedanken machen.
Ich meine, du kannst es nicht am ersten Tag machen.
Aber, selbst wenn, und das ist
auch ein unterschätzter Faktor, selbst
wenn du jemanden hast, der perfekt
passt von den Technologien.
Stell dir mal vor, irgendjemand verwendet
ähm,
was weiß ich, Ubuntu
als, du suchst einen Serveradmin, ja.
Ihr verwendet Ubuntu,
mit Nginx drauf als Webserver,
Postgres als Datenbank, so eine klassische,
klassische Geschichte, ja.
Und du findest jemand, der in der
Stellenanzeige exakt diese Sachen
drinnen stehen hat, auch schon super
Erfahrung. Das heißt noch lange nicht,
dass der eins zu eins am
ersten Tag volle Pulle alles
machen kann. Weil,
nur weil du von den Technologien Ahnung hast,
heißt es ja noch lange nicht,
dass du weißt, wie es in dem jeweiligen
Unternehmen benutzt wird.
Nginx ist ein Webserver, ja.
Schön und gut. Aber was machen
die genau damit? Was für Anwendungen
laufen denn dahinter? Was haben die,
äh, machen die letzten Crypt-Zertifikate?
Was brauchen die für eine Config?
Was läuft für ein Betriebssystem unten drunter?
Ähm, wie läuft
das Change-Management im jeweiligen Unternehmen
und sowas? Das weißt du alles nicht.
Das heißt, selbst wenn du Ahnung von der Technologie
hast, kannst du trotzdem nicht am ersten Tag
da was machen.
Hundertprozentig.
Also, wenn so prinzipiell das
passt, kannst du dich da durchaus drauf
bewerben. So pauschal kann man das natürlich
nicht sagen.
Das stimmt, ja.
Sowas in der Richtung ist das genau.
Was ist aus dem Monitoring-System
geworden? Aus welchem? Ähm,
ist witzigerweise dort, wo
ich aktuell arbeite, relativ ähnlich.
Den rennen die Leute gerade
weg. Und externe
kosten irgendwie das, das, keine Ahnung,
fünf- bis zehnfache.
Ich verstehe
die Logik ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
so ganz. Zumal schon total oft
das Problem gab, dass externe
richtige Know-How-Träger waren und die sind
halt einfach abgehauen.
Weil es halt externe sind.
Keine Ahnung.
Die Logik verstehe ich nicht. Da muss man wahrscheinlich
High-IQ-BWL-Management-
Ausbildung haben, um das zu verstehen.
Ja, das kann die nicht ernstgemeins haben.
So blöd ist keiner.
Hast du eigentlich ein Anschreiben machen müssen? Nein.
In beiden Fällen nicht.
Ne, in allen drei Fällen nicht.
Kein Anschreiben.
Du bist genau das. Du bist Elektro-Engineer, der programmieren kann.
Ja, bei uns gibt es auch einige
Quereinsteiger.
Es ist ein Unterschied, ob man mit Leuten im Stream redet
oder ob man mit Leuten, wo man real-life
nicht klarkommt, irgendwie
klarkommen muss, weil man jetzt
mit denen im Meeting sitzt.
Ich komme mit den meisten Leuten klar. Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Ich bin da äußerst
umgänglich. Es gibt so ein paar Sachen,
die mich nerven. Zum Beispiel, wenn
Leute irgendwie so auf
superkrassen Alpha-Mail
machen irgendwo. Also, die
an der Position überhaupt nicht sind.
Jeder kennt's. Ist irgendein Meeting,
du hast irgendeinen Typ da sitzen, der allen erzählen
will, wo es lang geht,
obwohl das überhaupt nicht sein Job ist,
an der Stelle. Das geht mir mega auf
den Keks, Alter.
Die dann irgendwie so
so möchte
gern Giga-Chat auftreten.
Gibt es immer noch, ja?
Den gibt es immer noch.
Da ist er.
Aber ich hab den Zugang
nicht mehr. Ich hab den Zugang verloren.
Zu
LinkedIn. Und das, obwohl
ich dort Cloud Native Agile
GitHub Solution Chief Engineer Officer
bin, Mann.
Hast du Erfahrung mit CCNA? Ja, ich hab mal
einen CCNA gemacht in meiner Ausbildung.
Kein Plan mehr von.
Also, wenn du eine Stelle gefunden
hast, die nahezu 1 zu 1 auf dich
zutrifft, dann bewirb dich da.
Ob es manche Punkte gibt,
die nicht
zutreffen, das ist egal.
Die freuen sich schon, wenn sie einen Bewerber finden, der
auch nur 70, 80 Prozent hat.
Und das andere kriegst du easy.
Wenn du Ahnung hast von
irgendwas in dieser Richtung,
arbeitest du dich da easy ein. Ich würde mich da auf jeden Fall
drauf bewerben. Wenn dir das gefällt.
Keine Ahnung, ich bin nicht bei
LinkedIn und Xing.
Ich kann dir sagen,
was mein Kollege bekommt, der bekommt irgendwie
30 Stück in der Woche oder so.
Oder war es am Tag? Ne, ich glaube in der Woche.
Er hat letzte Woche irgendwie 30 Stück gekriegt.
Das ist halt vieles
unbrauchbare Kram dabei.
Ja, 30 Stück.
Ich glaube, es war die Woche.
Plutscht. Die suchen alle wie
verrückt. Sind auch oftmals die gleichen.
So.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du mich meinst.
Ich verstehe, warum externe
5-10 mal so viel kosten.
Also, die verdienen ja auch gar nicht 5-10 mal so viel.
Warum externe 5-10 mal so viel
kosten, ist ja, der Typ an sich ist nicht billig.
Der verdient auch sicherlich
mehr. Aber da sind dann noch 2-3
Vermittler dazwischen.
Und das kostet Geld. Und außerdem
müssen sie sich das bezahlen lassen,
dass sie von heute auf morgen
nicht mehr da sein können. Ja doch, mir ist das
vollkommen klar, warum externe
Leute mehr verdienen. Warum
man allerdings den Anteil der externen
oftmals so hoch, quasi
so hoch schraubt,
anstatt zu gucken, dass die eigenen Leute da
bleiben, das erleuchtet mir bei
meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber weniger ein.
Weil man könnte ja durchaus dafür sorgen,
dass die eigenen Leute da bleiben.
Wenn man da manche Sachen
machen würde,
die sauer aufstoßen.
Das ist tatsächlich schwierig.
Bekannter, um 3 Ecken
Leute, wirklich bekannter, also
der Mann von
der Tochter von der Freundin
von meiner Mutter, also Leute, das ist
wirklich weird champ
Bekanntschaft um 50 Ecken.
Der macht gerade eine Umschulung
zum Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung.
Und der hat mich gefragt,
ob ich mal bei uns anfragen könnte,
ob er dort sein Praktikum machen kann.
Weil die müssen wohl irgendwie 9 Monate Praktikum
machen, dass sie ihre
Abschlussprüfung schreiben dürfen, irgendwie sowas.
Habe ich gefragt bei unserer, bei unserem
Ausbildungs
Ausbildungschef oder
Ausbildungsabteilung da,
die das halt machen. Und
die haben ewig gebraucht. Denn im Endeffekt
haben sie abgesagt und ich habe halt einfach die
Vermutung, sie haben nicht abgesagt, weil es wirklich
keine Möglichkeiten gibt, sondern
weil sie schlicht und ergreifend keinen Bock hatten, sich drum zu kümmern.
Weil ich war dann hartnäckig und habe
mehrfach noch nachgefragt, auch über meinen Chef
und dann wurde mir einfach abgesagt.
Ne, geht nicht. Ich glaube, die hatten schlicht und ergreifend keinen Bock.
Und da muss man sich nicht wundern,
wenn man nicht ausbilden will, beziehungsweise
Leute, mehr oder weniger, die fast schon fertig sind,
auf dem Servierteller präsentiert
bekommt und die nicht, die nicht
will, da muss man sich halt nicht wundern,
wenn man auch irgendwo keine Leute mehr hat irgendwann.
Richtig, genau.
Das kannst du, das kannst du mit externen Leuten
so machen. Blöd ist es halt natürlich
nur, wenn man externe Leute
hat, die wichtige Sachen
umsetzen, die dann rausschmeißt
und feststellt, Mist, wir
haben ja niemand, der sich mit dem Kram mehr auskennt.
Weil mit dem
Rausschmiss des externen quasi die Ahnung
über diesen Service auch komplett mit rausgeschmissen
wurde. Das ist dann aber ein Management-Fail.
Ja, ganz klar.
Naja. Leute, viereinhalb Stunden,
guck mal, 420 haben wir jetzt.
Ich bin jetzt 4 Stunden 20 Minuten am
Stream. Ich gehe jetzt off.
Was fordern? Wir haben ganz schön
lange geschwätzt jetzt noch. Wir haben über,
über eineinhalb Stunden, glaube ich, einfach jetzt nur über das,
über IT und Job und sonst
was geredet.
Aber musste anscheinend auch mal sein.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream, Leute.
Macht's gut, bis denn. Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich hab übelst Hunger. Macht's gut, bis denn.
See you.